SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN, I'LL RODA-GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. DALLY DODD. DURAZO
EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ. GROVE.
OTERO JONES. LAIRD LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE MINGYUAN. MINH NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OKOBO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER. WILK
MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WHAT? OUR MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS.
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY. PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED
IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. AS WE GATHER IN GOD'S
PRESENCE AGAIN, O GOD OF PEACE,
WE SEEK ENERGY FOR OUR SPIRITS
AND LIGHT FOR OUR THOUGHTS. WE
BRING OUR WORK TO BE SANCTIFIED,
OUR WOUNDS TO BE HEALED, OUR
HOPES TO BE RENEWED. YOU IN WHOM
ALL ARE ONE, FILL US WITH THE
FULLNESS OF YOUR LOVE. RAISE US
BEYOND THE LIMITS OF OUR DAILY
IMPERFECTIONS. SEND US VISIONS
OF THE LOVE THAT IS IN YOU AND
OF THE GOOD THAT WILL BE
ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH US. YOUR
GREATNESS IS BEYOND OUR PRAISE.
AMEN. MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
UNITED SIX AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. ALL RIGHT. NOW,
MOVING THE PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. FILE 15 AB 2348, FILE 16,
AB 3121. PURSUANT TO RULE 29.10,
D, THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES, FILE 59 SB 918 AND FILE
82, SB 1143. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. WE'RE AT SECOND
READING FILE. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 224 518 535
1034 2095 1843 2930, 1252, 1831,
24, 71. THE SECOND READING IS
DEEMED READ NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM 20 BY
SENATOR UMBERG. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ THE
SENATE BILL 901 BY SENATOR
UMBERG. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
MILITARY. SENATOR UMBERG, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES. THIS BILL SIMPLY
SAYS THAT IF YOU ARE A MEMBER OF
ANTIFA OR YOU'RE A MEMBER OF
ANOTHER ORGANIZATION THAT
BELIEVES THAT THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE OVERTHROWN, WHETHER
IT'S THE GOVERNMENT OF
CALIFORNIA OR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, THEN YOU CANNOT BE
TRAINED IN LETHAL FORCE BY THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD OR THE
STATE GUARD. I URGE, AND I VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 20.
ALAN I ALVARADO. GILL I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY
DODD I DURAZO EGGMAN I GLASER I
GONZALEZ. GROVE OTERO I JONES.
LAIRD I LEMON. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR
I MIN I NEWMAN. I NGUYEN. NILO
OKUBO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. SKINNER
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN. I UMBERG
I WAHAB I WIENER WILK.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DAWLEY TERRAZAS.
GONZALEZ I GROVE. JONES LEMON.
I. MCGUIRE NGUYEN. NILO OKUBO.
SATO SKINNER. WIENER. WILK.
WIENER I. SENATOR UMBERG MOVES
TO CALL NEXT. MEMBERS. WE'RE
MOVING ON TO ITEM 25 BY SENATOR
PADILLA. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ THE.
SENATE BILL 764 BY SENATOR
PADILLA. AN ACT RELATING TO
MINORS. SENATOR PADILLA, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. SB 764 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WITH MINOR
AMENDMENTS FROM THE ASSEMBLY TO
GIVE IT CONSISTENCY WITH
EXISTING STATUTE. SENATE BILL
764 WOULD REQUIRE FAMILY CONTENT
CREATORS WHO ARE COMPENSATED FOR
FILMING THEIR MINOR CHILDREN IN
MORE THAN 30% OF THEIR CONTENT,
TO SET ASIDE A PERCENTAGE OF
THEIR EARNINGS IN THE TRUST FOR
THE BENEFIT OF THEIR MINOR WHEN
THEY REACH THE AGE OF MAJORITY.
IT BUILDS ON THE KUGANAK, WHICH
BECAME THE NATIONAL STANDARD IN
PROTECTING CHILDREN FROM
FINANCIAL ABUSE IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. AFTER
FAMOUS CHILD ACTOR JACKIE COOGAN
HAD HIS EARNINGS STOLEN FROM HIS
GUARDIANS AS SOCIAL MEDIA
BECOMES EVEN MORE INTEGRATED
INTO OUR DAILY LIFE AND A
GROWING SHARE OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT LANDSCAPE, WE NEED
TO UPDATE OUR HARD FOUGHT LABOR
PROTECTIONS AND SAFEGUARDS TO
PROTECT THE FINANCIAL
PERFORMANCE OF THESE CHILDREN
AND THEIR FUTURE. 764 WOULD
RECOGNIZE THAT CHILDREN DESERVE
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
COMPENSATION FOR BEING FILMED
AND GENERATING REVENUE FOR THEIR
FAMILY. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
REQUIRE 65% OF THE EARNINGS MUST
BE PUT IN A TRUST, ALONG WITH
OTHER CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL HAS HAD BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 25. ALAN I RODA-GIL I
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALI. DODD
I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLASER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. OTERO I JONES.
LAIRD I LIMON I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR
I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NILO
OKOBO I PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DAWLEY
GROVE I JONES I MCGUIRE NGUYEN I
NILO SERRATO. WE'RE GOING TO
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. DAWLEY MCGUIRE. NILO I
SATO. SENATOR PADILLA MOVES THE
CALL. Þ. ALL RIGHT, WE'LL SHUT
IT DOWN. ALL RIGHT. AGE 37. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES AND
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 27. SENATOR
WIENER, HE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ THE SENATE BILL 960
BY SENATOR WIENER. AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION.
SENATOR WIENER, I THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. OUR COLLEAGUES, SB
960 IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THIS
BILL IMPROVES THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF COMPLETE STREETS FACILITIES
FOR PEDESTRIANS, CYCLISTS AND
TRANSIT RIDERS ON CALTRANS
PROJECTS ON STATE OWNED ROADS.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS REPRESENT AN
AGREEMENT WITH CALTRANS AND
RELEVANT POLICY AND FISCAL
COMMITTEES. ALL TRANSPORTATION,
LABOR, AND CONTRACTOR GROUPS
WENT NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AFTER
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE HEARING. THESE
AMENDMENTS IMPROVE OVERSIGHT
OVER COMPLETE STREETS FACILITY
IMPLEMENTATION, IMPROVE THE
DEPARTMENT'S COMPLETE STREETS
INVESTMENT TARGET PRACTICES, AND
DIRECT CALTRANS TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION ON THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 27. ALLEN A BILL NØ
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ DALLY. NØ DODD. AYE.
DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN GLASER.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR MEN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NO COBO. NO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH I RUBIO.
AYE. SATO. NO SKINNER I CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE OF
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA AYE. ORTEZ
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE AYES 31. NOES
NINE. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM 28.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 1067 BY SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS AND ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS. SENATOR, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND GOOD MORNING,
COLLEAGUES. THIS MORNING I AM
PRESENTING SB 1067, WHICH IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THIS IS A
BILL TO EXPEDITE LICENSURE FOR
HEALTH CARE PRACTITIONERS WHO
WILL BE PROVIDING MEDICAL
SERVICE IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AND FALL. ITEM 28. ALLEN I
ALVARADO. GILL I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEAR I BRADFORD I GUERRERO I
CORTEZ I DALI I DODD. I DURAZO.
EGGMAN GLASER I GONZALEZ. GROVE
I OTERO I JONES, I LAIRD I LIMON
I MCGUIRE. I MENGIBAR I MEAN.
NEWMAN I NGUYEN, I NILO. EBCLC I
PURDUE, I PORTANTINO, I ROTH, I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN. UMBERG I WAHAB I
WEINER I WILK I SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
DURAZO I EGGMAN I GONZALEZ. I
MIN I NILO STERN I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. GONZALEZ I NILO. AYES 39.
NÓ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED IN NOW. MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM 29,
SENATOR ROTH. HE'S READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 1249 BY SENATOR ROTH. AN
ACT RELATING TO OLDER ADULTS.
SENATOR ROTH, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS INCORPORATE THE
LANGUAGE FROM HB 2636 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAYNES. WITH
THAT OF THIS BILL IMPACTING THE
SAME SECTIONS OF THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT, ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS ADD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAYNES AS A PRINCIPAL COAUTHOR,
OUR TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING IN
NATURE. PLEASE VOTE AYE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY. CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
29. ALAN I RODA-GIL I ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER. I
BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALI DODD I
DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LOWMAN I MAGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MEAN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN I NILO I DROBO I PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SATO I SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER
I WILK I SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS DALI GROVE
AYES 38 NO. ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 32.
SENATOR WIENER HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 532 BY SENATOR WIENER AN
ACT RELATING TO VEHICLES.
SENATOR WIENER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. I THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. I RISE
TO PRESENT SB 532, WHICH
MODERNIZES PARKING PAYMENTS BY
AUTHORIZING, BUT NOT REQUIRING A
FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM IN SAN
FRANCISCO, LONG BEACH AND SANTA
MONICA TO IMPLEMENT PAID PARKING
WITHOUT HAVING TO INCUR THE HIGH
COST OF PHYSICAL METERS. CURRENT
LAW EFFECTIVELY REQUIRES CITIES
TO SPEND SIGNIFICANT, LIMITED
RESOURCES PURCHASING,
INSTALLING, AND MAINTAINING
OUTDATED AND EXPENSIVE PARKING
METER EQUIPMENT. PARKING METERS
ALSO CAN IMPEDE PASSAGE FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
TAKE UP VALUABLE SIDEWALK SPACE
THAT COULD BE REPURPOSED FOR
OTHER USES. SB 532 ADDRESSES
THESE CHALLENGES BY ALLOWING THE
THREE PILOT CITIES TO PILOT A
PAY BY PHONE ONLY ZONE, PROVIDED
THAT THE CITY PROVIDES SIGNAGE
IN SUCH ZONES AND WORKS WITH
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS TO IMPLEMENT
REASONABLY ACCESSIBLE MEANS FOR
CASH PAYMENTS OF PARKING FEES.
THE REQUIREMENT FOR THIS PILOT
IS STRONGER THAN EXISTING LAW,
WHICH DOES NOT REQUIRE PHYSICAL
PARKING METERS TO ACCEPT CASH
PAYMENTS AT ALL. FINALLY, THE
BILL CAPS THE MAXIMUM CITATION
FOR THOSE WHO DO NOT PAY AT ALL
FOR PARKING IN SUCH ZONES. AT
50% OF THE REGULAR CITATION
COSTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING
AND SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON. FINAL
ITEM 32. ALLEN I RODA-GIL NO.
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALI DODD I
DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE NO ODATO I
JONES NO. LAIRD I LEMON I
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN NO NILO I OCHOA EBCLC.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO. CIERTO I SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLEY NO. MCGUIRE OCHOA. RUBIO
HI. AYES 33. NOES FIVE. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 33. SENATOR
LAMONT. SENATOR LAMONT, SHE'S
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 639 BY SENATOR LIMÓN
AN ACT RELATING THE HEALING
ARTS. SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. SB 639 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE BILL ENSURES
THAT HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
ARE EQUIPPED FOR DEMENTIA
DETECTION AND DIAGNOSIS
STATEWIDE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 33. ALLEN AYE. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALI
DODD. AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES NØ.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. EBCLC. AYE Dð. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH I RUBIO.
AYE SEYARTO. SKINNER HI. SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALY. NO GROVE. MCGUIRE
MENDOZA. MIN AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
SEYARTO. GROVE. NO. AYES 33.
NOES THREE. THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW. MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM 34. WITH
THAT, SENATOR DODD IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ THE
SENATE BILL 295 BY SENATOR DODD
AND ACT TO BAR PILOTS AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE,
SENATOR DODD, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. YOU'RE DOING A REALLY
GREAT JOB. PRESIDENT MEMBERS,
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB 295
REGARDING THE PILOT BOAT
SURCHARGE ACCOUNT, WHICH IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL WOULD
REMOVE THE STATUTORILY
ESTABLISHED CAPS AND ALLOW
UNSPENT FUNDS TO CARRY FORWARD
TO FUTURE FISCAL YEARS,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FARM 34 OAN. AYE BOB. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLI
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. MIN NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. AYE AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO ACIERTO. AYE. SKINNER A
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG I WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DURAZZO AYE. GLAZER
AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. I MEAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYES 38. NOES ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK FOR YOUR ATTENTION
FOR A MINUTE. WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE FORMER STATE SENATOR
FROM THE STATE OF WASHINGTON.
RAVEN CARLISLE, WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 37 BY
SENATOR ALLEN. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ THE
SENATE BILL 285 BY SENATOR
ALLEN, AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE. SENATOR
ALLEN. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. IN 2017, 2019, THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE RISE ACT.
WE VOTED FOR. THESE WERE
AUTHORED BY SENATORS MITCHELL
LARA AND WIENER. THEY
PROSPECTIVELY REPEALED THE
APPLICATION OF CERTAIN SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS. I THEN AUTHORED IN
2021, SB 483, THAT CREATED THE
PROCESS TO REMOVE THOSE NOW
INVALID SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT NO ONE WAS SERVING
EXTRA TIME, YOU KNOW,
UNNECESSARILY AND UNRESPONSIVELY.
OUR OFFICE HAS HEARD MANY
STORIES OF THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
GIVEN BACK YEARS OF THEIR LIVES.
THEY'RE MAKING THE MOST OF IT.
AND I'M REALLY PROUD OF ALL OF
THE SUCCESSES FROM MY SB 483.
UNFORTUNATELY, A SMALL BUT BUT
BUT VERY REAL GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO CONVICTED OF VIOLENT AND
HEINOUS CRIMES WERE ALSO
UNINTENTIONALLY MADE ELIGIBLE
FOR RESENTENCING UNDER SB 483,
AND THIS BILL, SB 285, INTENDS
TO RIGHT THIS ERROR BY
CLARIFYING THAT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN SENTENCED TO DEATH OR LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE, AND THEY'VE BEEN
CONVICTED FOR A SEXUAL, VIOLENT
OFFENSE ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
RESENTENCING UNDER MY SB 483.
THE BILL WILL NOT RETROACTIVELY
AFFECT ANYONE WHO'S ALREADY BEEN
RESENTENCED UNDER THE BILL, BUT
THIS IS ULTIMATELY ABOUT
REDUCING CASELOADS AND LIMITING
THE RETRAUMATISATION OF VICTIMS
AND THEIR FAMILIES
UNNECESSARILY. AND SO WITH THAT,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 37. ALLEN A
BILL A ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DELHI AYE. DODD I
DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. MEN HI I NEWMAN I
WAYNE I NILO I OCHOA. I PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
CIERTO SKINNER SARAH Tð I
SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS. STERN I
UMBERG I WAHAB. WIENER I WILK I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR I SMALL CUEVAS
WAHAB I. AYES 38 NO. ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN NOW MEMBERS. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 40
BY SENATOR DODD. SECRETARY. YOU
MAY READ SENATE BILL 278 BY
SENATOR DODD AND RELATING TO
ELDER ABUSE, SENATOR DODD. MR.
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS SB 278
PERTAINING TO ELDER FINANCIAL
ABUSE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TO NOTIFY
AN EMERGENCY FINANCIAL CONTACT
OF SUSPECTED ABUSE OF A SENIOR
IF A TRUSTED CONTACT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED, AND TO DELAY BY THREE
DAYS A TRANSACTION WHERE THE
BANKS REASONABLY SUSPECT ABUSE.
AMENDMENTS PROVIDE BANKS AND
CREDIT UNIONS WITH WILD EXCUSE
ME, WITH LIABILITY PROTECTIONS.
AMENDMENTS TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION BY ONE YEAR TO
ALLOW THE BANKS TO WORK SOME
SITUATIONS OUT. AMENDMENTS ALSO
INCLUDE ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS
FOR ANY INSTITUTION THAT
REPEATEDLY VIOLATES THE LAW, AND
THE AMENDMENTS PROVIDE THAT. IF
THE APPLICATION OF THE
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS ARE HELD
INVALID FOR ONE COVERED ENTITY,
THE ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS ARE
INVALID FOR ALL. THERE IS NO
LONGER ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 40. ALAN I ALVARADO.
GILL I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKESBERG I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ GROVE HURTADO
I JONES NO LAIRD I LEMON I
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I ADMIN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN NILO JOBO
PADILLA I PORTANTINO IRA I RUBIO
I SAITO SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG WAHAB I WIENER I
WILK I SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLEY
GONZALEZ I GROVE. MCGUIRE NGUYEN.
NILO COBO. CIERTO UMBERG I. I 32
NOES ONE. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED AND NOW
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM
44. SENATOR DURAZO. SHE IS
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 227 BY SENATOR
DURAZO. AN ACT RELATING TO
UNEMPLOYMENT. SENATOR DURAZO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SB 227
AMENDMENTS REQUIRE THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP A DETAILED
PLAN TO ESTABLISH A PERMANENT
EXCLUDED WORKERS PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE CASH ASSISTANCE TO
WORKERS WHO ARE EXCLUDED FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SOLELY
DUE TO THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS
AS EXTREME HEAT AND WILDFIRES
CONTINUE TO AFFECT THE STATE,
ALL CALIFORNIANS, REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY WERE BORN, DESERVE
ACCESS TO A SAFETY NET WHEN THEY
ARE DISPLACED AND OUT OF WORK. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 44. ALAN I GÒM
NÓ ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DEL NØ DODD
I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE NÓ HURTADO I
JONES NØ. LAIRD I LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN. NEWMAN
I WAYNE NÓ. NILO NØ. JOBO NØ.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. NO SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK NÓ.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BLAKE SPEER.
MCGUIRE. MEN FIVE. EYES. EYES
29. NOES NINE. THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 45 BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SHE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ THE
SENATE BILL 254 BY SENATOR
SKINNER. AN ACT RELATING TO
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, SB 254 IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
ENSURE SAFETY AND MINIMIZE
DISRUPTIONS AND PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF VISITORS AND STAFF
AND DELAYS THE IMPLEMENTATION.
SB 254 HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 45. ALLEN I GILL.
ARCHULETA I, ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DEL NØ DODD
I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE NÓ O'DONNELL.
NØ JONES. NØ. LAIRD I LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MAN I NEWMAN.
I NGUYEN. NØ NILO. NÓ. JOBO NØ.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SEYARTO NØ. SKINNER I.
SMALL CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG. I
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK. NØ
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GILL.
NO BLAKE. SPEER I MCGUIRE. AYES
29. NO'S TEN. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM 47.
SENATOR ATKINS. SHE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 450 BY SENATOR ATKINS. AN
ACCOLADE TO LAND USE. SENATOR
ATKINS, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 450 IS
BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
CONCURRENCE. THE BILL WAS
AMENDED TO REFLECT THE CHANGES
TO THE CODE SECTION THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE SINCE LAST YEAR AND
REMOVED PROVISIONS THAT WERE
ADDRESSED IN LEGISLATION IN THE
2023 SESSION. ADDITIONALLY,
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS WERE
ADDED TO CLARIFY THAT SB NINE IS
MEANT TO HELP ALLEVIATE OUR
HOUSING CRISIS BY CREATING A WAY
FOR HOMEOWNERS TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. SB
450 WILL INCREASE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF SB NINE BY
IMPROVING ACCESS AND CERTAINTY.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, AND
CERTAINTY FOR HOMEOWNERS WHO
WISH TO USE THE PROVISIONS OF
THAT LAW. AND IT INCREASES THE
ENFORCEMENT OF EXISTING LAW. I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FINAL ITEM 47. ALLEN, A GILL.
ARCHULETA VÌ ASHBY. Ã ATKINS I
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO. I. CORTEZ I. DALY
NØ. DODD I DORADO I EGGMAN. I
GLAZER I NØ GONZALEZ I GROVE NØ
O'DONNELL I JONES NØ. LAIRD I
LEMON I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN
I NEWMAN I NGUYEN NØ. NEELAM NO
JOBO NO PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO NO SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK. NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MEMBERS. AL
RODA-GIL I BECKER. MCGUIRE.
PORTANTINO. I AYES 28. NOES
NINE. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED AND NOW MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 51.
SENATOR GLAZIER. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ THE
SENATE BILL 597 BY SENATOR
GLAZER. AN ACT RELATING TO
RAINWATER CATCHMENT SYSTEMS.
SENATOR GLAZIER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS. WHILE
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD THE WETTEST
WINTERS ON RECORD OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, OUR STATE STILL
FACING A WATER CRISIS
EXACERBATED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
RESEARCH AND AUTHORIZE BUILDING
STANDARDS, AND TO PROPOSE
BUILDING STANDARDS TO INCREASE
THE INSTALLATION OF RAINWATER
CAPTURE SYSTEMS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS MOVE THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE OUT TO
JANUARY 1ST, 2027. AUTHORIZES
HCD TO PROPOSE VOLUNTARY
BUILDING STANDARDS AND CLARIFY
THAT THE BUILDING STANDARDS
SHOULD APPLY STATEWIDE. WITH
THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? SENATOR
JONES. GOOD MORNING, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB 597. AND IN FACT,
CALIFORNIA'S A LITTLE BIT BEHIND
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY ON THIS.
I REMEMBER, TOURING NEW HOMES IN
DENVER, COLORADO, PROBABLY OVER
20 YEARS AGO, AND THEY WERE
ALREADY DOING THESE RAINWATER
CAPTURE SYSTEMS. I'M SURE THAT
THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE EFFORTS
SINCE THEN HAVE BEEN IMPROVED,
AND SO I THINK CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BE LOOKING INTO THIS AS WELL. I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SB 597.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING? NONE. SENATOR GLAZIER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM
SANTEE FOR MAKING THE POINT THAT
IS IMPORTANT IN AUSTRALIA, 40%
OF THE HOMES HAVE RAINWATER
CAPTURE SYSTEMS ON THEM, 40% IN
AUSTRALIA, WE ARE BEHIND THE
TIMES WE NEED TO CATCH UP. THIS
BILL WILL HELP THAT. WITH THAT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON LINE 51
OAN. AYE ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBURG
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY AYE. DODD
AYE. DARAZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
AYE. ODODO. AYE. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NÓ NEELO. AYE. OJOBO
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER A SMALL CREVICE.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE. AYE
AMBURGEY. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE.
OCHOA EBCLC. OCHOA. B¢O. GUY
AYES 38. NOES ONE. THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 52.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 729 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. SENATOR,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS, MR.
PRESIDENT. LOOK AWAY. I MIGHT
BLIND YOU, BUT I'M RISING
BECAUSE SB 729 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
REALLY NARROWED IT AND DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION FOR CALPERS TO
2027. PRIVATE LARGE GROUPS SIX
MONTHS TO JULY OF 2025
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
BECAUSE I'M BLIND, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALL RIGHT.
GIL NÓ ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE ATKINS. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALI. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES
NØ. LAIRD. AYE LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MEN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO NO COBO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK NO. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS. AYE BECKMAN. AYE. GROVE
NO. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE WAYNE.
NO OKOBO. UMBERG AYE. AYES 30.
NOES EIGHT. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW. MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 57.
SENATOR ROTH. MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THAT YOU TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATION OFF THE FLOOR. IT'S
HARD TO HEAR RIGHT NOW.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 902 BY SENATOR ROTH, AN ACT
RELATING TO FIREARMS. SENATOR
ROTH, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. ON
CONCURRENCE, THIS BILL ENSURES
THE MOST SERIOUS ANIMAL ABUSERS
ARE PROHIBITED FROM OWNING OR
POSSESSING A FIREARM FOR TEN
YEARS. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
REMOVED THE FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS SECTION FROM THE
BILL TO ENSURE THAT THE BILL
MAINTAINS A NARROW SCOPE. BILL
HAS BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AS
FOR AN AYE VOTE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 57. ALLEN I, GILL I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLI
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE HURTADO I
JONES NØ LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE.
MENJIVAR I MIN I NEWMAN I WAYNE.
I MILO I OKOBO I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO
I SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN
I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS DALLY NO GROVE. MCGUIRE.
WILK I. GROVE. NO. AYES 36. NOES
THREE. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO SENATOR
BECKER. FILE ITEM 61. SECRETARY,
YOU MAY READ THE SENATE BILL 942
BY SENATOR BECKER. AN ACT
RELATING TO CONSUMER PROTECTION.
SENATOR BECKER, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, 942 IS
BACK ON CONFIRMED CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A CLEAR
FRAMEWORK TO HELP CALIFORNIANS
IDENTIFY AI GENERATED CONTENT.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS, DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL TO
2026, MAKE SOME CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO ENSURE TECHNICALLY
FEASIBLE AND REASONABLE
TIMELINES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR. I VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 61. ALAN I ALVARO. GIL I
ARCHULETA, I ASHBY I ATKINS, I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALI DODD I
DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE HURTADO I JONES
NØ LAIRD I LEMON I MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I WAYNE
I MILO, I OKUBO I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO
SKINNER. I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN
I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK
NÓ. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DOLLY GROVE.
MCGUIRE. STELLATO. AYES 34. NOES
TWO. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FALL. ITEM 62. SENATOR
WIENER IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
YOU MAY READ THE SENATE BILL 957
BY SENATOR WIENER. AN ACT
RELATING TO DATA COLLECTION.
SENATOR WIENER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. I THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 957 IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THIS HAS TO
DO WITH COLLECTION OF HEALTH
DATA REGARDING SEXUAL
ORIENTATION, GENDER IDENTITY.
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY WERE
LARGELY TECHNICAL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. YOU MAY CALL THE
ROLL AND FILE ITEM 62. ALLEN I
ALVARADO. GILMAN NØ ARCHULETA I,
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLI. DODD
I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLASER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. NØ. HURTADO I
JONES. Þ. NØ. LAIRD I LIMON I
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MEAN I
NEWMAN I WAYNE. NO. NILO NO.
OJOBO NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. NO SKINNER
I SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLI. NO MCGUIRE. AYES 30. NOES
NINE. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED AND NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO ITEM 64. THAT'S
SENATOR WIENER AGAIN. HE IS
READY TO GO. SECRETARY MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 966 BY SENATOR
WIENER AND AQUILINA. AN PHARMACY
BENEFITS. SENATOR WIENER I THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SB 966 IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL,
IF YOU'LL RECALL, RECEIVED A
UNANIMOUS VOTE ON THIS FLOOR AND
HOUSE OF ORIGIN ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE
PROHIBITION ON SPREAD PRICING,
EXEMPT COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED
TAFT-HARTLEY PLANS REQUIRE PBMS
TO DISCLOSE THE AMOUNT AND TYPE
OF FEES CHARGED FOR THEIR
SERVICES TO THE HEALTH PLAN, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 64. OAN I
RODRIGO ARCHULETA, I ASHBY, I
ATKINS, I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY I DODD I RUSSELL I EGGMAN
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO I JONES LAIRD I LOWMAN I
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MAN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN I NILO I IDROBO I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS, I'LL GO NØ
JONES MCGUIRE. AYES 37 NOES ONE.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 65 AND 66
BY SENATOR WAHAB. SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM 65, SENATE BILL 983 BY
SENATOR WAHAB. AN ACT RELATING
TO ENERGY. SENATOR WAHAB, THANK
YOU. SB 983, THE ALTERNATIVE
FUELS INFRASTRUCTURE TASK FORCE
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH THE ALTERNATIVE
FUELS INFRASTRUCTURE TASK FORCE
TO DETERMINE HOW CALIFORNIA CAN
ADD ALTERNATIVE FUEL OPTIONS TO
GAS STATIONS AND ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN RELY ON CLEAN
ENERGY FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE ARE NOT BETTING ON
TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE BETTING ON
INFRASTRUCTURE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING
AND SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 65.
ALLEN A GILL AYE. ARCHULETA I
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DORADO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE HURTADO
I. JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. MILO OKOBO.
AYE. BIÂU. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO I SATO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. UMBERG BY WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BECKER LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN MILO. STERN. AGE 35. NOES
ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN SENATOR ROSSUM,
YOU HAVE FILED ITEM 66. SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ THE SENATE BILL 984 BY
SENATOR WAHAB. AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS. SENATOR
WAHAB, THANK YOU. SB 984 PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND THE CALIFORNIA COURTS TO
IDENTIFY THREE MAJOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS TO BE
GOVERNED BY A PLA. AMENDMENTS
REFLECT AN AGREEMENT REACHED
WITH THE SPONSORS AND
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 66. OAN. AYE RODRIGO
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
GUERRERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALI.
NÓ. DODD AYE. DARAZO AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER NO. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO HURTADO. AYE. JONES
NO. NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NO
JOBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
ACIERTO NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE AYE.
UMBERG I. WAHAB AYE. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MEMBERS. GILL. NO MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN AYES 30. NOES EIGHT. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 69 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. HE HAS PREPARED
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ THE
SENATE BILL 1006 BY SENATOR
PADILLA. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY. SENATOR PADILLA,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1006. IT IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
IT REQUIRES UTILITIES TO PREPARE
A GRID ENHANCING TECHNOLOGIES
AND CONDUCTING STUDY TO INCREASE
CAPACITY AND COST EFFICIENCY.
THESE TECHNOLOGIES CAN INCREASE
CAPACITY FASTER AT A FAR CHEAPER
RATE THAN NEW LINES, REDUCING
COSTS FOR RATEPAYERS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS NARROW THE BILL FROM
A STRATEGIC PLAN TO A STUDY
SPILL HAS BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. HAS HAD ZERO NO VOTES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON ITEM 69. ALAN AYE GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. IGHODARO.
AYE JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE NILO. IACOVO. AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO I ROTH.
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG HI. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DURAZZO. AYE. GWYER. SMALL
CUEVAS. AYE AYES 39. NOES ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED. AND NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 71. SENATOR
WIENER, HE IS READY TO GO.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 1047 BY SENATOR WIENER. AN
ACT RELATING TO ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. SENATOR WIENER.
AYE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 1047
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS, RESTRUCTURED PARTS
OF THE BILL AND SIGNIFICANTLY
NARROWED REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED ON
DEVELOPERS. CHANGES INCLUDE
AROUND CIVIL PENALTIES.
ELIMINATION OF CERTAIN CRIMINAL
PENALTIES, SIMPLIFICATION OF
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF, RELYING ON AN
EXISTING AGENCY INSTEAD OF A NEW
AGENCY AS WELL AS OTHER
AMENDMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 71. ALAN Ã ALVARADO NØ
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS. I
BECKER. BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. I CORTEZ I DAWLEY
DODD I DURAZZO. I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE NØ.
HURTADO I JONES NÓ. LAIRD I
LEMON. I MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MAN
NEWMAN. I WAYNE NÓ. NIELSEN NO.
JABO. NO PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. NO. SKINNER
I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER
NÓ NØ. DALLEY. NO MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN. AGE 29. NOES
NINE. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 72. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1050. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1050 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SB 1050 IS BACK FOR
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A PATHWAY TO RETURN
LAND OR PROVIDE RESTITUTION TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE HAD THEIR
LAND OR THEIR PROPERTY TAKEN BY
RACIALLY MOTIVATED REASONS,
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID A FEW
YEARS AGO WITH BRUCE'S BEACH
ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS CHANGE THE
RESPONSIBILITY RESPONSIBLE PARTY
FROM THE STATE TO THE ACTUAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITY THAT COMMITTED
THE RACIALLY MOTIVATED ACT.
AMENDMENTS ALSO REMOVE THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
SPECIFICALLY FOR CLAIMS OF
RACIALLY MOTIVATED ABUSES OF
EMINENT DOMAIN. THE BILL
PROTECTS PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS, MEANING THAT LAND THAT
IS CURRENTLY IN PRIVATE HANDS
WITH GOOD FAITH OWNERS COULD NOT
BE RECLAIMED. THESE CHANGES STAY
TRUE TO THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF
THE BILL OF CREATING A PATH TO
JUSTICE FOR VICTIMS OF RACIALLY
MOTIVATED TAKINGS, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OH, EXCUSE ME, PARDON ME. I SEE
A HAND FROM THE SENATOR FROM
FAIR OAKS. WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RISE, SIR, TO SPEAK TO THE BILL?
I SUPPOSE I'M JUST TOO FAR TO
YOUR RIGHT FOR YOU TO SEE ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT WAS THE
PRESIDENT, I THINK THE BLING WAS
SHINING IN MY EYES WHEN THIS
BILL WAS ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED.
I OPPOSED IT AND I SPOKE TO IT
CERTAINLY IN COMMITTEE. AND I
THINK ON THE FLOOR, MY CONCERN
WAS THAT THE OBLIGATION OF
RESTITUTION LAID WITH THE STATE,
THAT IS TO SAY, TAXPAYERS FROM
COLUSA WOULD POTENTIALLY
CONTRIBUTE IN CONTRIBUTING TO
THE RESTITUTION OF A RACIALLY
MOTIVATED TAKE THAT HAPPENED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THE AUTHOR
HAS ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS THAT
REALLY ADDRESS THE CONCERN THAT
I HAVE, AND I BELIEVE NOW THE
THAT THE BILL IS EMINENTLY
SUPPORTABLE. I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR
BRIGHTENING UP OUR DAY. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR DOLLY? THANK YOU, MR.
SPEAKER. MEMBERS, I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THERE'S
NOTHING WORSE THAN TAKING
SOMEONE'S LAND UNJUST. AND IN
AMERICAN AND CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE
THE RIGHT TO OWN PRIVATE
PROPERTY. AND THE ONLY TIME THAT
PROPERTY SHOULD BE TAKEN IS
THROUGH EMINENT DOMAIN, AND IT
SHOULD ONLY BE USED FOR A PUBLIC
GOOD FOR SCHOOLS, ROADS AND
THOSE TYPES OF SITUATIONS. IF
IT'S BEEN TAKEN IN ANY OTHER
WAY, THAT'S UNJUST AND IT SHOULD
BE RECTIFIED IN THIS BILL, I
THINK MOVES IN THAT DIRECTION TO
DO THAT. SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AND STANDING UP FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE PRIVATE
PROPERTY. AND THAT'S THE ONE
THING THAT MAKES AMERICA GREAT,
IS WE ACTUALLY OWN SOMETHING.
AND IF IT'S UNRIGHTFULLY TAKEN,
WE SHOULD MAKE THAT RIGHT. ANY
MEMBER WISHES TO ADD THEIR VOICE
TO THIS DEBATE. SEEING NONE,
SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
JOINING ME IN WHAT IS REALLY A
SENSIBLE APPROACH TO RETURNING
LAND THAT WAS UNJUSTLY TAKEN AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY SPEAKS TO THOSE
FOLKS WHO HAD THEIR LANDS TAKEN
UNJUST FOR OTHER, NO OTHER
REASONS THAN RACIALLY MOTIVATED
HATRED. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN A GIL A ARCHULETA,
A ASHBY, A ATKINS, A BECKER, A
BLAKE SPEER. I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY, I
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LEHMAN I MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR I MIN. NEWMAN I NGUYEN.
NILO I OKOBO. I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SEYARTO I SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG I WAHHAB I
WIENER I WILK I PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE I MCGUIRE
MEN. NGUYEN. ON A VOTE OF 37
AYES, ZERO NOES. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL. ITEM 75. SENATOR PADILLA.
HE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ SENATE BILL 1072 BY
SENATOR PADILLA, AN ACT RELATING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
PADILLA. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. SB
1072 IS BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY
ON CONCURRENCE. IT WOULD REQUIRE
A LOCAL AGENCY IF A COURT
DETERMINES THAT A FEE OR CHARGE
FOR A PROPERTY RELATED SERVICE,
INCLUDING WATER, SEWER OR REFUSE
COLLECTION, VIOLATES SECTION SIX
OF ARTICLE 13 OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION, THEN THE LOCAL
AGENCY SHALL, IN THE NEXT
PROCEDURE, TO IMPOSE AN INCREASE
FOR A FEE OR CHARGE CREDIT THE
AMOUNT DUE OF THE FEE OR CHARGE
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE VIOLATION
AGAINST THE AMOUNT OF REVENUES
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THAT THAT
PROPERTY RELATED SERVICE, UNLESS
A REFUND IS. UNLESS A REFUND IS
EXPLICITLY CALLED FOR IN STATUTE,
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
REMOVE THE BILL'S PROVISIONS
THAT THE BILL IS DECLARATORY OF
EXISTING LAW. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 75. ALAN I, GILL NÓ
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY.
DODD I DALLEY. NÓ DURAZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROVE. HURTADO I JONES. LAIRD I
LEMON I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MEN. I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO
COBO. NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. NO SKINNER
I SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG.
WAHHAB I WIENER I WILK. NO.
SENATOR PADILLA MOVES THE CALL.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE MOVE ON TO
FALL. ITEM 77 BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY YOU MAY READ
THE SENATE BILL 1089 BY SENATOR
SMALL CUEVAS. AN ACT RELATING TO
FOOD AND PRESCRIPTION ACCESS.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES. SB 1089 IS A
PRIORITY BILL OF THE BLACK
CAUCUS REPARATIONS PACKAGE. AND
IT'S BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AMENDMENTS
DECREASE THE NOTICE PERIOD AND
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
PHARMACY COALITION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL. I'M FILING 77.
ALLEN I ALVARADO GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER. HI I BLAKESBURG I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DAWLEY. NO DODD I DURAZO I
EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ. GROVE
NO. HURTADO I JONES. NO. LAIRD I
LOWMAN I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MAN I
NEWMAN. I WAYNE. NO. NILO NO.
COBO NO. PADILLA. I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO, I SATO. NO
SKINNER. I SMALL. CUEVAS, I
STERN, I UMBERG, I WAHAB, I
WIENER, I WILK. NO WAIT, WAIT.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS MOVES
THE CALL NOW. MEMBERS. WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FALL. ITEM 80 BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A TIME OUT FOR A MINUTE.
YES. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO SENATOR CABALLERO FOR
ITEM 80. SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY MAY READ. SENATE BILL
1123 BY SENATOR CABALLERO. AN
ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB 1123, WHICH
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE ASSEMBLY
DEFINE WHAT CONSTITUTES A VACANT
SINGLE FAMILY PARCEL AND MAKE
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY MAY CALL THE ROLL ON
ITEM 80. ALAN A GILL A ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY DODD I DURAZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO I JONES. LAIRD I LEMON I
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MEN I NEWMAN.
I WAYNE. NO. NILO NO. JOBO
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO. SATO. NO SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK. NO SENATOR
CABALLERO MOVES TO CALL NOW
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM 83. SENATOR
PORTANTINO. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 1147 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
AN ACT RELATING TO DRINKING
WATER. MR. SENATOR PORTANTINO,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS. SB 1147 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY DIRECT THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT TO SHARE BIENNIAL
REPORTS ON THEIR MICROPLASTICS
IN DRINKING WATER RESEARCH,
WHICH WILL INCLUDE RESEARCH ON
BOTTLED WATER, WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANT. WE'RE INCLUDING
BOTTLED WATER ONCE THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
HAS REVIEWED THE FINAL REPORT,
THEY WILL DETERMINE THE BEST
INTERESTS OF PUBLIC TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL ACTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FINAL ITEM 83. ALLEN I
ALVARADO. GILL I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY DODD
I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ GROVE. HURTADO I JONES.
NO. LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE.
MINGYUAN MIN I NEWMAN I WAYNE.
MILO NO JABO. PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO, I
SATO. NO. SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I
WIENER I WILK I. SENATOR
PORTENTINO MOVES THE CALL. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM 91. SENATOR SKINNER, SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1211 BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND AQUILINA.
LAND USE. SENATOR SKINNER, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, SB 1211 IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. IT PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY WHERE
ADUS CAN BE SITED ON MULTIFAMILY
PROPERTIES. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON. FINAL ITEM 91 OAN.
ALVARADO. GILL Ã. ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE.
SPEER I BRADFORD I. CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY NÓ DODD I
D'ORAZIO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. GROVE NØ HURTADO I
JONES NO. LAIRD I LEMON I
MAGUIRE MINGYUAN MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO TROBERG. NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO. ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. NO SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG,
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK NO.
SENATOR SKINNER MOVES A CALL.
NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM 93 BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. THE SENATE BILL 1216 BY
SENATOR SHAKESPEARE. AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, SB 1216 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ADD FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO USE SHARROWS AND
HIGHER SPEED ROADS TO DIRECT
CYCLISTS THROUGH INTERSECTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FINAL ITEM 93
OAN Ã. ALVARADO GILL NØ
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I. CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY
NÓ DODD. DURAZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ. GROVE. NÓ.
HURTADO I JONES NO. LAIRD I
LEMON I MAGUIRE MENJIVAR. MEN I
NEWMAN I WAYNE. NO. NILO, NO
COBO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH. I RUBIO, I SATO. NO
SKINNER, I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN,
I UMBERG, I WAHAB, I WIENER I
WILK. NO SENATOR BLAKE MOVES THE
CALL. NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM 97. SENATOR BECKER,
HE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1254 BY
SENATOR BECKER. AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC, SOCIAL SERVICES.
SENATOR BECKER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
INCARCERATED FOLKS WITH CALFRESH
BENEFITS 90 DAYS BEFORE REENTRY,
GET THEM SIGNED UP SO THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A BETTER
CHANCE OF REENTERING SOCIETY.
AND NOT RECIDIVISM. THANK YOU. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM, HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 97. ALAN I.
ALVARADO GILL NØ ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NØ
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ GROVE. HURTADO I
JONES. NO LAIRD I LEMON. I
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR MEN I NEWMAN I
WAYNE. MILO NO. JOBO PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO. SATO
NO. SKINNER I SMALL. CUEVAS I
STERN. I UMBERG I WAHAB I
WIENER, I WILK. NØ. NGUYEN. NO
SENATOR BECKER MOVES TO CALL NOW
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM 98 SEN. NEWMAN YOU
READY? SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ
SENATE BILL 1263 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
TEACHER CREDENTIALING AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE
SENATOR NEWMAN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL IS BACK IN CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL IS NOW A STUDY BILL
THAT LOOKS AT THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR WAYS TO
ENHANCE OUR EDUCATOR WORKFORCE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NO MIX UP, WE WILL CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 98. ALLEN, I, GILL
I, ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN I MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN I
MILO I TURBO I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I RON I RUBIO I SATO
I SKINNER. I SMALL CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER
I WILK I. SEN. NEWMAN MOVES THE
CALL NOW MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 99 BY
SENATOR LAIRD. HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1280 BY SENATOR LAIRD, AN
ACT RELATING TO WASTE
MANAGEMENT. SENATOR LAIRD, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS REQUIRE CAL RECYCLE
TO CREATE REGULATIONS TO ENSURE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE,
LET'S CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 99
OAN. I'LL RODA-GIL NØ ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DEL. NØ DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE. NO
ADATO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO NO COBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE SATO. NO. SKINNER
AZEMAR. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE SENATOR LAIRD
MOVES TO CALL NOW. MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO.
SENATOR WAHAB FILED ITEM 101.
SHE IS READY. SECRETARY YOU MAY
READ. THE SENATE BILL 1321 BY
SENATOR WAHAB. AN ACT RELATING
TO EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR WAHAB,
THANK YOU. SB 1321 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
FUNDED THROUGH THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL, PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR WORKERS WITH A SPECIFIC
CRITERIA FOR HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND NOT DUPLICATING OR
COMPETING WITH ANY OTHER TYPE OF
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. FOR THE
MOST PART, THIS HAS NOT BEEN
TOUCHED IN SEVERAL DECADES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, SEEING
NONE, HEARING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON. FINAL
ITEM 101 OAN. AYE ALVARADO.
GILL. NØ. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY
ATKINS. AYE. ASHBY. AYE BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ.
DALLY. NÓ. DODD AYE. TERRAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMON AYE.
MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NO
COBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
ACIERTO NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
NO. SENATOR WAHAB MOVES TO CALL.
NOW, NEXT UP IS SENATOR
GONZALEZ, ITEM 102. YOU'RE
PREPARED. YOU WANT TO SKIP.
WE'LL SKIP. WE'LL SKIP. ALL
RIGHT. WELL WE'LL GO TO ITEM
105. SENATOR DURAZO, SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ THE SENATE BILL 1375 BY
SENATOR DURAZO. AN ACT RELATING
TO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
SENATOR DURAZO. MR. PRESIDENT,
THANK YOU. 1370 SB 1375 WAS
AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY TO
RESERVE 1% OF FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY FOR
WORKFORCE TRAINING TO CREATE
PATHWAYS INTO HIGH DEMAND, HIGH
PAY JOBS. THESE AMENDMENTS ALSO
PROVIDE A DEFINITION FOR JOB
QUALITY AND ECONOMIC EQUITY TO
ALIGN WITH THE FEDERAL GOOD JOBS
PRINCIPLES. ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING NONE. LET'S
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE 105. ALAN
ALVARADO. GILL. NO. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS BECKER.
AYE AYE. BLAKESBERG AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DEL DODD. AYE.
DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO.
NO. COBO NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN. AYE ATKINS. AYE
DALLEY. NO GLAZER. AYE MCGUIRE.
MINN AYE. AYES 30. NOES NINE.
MEASURE PASSES. ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
ARE CONCURRED IN. AND SO NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM 106. SENATOR CABALLERO, SHE
IS READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1386 BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. AN ACT
RELATING TO EVIDENCE. SENATOR
CABALLERO THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. SB 1386
IS BACK ON ON CONCURRENCE. THIS
IS THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL RAPE
SHIELD PRESERVATION ACT. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEING NONE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM 106. OAN AYE. GILL HÌNH
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBURG AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALI
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE.
JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE.
MAGUIRE MENJIVAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. AYE. MILO
AYE. ARAMBULA AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER SAU.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
MEMBERS. JONES MCGUIRE. SKINNER
AYE. ICE 38 NOES ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 108.
SENATOR ALLEN, HE'S READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. THE
SENATE BILL 1406 BY SENATOR
ALLEN, AN ACT RELATING TO
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES.
SENATOR ALLEN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
EMPOWER ASSISTED LIVING
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE BILL INCREASES THE NOTICING
PERIOD FOR RATE INCREASES FROM
60 TO 90 DAYS, TO GIVE SENIORS
AND THEIR FAMILIES THE NECESSARY
TIME TO DETERMINE WHETHER THEY
CAN AFFORD THE HIGHER RATES OR
IF THEY SHOULD APPEAL THE RATE
CHANGE, OR FIND AN ALTERNATIVE
SETTING THAT MIGHT WORK BETTER
FOR THEM. ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATION
COMMITTEE AMENDED THE BILL TO
REMOVE THE RATE INCREASE CAP.
THERE'S NOW NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 108. ALLEN I VOTE
AYE. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA I ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS I BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ I DEL.
AYE. DODD I DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN
I GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ I GROVE.
AYE HURTADO I JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MAGUIRE. MENJIVAR
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE TRUMBO.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER A SMALL
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MEMBER.
JONES. MCGUIRE AYE. 38. NÓ ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM 112.
SENATOR ARCHULETA, ARE YOU READY?
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1418 BY SENATOR ARCHULETA,
AN ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I PRESENT SENATE
BILL 1418 AND IT'S BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. AS A AS A REMINDER,
SB 1418 BRINGS PARITY TO THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE, PERMITTING
PROCESS BY STREAMLINING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS IN
THE SAME WAY AS WE DO FOR
CHARGING STATIONS. AND I
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SENATOR STERN? YEAH, THANK
YOU. MEMBERS, I JUST WANT TO
RISE BRIEFLY. UNFORTUNATELY, I
CAN'T SUPPORT TODAY JUST BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF A LOCAL SAFETY
REVIEW ON CERTAIN ASSETS THAT DO
HAVE HIGH FLAMMABILITY AND
PRESSURE POTENTIAL. AND SO I
THINK LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND OUR
FIRE DEPARTMENTS NEED STRONGER
OVERSIGHT. SO I CAN'T SUPPORT
TODAY, BUT DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SENATOR TAYLOR, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
112. ALLEN ALL RIGHT. GO HØI.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALI. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN GLASER.
AYE GONZALEZ. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. LAIRD. AYE
LIMÓN. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MC.
MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. AYE
NILO. OCHOA. BERG PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO SKINNER A SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN BECKER. AYE EGGMAN.
GONZALEZ JONES. LIMÓN MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR MILO. COBO SEYARTO.
STERN. NO. AYES 29. NOES ONE.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW. MEMBERS,
BEFORE WE MOVE ON, WE'RE JUST
GOING TO LET YOU KNOW. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A LUNCH BREAK AT
1215, AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
CONDUCT SOME COMMITTEE BUSINESS.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT WE BREAK
FOR ONE HOUR, BUT WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO ASK THAT ALL THE
MEMBERS PLEASE STAY IN THE
BUILDING SO WE CAN GET RIGHT
BACK TO WORK AT 115. ALL RIGHT.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
115 SENATOR HURTADO. SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1448 BY SENATOR
HURTADO, AN ACT RELATING TO FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE, AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
HURTADO THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SB 1448 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDE AN
URGENCY CLAUSE, EXTEND THE
SUNSET DATE TO JANUARY 1ST,
2034, AND WILL DEVELOP AND
CONSULT A WORKING GROUP
COMPRISED AT LEAST OF SEVEN
INDIVIDUALS WHO POSSESS
EXPERTISE IN THE OPERATION OF
FOOD HUBS. THIS BILL HAS MADE IT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 115. ALLEN I
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE ARCHULETA.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS I BECKER. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA. AYE JONES. LIMON. AYE
MAGUIRE. NGUYEN NILO. OKOBO
SEYARTO. WILK. AYE. AGE 32 NOES!
TWO. ON THE URGENCY. AYES 32
NOES! TWO ON THE AMENDMENTS. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 116 BY
SENATOR ASHBY. SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 1452 BY SENATOR ASHBY. AN
ACT RELATING TO ARCHITECTS AND
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE,
SENATOR ASHBY, MR. PRESIDENT, SB
1452, IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
WITHOUT THIS BILL, THE
CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS BOARD AND
THE LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS
TECHNICAL COMMITTEE WOULD EXPIRE
ON JANUARY 1ST, 2025. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
UPON ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP, SECRETARY, YOU
CAN CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 116.
ALLEN I GILL, I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I TERRAZZO I EGGMAN I
GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO I JONES LAIRD I LEMON I
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MEAN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN NILO I ADOBO I PADILLA
I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO I
SATO I SKINNER I IS MOORLACH
RIVAS I STERN. I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS JONES,
MCGUIRE, NGUYEN. AYES 37. NØ
ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM 122 BY SENATOR DURAZO.
SHE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. SENATE BILL 1500 BY
SENATOR DURAZO AN ACT RELATING
TO HOUSING AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE,
SENATOR DURAZO MR. PRESIDENT, SB
1500 IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL. THIS WILL GREATLY
HELP. IN PARTICULAR, MAYOR BASS
IN LOS ANGELES TO GET MORE
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS FASTER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 122. ALLEN. ALVARADO.
GILL I ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I
ATKINS. I BECKER. HI I
BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NÓ
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE NÓ HURTADO I
JONES. LAIRD I LIMÓN I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
NØ NILO NØ DROBO NØ PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
CIERTO NÓ. SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK KNOW. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN I
JONES. NO. MCGUIRE. AYES 31.
NOES EIGHT. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW
WE HAVE FILE LINE 123 BY SENATOR
STERN. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 1509 BY SENATOR
STERN. AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SENATOR STERN, I THANK
YOU, MEMBERS. THIS BILL IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE. CREATES A
STANDALONE DEFINITION FOR THOSE
WHO ARE CHRONIC EXTREME SPEEDERS.
IF YOU'RE A REPEAT SPEEDER
WITHIN A THREE YEAR PERIOD,
YOU'RE GOING TO GET POINTS ON
YOUR RECORD AND YOU'RE GOING TO
GET INCREASED FINES. THE NUMBER
ONE KILLER OF CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA, AGES 5 TO 14, ROAD
RELATED DEATHS IS PEOPLE NOT
PAYING ATTENTION WHEN THEY DRIVE
THEIR CAR, AND THEY REALIZE IT'S
ACTUALLY A WEAPON. IF YOU'RE
CARELESS, SO HIGH TIME WE GET
THIS DONE, I HOPE WE CAN GET A
SIGNATURE. RESPECTFULLY, I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NO MIX UP.
SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
123. ALAN Ã I'LL RODA-GIL. HI,
ARCHULETA. HI, ASHBY. HI, ATKINS.
BECKER BLAKE. SPEER HI,
BRADFORD. I CABALLERO. CORTEZ
HI. DALLEY HI, DODD I DURAZO I
EGGMAN GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HURTADO. GROVE I HURTADO I JONES.
NO. LAIRD I LOWMAN I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN NEWMAN I NGUYEN I
MILO I OKOBO I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SEYARTO I SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB. WIENER
I WILK I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS I BECKER.
CABALLERO I EGGMAN I MCGUIRE. I
MIN WAHAB. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
BECKER MIN. WAHAB. ICE 36 NOES
ONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THAT YOU RETURN TO
YOUR DESK. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ALL OUR OUTSTANDING
ITEMS. SO WE'RE GOING TO NEED
ALL MEMBERS BACK ON THE FLOOR
AND PREFERABLY AT YOUR DESKS.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE READY
TO LIFT THE CALLS ON OUTSTANDING
ITEMS. WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
FILE ITEM 20.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO LIFT THE CALLS. WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM 20 SB
901.
DOLLY DORADO BROUGH MEMBERS,
WE'RE LIFTING THE CALL. WE Ã
GROVE JONES. MCGUIRE Ã. NGUYEN
MILO. AYE OKOBO. SEYARTO SKINNER.
AYE WILK.
AYES 33. NO. ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM 75 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GLASER
GROVE. NO. JONES MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE UMBERG. AYE JONES.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER.
GLASER AYES 30. NOS. NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 77 BY SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER
GONZALEZ. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. AYES 30 NOES NINE.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM 80 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER DAWLEY.
NO GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. JONES. NO MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE OKOBO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER AYE.
GROVE JOBO. RUBIO. AYE. AYES 32.
NO. SIX. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 83 BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO. LET ME CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DAWLEY NO.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE. NGUYEN OKOBO. AGE
33. NOS. FOR THE ASSEMBLY.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN NOW
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
91 BY SENATOR SKINNER. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN A
GONZALEZ. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE PORTANTINO. LIMÓN.
I DON'T KNOW. WHERE AYES 30. NOS
NINE. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 93 BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS DODD. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR I OCHOA.
AYES 31. NOES EIGHT. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 97 BY SENATOR BECKER.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GONZALEZ A GROVE. NO MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR I COBO. RUBIO I
MEAN, I DON'T KNOW. AYES 30.
NOES NINE. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED. AND NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 98 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALEZ AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE MENGIBAR I AYES 40.
NØ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN NOW FILE ITEM
99 BY SENATOR LAIRD. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. OAN AYE.
GONZALEZ Ã MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR NO. AYES 31. NOES NINE.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN OUR FINAL ITEM ON
CALL IS FILED ITEM 101 BY
SENATOR WAHAB. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS A CORTEZ
A, GONZALEZ A MCGUIRE. AYE
NGUYEN NO. AYES 31. NOES NINE.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN NOW. MEMBERS
NOW WOULD BE THE TIME FOR OUR
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. ANYONE
READY FOR COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS? SENATOR ALLEN,
ARE YOU PREPARED? YES, FRIENDS,
WE'RE GOING TO BE HOLDING A
HEARING OF EAC TO HEAR TWO BILLS
IN ROOM 113. UPON ADJOURNMENT.
ON RECESS. RECESS A RECESS FOR
LUNCH IMMEDIATELY IN ROOM 113.
SENATOR BLAKESPEAR. THANK YOU.
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM 112
DURING LUNCH. ELECTIONS WILL BE
MEETING IN 112 DURING LUNCH.
SENATOR BLACKSHIRE, I MEAN,
SENATOR WAHAB, I'M SORRY. THANK
YOU. SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY WILL
MEET IMMEDIATELY IN ROOM 113 TO
HEAR TWO BILLS. AB 2348 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AND SB 918
BY SENATOR UMBERG, BUT THIS IS
AT DINNER TIME. THANK YOU. A
DINNER TIME, NOT AT LUNCH TIME.
ALL RIGHT. AT DINNER TIME. ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR DODD. YEAH. MR.
PRESIDENT, IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS EVENING WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A COMMITTEE AFTER
ADJOURNMENT IN A PLACE TO BE
NAMED LATER. SOMEWHERE IN
SACRAMENTO. GOT IT. OUR MEMBERS,
I NEED YOUR ATTENTION. WE'RE
GOING TO BREAK FOR LUNCH. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE AN HOUR BREAK.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT ALL
MEMBERS BE BACK HERE ON THE
FLOOR AT 125. WE HAVE WE HAVE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALLS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO COMPLETE. SO WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO BE BACK ON
125.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO RETURN
TO UNFINISHED ITEMS. WE NEED
YOUR ATTENTION. WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH ITEM
ONE 102 BY SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SHE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ THE SENATE BILL 1337 BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ, AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS. SENATOR
GONZALEZ, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS TO SB 1337 CLARIFY
HOW SIGNATORIES ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THEY HAVE REVIEWED TOP FUNDERS
AND CLARIFY TECHNICAL LANGUAGE
AT THE REQUEST OF THE SECRETARY
OF STATE, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE IN
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NO MICROPHONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 102. ALLEN A GILL
NO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS HI. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. BLAKESBURG. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY NØ. DODD
TERRAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. NO. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
NO O'DONNELL. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NO. NILO NO. OKOBO. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE RUBIO. CIERTO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AL-WAHHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD. NÓ OR
DOTTO. MCGUIRE. RUBIO.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT YOU CALL
THE ROLL. ONE MORE TIME. HURTADO
MCGUIRE. RUBIO AYE. AYES 27.
NOES 11. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MEMBERS NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM 100. THIS IS SENATE
BILL 1292. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1292 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD. AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY. SENATOR
BRADFORD, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. 1292 WOULD REQUIRE
THE PUC TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF INCOME BASED FIXED CHARGE AND
ITS IMPACTS ON CUSTOMERS BEFORE
MAKING FUTURE ADJUSTMENTS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN ASSEMBLY
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES AND ADD
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE REPORT
INCLUDE INFORMATION REGARDING
IMPACTS TO BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION, CONSERVATION
EFFORTS AND AIR CONDITIONING
ADOPTION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
OUR VOTE MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I GILL I ARCHULETA I ASHBY
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DAWLEY I DODD I D'ORAZIO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE I HURTADO I JONES I LAIRD
I LEHMAN I MCGUIRE MENJIVAR I. I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I CIERTO I SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I A VOTE OF 39
TO 0. THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 103. THIS IS
SENATE BILL 1348 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. PLEASE SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ THE READ THE
MEASURE. SENATE BILL 1348 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD. AN ACT TO
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. 1348 IS BACK FOR
ASSEMBLY ON CONCURRENCE. THE
BILL WOULD CREATE A STATE LEVEL
DESIGNATION RECOGNIZING COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE MAKING SIGNIFICANT
COMMITMENTS TO ENHANCING THE
BLACK STUDENT SUCCESS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS CREATE A
ADMINISTERING BODY, A BOARD AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE FOR
APPLICANT SCHOOLS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR BRADFORD. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE?
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DELI I DODD
BARRASSO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES. LAIRD I LIMÓN. I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN I NEWMAN. I
WAYNE. NILO I JOBO PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I RA I RUBIO I SATO I
SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DODD I JONES. MCGUIRE NGUYEN
OCHOA. ON A VOTE OF 36 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. THANK YOU, SIR.
THANK YOU. WHAT. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING BACK IN
FILE TO FILE ITEM 81. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ THE
SENATE BILL 1142 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC UTILITIES. SENATOR FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SB 1142, BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. AMENDMENTS TAKING
ASSEMBLY. REMOVED THE ENTIRE
OPPOSITION AND THEY'RE NOW IN
SUPPORT. WE CHANGED AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS SAFETY ISSUES,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING,
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 81.
ALAN Ã ALVARADO NÓ ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY I DODD. DALLEY
NÓ DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE. NO
HURTADO I JONES. LAIRD I LEMON I
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO COBO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO. IRA I
RUBIO I SATO. NO. SKINNER I
CUEVAS, I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK. NOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES
MCGUIRE OJOBO. AGE 30 NOES
SEVEN. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 89
BY SENATOR MENGIBAR. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1193 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. AN ACT
RELATING TO AVIATION. SENATOR,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. SB 1193, REMOVING
THE SALE OF LEADED FUEL IN
CALIFORNIA IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL WAS
THOROUGHLY AMENDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY THAT IS NOW ALIGNING
THE TIMELINE TO DO THE BAN TO
2031, IN LINE WITH THE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE OF REMOVING LEAD FROM
AVIATION FUEL. THE AMENDMENT
TOOK OFF ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
OPPOSITION. ONLY ONE REMAINS. WE
WORKED VERY HARD ON THIS TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS FEASIBLE AND
WORKABLE IN CALIFORNIA,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FINAL ITEM 89.
ALAN AYE. GILL NÓ ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DEL NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN
NO. NILO. NO TURBO. NO. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO SEYARTO. RUBIO. AYE SATO.
NO. SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS BY
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK NO,
PLEASE CALL THE OPPOSITION
MEMBER. JONES MCGUIRE. AYES 30
NOES EIGHT. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO OUR FILE AND WE'RE GOING
TO THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ITEMS. WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT
ALL MEMBERS STAY ON THE FLOOR SO
WE CAN SUCCESSFULLY USE THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. AND WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
19. SENATOR HURTADO, ARE YOU
READY? SHE IS SECRETARY. YOU MAY
READ THE SENATE BILL 577 BY
SENATOR HURTADO. AN ACT TO
INSURANCE. SENATOR HURTADO,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SB 577
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE ASSEMBLY
WERE TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING IN
NATURE. THIS BILL HAS MADE IT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE
MEMBERS AGAIN, THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NO OBJECTION.
AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSED SINCE THE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO SENATOR CABALLERO FILE
ON 23.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
23. SENATE BILL 366 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. AN ACT RELATING TO
WATER. SENATOR CABALLERO, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. SB 366 IS
MY BILL TO CREATE AND UPDATE THE
CALIFORNIA WATER PLAN. THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY WERE
TECHNICAL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR. I VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
HEARING AND SEEING. NONE. THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
TO THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE. AYES
38. NO ZERO. THE MEASURE THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THANK YOU. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 24
BY SENATOR PORTENTINO.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 445 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
AN ACT RELATING TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION. SENATOR PORTANTINO,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO BRING BACK SB
445 ON CONCURRENCE. THE BILL HAS
BEEN NARROWED TO REQUIRE THAT
THE TEMPLATE BE TRANSLATED, NOT
THE ACTUAL IEP. AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NONE, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
THE UNANIMOUS. UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL TO THIS MEASURE. SEEING.
NONE. AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE AND SENATE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. OUR
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 30 BY
SENATOR MAN. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1271 BY
SENATOR. MEN AND ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. SENATOR. MAN. HI.
THIS SB 1271 ABOUT ELECTRIC
BIKES IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? NO
OBJECTION WILL APPLY. UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL 38 TO 0. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NEXT UP, SENATOR NEWMAN. HE HAS
PREPARED ON FILE ITEM 31, SB
347. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 347 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN AND AQUILINA. LAND USE.
SENATOR NEWMAN THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
347, WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AND WHICH WILL
STREAMLINE THE DEPLOYMENT OF NEW
EV INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA
BY MODIFYING THE STATE'S
SUBDIVISION MAP ACT. THE BILL
HAS HAD NO VOTES AND NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION THUS FAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM? SEEING
NONE, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL? AYES 38. NOES ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
NEXT UP IS ITEM 50 BY SENATOR
WAHAB. SHE PREPARED. SHE IS
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 575 BY SENATOR WAHAB. AN
ACT RELATING TO UNDERAGE
MARRIAGE. THANK YOU, SB 57. GO
AHEAD. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU. SB 575 CHILD MARRIAGE DATA
INTEGRITY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NONE, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 38.
NOES ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. OUR
NEXT UP IS SENATOR ROTH. HE IS
READY TO GO. SECRETARY MAY READ
FILE ITEM 54, SB 895. SENATE
BILL 895 BY SENATOR ROTH. AN ACT
RELATING TO POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. SENATOR RALPH, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS LIMIT THE PILOT
PROGRAM TO TEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS AND ADD INTENT
LANGUAGE RELATING TO THE RN TO
BSN CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS AND REQUIRE
POSITIVE CONSIDERATION OF THOSE
PROGRAMS WHEN SELECTING
CANDIDATES FOR THE PILOT
PROGRAM, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING.
SEEING. NONE MEMBERS. THIS Tð IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING? UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
AYES 38. NOES ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR NEWMAN
FOLLOWING ITEM 55, SB 897. HE IS
READY TO GO. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 897 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO PUPIL
ATTENDANCE. SENATOR NEWMAN, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SB 897 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE BILL MAKES
PERMANENT CALIFORNIA'S DISTRICT
OF CHOICE PROGRAM. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TO THE ASSEMBLY. ADD NEW
PROTECTION FOR DISTRICTS OF
RESIDENTS AND ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION. THIS
BILL NOW HAS NO OPPOSITION, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE? SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR Þ, THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SEEING
NONE. AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. TO BE. PROBABLY
NOT GOING TO RULE ON THIS. OKAY
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO CREATE
TROUBLE IN THE PROCESS. SO WE
MIGHT STILL SEE IT. BUT I'M
GOING TO FOLLOW YOU. SO PRESENT
IT WITH THIS SIDE. ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP IS ITEM 68. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. NO THANK YOU. SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1002 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. AN ACT
RELATING TO FIREARMS. SENATOR
BLAKE, THE FLOOR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS CAME AT THE
REQUEST OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO ADDRESS
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS, AND SB
1002 IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ALSO ADDED
CHAPTER AMENDMENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING. NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 68. ALLEN,
A GILL ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY I DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN
I GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO I JONES LAIRD I LOWMAN I
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROBB I
RUBIO. SEYARTO I SKINNER I
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG, I
WAHAB, I WIENER. WILK I. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. OR ARE
WE GOING TO MOVE THE CALL? ALL
RIGHT. NEXT UP IS ITEM 73 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. SECRETARY,
YOU CAN READ. SENATE BILL 1066
BY SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. AN ACT
RELATING TO HAZARDOUS WASTE.
SENATOR BLAKE, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. SB 1066 IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS STREAMLINED THE
PROGRAM TO REDUCE COSTS AND MAKE
IT EASIER FOR MANUFACTURERS TO
COMPLY. THERE ARE ALSO TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
AND CONTROL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING. NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 73. ALAN A GILL
ARCHULETA I ASHBY. ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER. I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLASER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES. LAIRD I LIMÓN I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
I NILO I DROBO I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO
SEYARTO I SKINNER I CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER
I WILK I SEN BLAKE SPEER MOVES
TO CALL. NEXT UP IS FALL ITEM 76
BY SENATOR BLAKE SPEARS.
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ. THE
SENATE BILL 1077 BY SENATOR
BLAKE. AN ACT RELATING TO
COASTAL RESOURCES. SENATOR BLAKE
SAU. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
RISE TO PRESENT SB 1077, WHICH
IS BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY WITH
AMENDMENTS. IT NOW REQUIRES THE
COASTAL COMMISSION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, OR HCD,
TO RESOLVE CONFLICTS IN HOW THEY
CITE AND REGULATE ADUS IN THE
COASTAL ZONE. CURRENTLY, HCD AND
COASTAL COMMISSION REGULATIONS
ON ADU LAND USE PLANNING
CONFLICT WITH ONE ANOTHER. SB
1077 WILL REQUIRE THESE TWO
AGENCIES TO REMOVE THIS
STUMBLING BLOCK. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DEBATE, DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 76. ALAN I.
GILL ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS.
I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLI I DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO I JONES LAIRD I LEMON I
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN I NILO I OKOBO I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO SEYARTO I SKINNER I
MOORLACH RIVAS I STERN I UMBERG
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I.
SENATOR BLAKE MOVES TO CALL.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR PORTANTINO
FILE ITEM 79. HE IS READY TO GO.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. I NEVER
RESPONDED. WHAT.
NO. ALL RIGHT. NOW WE MOVE BACK
TO FALL. ITEM 79 BY SENATOR
PORTENTINO. SECRETARY. YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1100 BY SENATOR
PORTENTINO. AN ACT RELATING TO
DISCRIMINATION. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. SB 1100
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE WITH
LARGELY TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
CHANGING GOVERNMENT CODE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 79 OAN. I RODA-GIL
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I BROUGH I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES LAIRD I LEMON I MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
I NILO I TURBO I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO SATO I
SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I.
SEN PORTANTINO MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS ITEM 82 BY SENATOR
ALLEN. SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ
SENATE BILL 1143 BY SENATOR
ALLEN. AN ACT RELATING TO PAINT
PRODUCTS. SENATOR ALLEN, MEMBERS
SB 1143 WOULD EXPAND THE STATE'S
EXISTING SUCCESSFUL PAINT
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM TO ALL PAINT
AND PAINT RELATED PRODUCTS. WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS AND THE INDUSTRY TO REACH
A STRONG DEAL HERE. IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM?
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS,
WE HAVE A TECHNICAL PROBLEM HERE.
WE CANNOT TAKE UP THIS BILL AT
THIS TIME BECAUSE IT WAS
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE. SO WE
WILL MOVE ON. I BELIEVE. OUR
NEXT STEP IS SENATOR LIMÓN FILE
ITEM 85. SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ THE
SENATE BILL 1152 BY SENATOR
LIMÓN AN ACT RELATING TO FIRE
SAFETY. SENATOR LIMÓN, THANK
YOU. MEMBERS. THIS BILL IS BACK
FROM CONCURRENCE. IT ESTABLISHES
REGULATIONS ALLOWING THE USE OF
LITHIUM BASED BATTERIES, WHERE
APPROPRIATE, FOR BROADBAND
COMPANIES TO SATISFY THEIR 72
HOUR BACKUP POWER REQUIREMENTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? CAN WE CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 85?
ALAN I WILL ARCHULETA, I ASHBY,
I ATKINS, I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALLEY I DODD I DURAZO I
EGGMAN I GLASER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE I HURTADO I JONES LAIRD I
LEHMAN I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN
I NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA
I PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. I SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG, I
WAHAB. I WIENER, I WILK I
SENATOR LOWMAN MOVES TO CALL.
NEXT UP IS FALL ITEM 94 SB 1217
BY SENATOR GLAZIER. SECRETARY
IT'S A PET BILL. YOU CAN READ
SENATE BILL 1217 BY SENATOR
GLASER. AN ACT RELATING TO PET
INSURANCE. SENATOR GLASER. MR.
PRESIDENT, I'M PRESENTING THIS
BILL THAT'S BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS SPECIFY
STANDARDIZED EFFECTUATION DATES
FOR POLICIES, CLARIFIES WHEN A
WELLNESS PROGRAM IS NOT
CONSIDERED INSURANCE, AND ALLOWS
THE START DATE TO BE EXTENDED IF
AN EMPLOYER PURCHASES PET
INSURANCE. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR CONCURRENCE
IN THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE,
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON Ã ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS, I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ. I DALLEY I DODD I DURAZO
I EGGMAN I GLASER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE I O'DONNELL I JONES LAIRD
I LIMON I MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN.
NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NILO I COBO I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I
MOORLACH RIVAS I STERN I UMBERG
I WAHAB I WIENER WILK I SENATOR
GLASER MOVES THE CALL. GLASER.
ALL RIGHT. FILE LINE 125 SB 1528
BY SENATOR GLASER. HE IS READY.
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ. THE.
SENATE BILL 1528 BY REVENUE AND
TAXATION AND RELATING TO
TAXATION. SENATOR GLASER. MR.
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. THIS IS A
REVENUE TAX COMMITTEE ANNUAL
TECHNICAL TAX OMNIBUS BILL. IT
CONTAINS CHANGES SUGGESTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION. THE
FULL LIST OF ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE IN OUR JOURNAL. AND IF YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS, I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER THEM. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR CONCURRENCE
AND ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR NILO? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE ON THIS ON
THIS BILL TO STATE NØ POSITION
TO APOLOGIZE TO THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE IT WAS ON CONSENT. I
ASKED FOR IT TO BE TAKEN OFF SO
THAT I MAY, IN AN ABUNDANCE OF
CAUTION, ABSTAIN. ALL RIGHT. NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION. SENATORS.
GLASER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BECAUSE
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO
SAY TO THE SENATOR FROM FAIR
OAKS THAT I SO APPRECIATE YOUR
INTEGRITY AND THE WORK THAT YOU
DO HERE IN THE SENATE. AND IT
WAS A PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT THIS BILL TO PROTECT ALL
THOSE QUALITIES OF YOURS THAT WE
SO ADMIRE. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK CONCURRENCE AND
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. FINAL ITEM. 125 ALAN, A GILL
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO. I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLASER
I GONZALEZ. GROVE I OTERO I
JONES. LAIRD I LOWMAN I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN NEWMAN I NGUYEN I
NILO. OKOBO. PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROD I RUBIO I SATO
I SKINNER I SMALL. CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER
WILK I OKOBOJI. SENATOR GLAZIER
MOVES THE CALL. APPLAUSE. MR.
PRESIDENT. WE'RE GOING TO JUST
TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE SO WE CAN GET
OUR FINAL ORDER TOGETHER. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK MEMBERS TO STAY ON
THE FLOOR, NOT TO LEAVE. YEAH. I
SAW YOU SCURRYING OFF.
MEMBERS, WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. WE'RE
GOING TO START OFF MEMBERS WHO
NEED YOUR ATTENTION. WE'RE GOING
TO START OFF WITH ITEM ONE FOR
ONE. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. FOLLOW
ITEM ONE FOR ONE. ARE YOU
PREPARED? YOU HAVE UNFRIENDLY
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2127 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO VOTER REGISTRATION. SENATOR
BLAKE, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. COLLEAGUES.
I'M SORRY, SENATOR BLAKE. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS ON ONE FOR ONE
RIGHT NOW. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE OVER TO FILE
ITEM 156 AB 1472 WITH SENATOR
PADILLA PRESENTING. HE HAS
PREPARED SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 1472 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ, AN ACT RELATING
TO RECREATIONAL VEHICLE PARKS.
SENATOR PADILLA THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1472 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ, THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT WILL PROHIBIT
THE UNFAIR BUSINESS PRACTICE
KNOWN AS THE RV SHUFFLE. IT
INVOLVES EVICTING AND RELOCATING
TENANTS FROM A RESIDENTIAL RV
PARK, USUALLY FOR 48 HOURS EVERY
SIX MONTHS, TO PREVENT TENANTS
GAINING CERTAIN STATUS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE THEM WITH
SUBSTANTIVE TENANT PROTECTIONS.
AB 1472 IS MODELED AFTER A BILL
THAT PASSED 20 YEARS AGO THAT
PROHIBITED A SIMILAR PRACTICE
WITHIN THE RESIDENTIAL HOTEL
SECTOR. IT IS ENJOYING THE
SUPPORT FROM ACE AND SAN DIEGO
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 156. ALAN A
GILL ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ.
DALLEY NÓ DODD I TERRAZZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE. NÓ. O'DONNELL I JONES.
LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE MENGIBAR
I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NO.
MILO NO. JOBO PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO.
NO. SKINNER, I MOORLACH. RIVAS I
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB, I WEINER.
WILK I SENATOR PADILLA MOVES THE
CALL. NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FOR
ITEM 157 BY SENATOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARRILLO,
PRESENTED BY SENATOR LEMON.
SHE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1950 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO.
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR LEMON, THANK
YOU, PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY
CARRILLO, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1950 THE CHAVEZ RAVINE
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. THE BILL
ACKNOWLEDGES THE HISTORICAL
HOUSING INJUSTICE OF THE PALO
VERDE, LA LOMA, AND BISHOP
COMMUNITIES KNOWN TODAY AS
CHAVEZ RAVINE AB. 1950 IS A
CRITICAL STEP FORWARD THAT AIMS
TO CORRECT INJUSTICE AND THAT
HAS LINGERED IN THE SHADOWS OF
THE LOS ANGELES EAST SIDE
HISTORY FOR FAR TOO LONG. WITH
THIS LEGISLATION, WE ARE
ADDRESSING THIS HISTORY AND
GIVING VOICE TO INJUSTICE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING.
SEEING NONE, SECRETARY, YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL ON FINAL ITEM 157.
ALLEN I ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA
I ASHBY ATKINS I BECKER. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE DESI AYE. DALI.
NÓ. DODD AYE. TERRAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO. AYE
JONES. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN NGUYEN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NO. MILO AYE. OCHOA
EBCLC. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. AYE RUBIO. AYE SATO. NO.
SKINNER A SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER WILK. AYE. WIENER.
AYE SENATOR LEMON MOVES THE CALL.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM 159. SENATOR
WIENER, AS YOU PREPARED, AB.
2258 SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2258 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ZUBIR AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. SENATOR
WIENER. AYE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2258 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF BURR TO CODIFY
FEDERAL LAW FOR EXISTING FEDERAL
GUIDANCE REQUIRING HEALTH PLANS
AND HEALTH INSURERS TO COVER
SERVICES INTEGRAL TO THE
DELIVERY OF RECOMMENDED
PREVENTIVE SERVICES WITHOUT
OUT-OF-POCKET COSTS. A STUDY BY
THE NIH FOUND THAT EVEN A $10
CO-PAY FOR HIV PREVENTION
MEDICATION DOUBLED PRESCRIPTION
ABANDONMENT RATES, INCREASING
THE POTENTIAL OF HIV INFECTIONS
IN THESE PATIENTS. FINANCIAL
BARRIERS TO PREVENTATIVE CARE
FORCED PEOPLE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
PREVENTING EXPENSIVE AND
DEVASTATING HEALTH PROBLEMS, AND
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE. AB
2258 ENSURES THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS, REGARDLESS OF
INCOME, HAVE ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE PREVENTIVE MEDICAL
CARE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON FINAL FILE. ITEM 159. ALLEN A
GILL ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBURG. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE JONES. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. OKOBO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE. SMALL
QUAVERS. AYE STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
SEN. WIENER MOVES THE CALL.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
160. SENATOR BECKER FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARNER.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2666 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARNER. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC UTILITIES. SENATOR
BECKER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. LAST AUGUST, AN AUDIT
REPORT SHOWED THAT THE CPUC WAS
NOT HOLDING IOUS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
HAVING SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND
SHOWING RECORD PROFITS. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE CPUC TO
LOOK AT THE ACTUAL COSTS
INCURRED BY AN IOU, COMPARED TO
THE FORECASTED COSTS FROM THE
PREVIOUS GENERAL RATE CASE, OR
GRC, AND ADJUST RATES THE NEXT
YEAR. SEE IF THE COMMISSION
DEEMS THEY ARE UNREASONABLY
HIGH. THUS HAS WORKED HARD TO
GET THE IOUS TO NEUTRAL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 160. ALLEN Ã
ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALI NØ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO
NO. OKOBO PADILLA. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO. NO. SKINNER AYE. CUEVAS
STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK AYE. SENATOR
BECKER MOVES. MOVES. THE CALL.
NEXT UP IS FINAL ITEM 162.
SENATOR UMBERG, ARE YOU PREPARED?
AB 2678. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2678 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE. AN ACT
RELATING TO VEHICLES. SENATOR
UMBERG THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES, I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 2678, WHICH EXTENDS
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT ZERO.
EMISSIONS PROGRAM, ALLOWING HIGH
OCCUPANCY VEHICLE LANE ACCESS
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES FOR
15 MONTHS TO THE END OF 2026. I
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NO MIX UP
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE. GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NO. DODD AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO LUCERO. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
AYE. SKINNER EYES. MOORLACH.
RIVAS STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
SENATOR UMBERG MOVES THE CALL.
NEXT UP IS ITEM 166. SENATOR
UMBERG, HE IS PREPARED AB 3074.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3074 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. SCHIAVO. AN ACT RELATING
TO SCHOOLS. SENATOR UMBERG,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
AB 3074 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHIAVO WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT
PROHIBIT ALL PUBLIC K THROUGH 12
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM USING CULTURALLY
INSENSITIVE NATIVE AMERICAN
TERMS FOR SCHOOL OR ATHLETIC
TEAMS OR MASCOTS OR NICKNAMES.
URGING I VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 166 OAN AYE. ALL RIGHT.
AGO ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY NØ. DODD
TERRAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMON
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. WAYNE NIELLO.
COBO AYE. PODIUM AYE. PORTANTINO
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE SATO.
SKINNER SMALL. CUEVAS STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE SENATOR UMBERG
MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE 172.
SENATOR BECKER, HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. THE
ASSEMBLY BILL 2313 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT. AN ACT RELATING
TO AGRICULTURE. SENATOR BECKER,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS
BILL WILL CREATE A REGIONAL
HEAVY EQUIPMENT TOOL SHARING
PROGRAM FOR FARMERS. RECENT
AMENDMENTS LIMIT THE COST OF THE
BILL BY REQUIRING THE PROGRAM'S
OPERATIONS TO BE APPROVED IN THE
CLIMATE BOND, AND MAKES FUNDING
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION BY
THE LEGISLATURE. THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE WAY TO SHARE
EQUIPMENT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 172. ALLEN A GILL
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS I BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE NO. DATO JONES.
LAIRD. AYE LIMON. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN
NO. MILO NO. TRUMBO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO ACIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK AYE. SENATOR BECKER
MOVES THE CALL NOW. MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
174. SENATOR CABALLERO, SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2750 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER. AN
ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICITY.
SENATOR CABALLERO THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. IT GIVES ME GREAT
PLEASURE TO PRESENT AB 2750 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER, WHICH CLARIFIES THAT
BIOMASS FACILITIES LOCATED IN
AIR DISTRICTS THAT VOLUNTARILY
RECLASSIFY THEIR OZONE OR
PARTICULATE MATTER IN THE
FEDERAL EPA CLASSIFICATION
SYSTEM TO A HIGHER, MORE
RESTRICTIVE TIER ARE NOT
PROHIBITED FROM RECEIVING A
FIREARM POWER PURCHASE AGREEMENT.
EXTENSION. THE FIREARM PROGRAM
HAS NOT ONLY BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
EXTENDING A LIFELINE TO CRITICAL
PLANTS AND REDUCING FOREST
FUELS, IT ALSO HAS RESULTED IN
CLEANER AIR COMPARED TO OPEN
BURNING AND REQUIRES STRINGENT
AIR EMISSIONS CONTROL. MEMBERS
WITHOUT A CONTRACT EXTENSION,
THIS PARTICULAR FACILITY FACES
JEOPARDY AND THE ABILITY TO
CONTINUE EFFECTIVELY MANAGING
FOREST WASTE AND TO PROVIDE
RENEWABLE ENERGY IS AT RISK. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 174. ALLEN I RODA-GIL
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ. I DALLEY I
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ GROVE I HURTADO.
JONES. LAIRD I LIMON. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. MAN I NEWMAN. I NGUYEN
I NILO I TURBO I PADILLA.
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO
I SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN
I UMBERG I WAHAB. WIENER WILK I
SENATOR CABALLERO MOVES THE CALL.
NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM 175. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 3064 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AN ACT RELATING TO
FIREARMS. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS AB 3064 WOULD REQUIRE
MANUFACTURERS OF FIREARMS SAFETY
DEVICES TO MARK THEIR PRODUCTS
WITH MAKE AND MODEL INFORMATION
FOR FIREARM SAFETY DEVICES, LOCK
AND PREVENT UNAUTHORIZED
AUTHORIZED USERS FROM
DISCHARGING A FIREARM. SAFETY
DEVICES MUST BE USED WHEN A
FIREARM IS TRANSFERRED THROUGH A
DEALER OR WHEN TRANSPORTED IN
SENSITIVE PLACES WITHOUT MAKE
AND MODEL INFORMATION. LOCKED ON
THE DEVICE. IT IS NEXT TO
IMPOSSIBLE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND CONSUMERS TO TELL ONE FROM
ANOTHER, MUCH LESS AN APPROVED
DEVICE VERSION, VERSUS AN
INEFFECTIVE LOOK ALIKE. MORE
IMPORTANTLY, IF A CONSUMER OWNS
A SAFETY DEVICE THAT HAS BEEN
RECALLED, IS DEFECTIVE, OR HAS A
WARRANTY ISSUE, THEY ARE UNABLE
TO IDENTIFY IF THEIR PARTICULAR
DEVICE IS AFFECTED. THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES MANUFACTURERS TO
NOTIFY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
IN THE EVENT OF A RECALL. THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE BILL TO ASSIST
BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
CONSUMERS, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM, SENATOR GROVE? MR.
CHAIR, I RISE IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS AND PRACTICALLY EVERY OTHER
GUN BILL THAT'S GONE OFF THIS
FLOOR. THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
VIOLATING THE LAWS ARE NOT GOING
TO COMPLY WITH THIS LAW. AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT I THINK
THERE'S ROUGHLY 4 MILLION, GUN
OWNERS, LAWFUL GUN OWNERS,
REGISTERED GUN OWNERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND
PROBABLY 9 MILLION HANDGUNS, 1
IN 4 HOUSES IN CALIFORNIA HAS A
FIREARM IN THEIR HOME. AND
BELIEVE ME, IF WE WERE THE
PROBLEM, YOU WOULD KNOW IT. IT'S
NOT OUR IT'S NOT US. AND WE ARE
FOLLOWING EVERY LAW THAT YOU PUT
IN PLACE. BUT WE NEED TO GO
AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT
FOLLOW THESE LAWS. AND THE GUY
CARRYING A GUN ON THE STREET
THAT'S NOT USING IT FOR
APPROPRIATE PURPOSES. AND THAT
IS WREAKING HAVOC, IS NOT
REGISTERING THEIR FIREARMS. THEY
ARE NOT COMPLYING WITH DOJ. THEY
ARE NOT FILLING OUT AN
APPLICATION. THEY'RE NOT DOING
LAWFUL GUN TRANSFERS. THEY ARE
NOT GETTING SOMEONE TO SITE THE
GUN TRANSFERS. THEY'RE NOT
WAITING FOR A TEN DAY WAITING
PERIOD FOR A SECOND PURCHASE,
NOT MUCH LESS THE FIRST. AND I
JUST THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS THAT
WE KEEP DOING THIS BECAUSE IT'S
NOT US. TRUST ME, YOU WOULD KNOW
IT'S NOT US. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE. SENATOR
BERKSHIRE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES. THANK YOU. SO THE
DATA IS UNQUESTIONABLY CLEAR
THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE SAFER
BECAUSE OF OUR GUN SAFETY LAWS.
SO WE NEED OUR GUN LAWS TO WORK
PROPERLY, AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN THEM IN
ORDER TO SAVE LIVES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 175. ALLEN A GILL
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALY NÓ
DODD NÓ DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE NÓ HURTADO.
JONES. LAIRD I LOWMAN I MCGUIRE
I MENJIVAR MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
NØ. NIELSEN. NØ B¢O NÓ. PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO I
SATO. NO. SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS STERN. UMBERG I WAHAB I
WIENER I WILK. NO. JONES. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL HURTADO. MENGIBAR
I ROTH. SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN. I.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. ALVARADO.
GILL HURTADO. ROTH. ARE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
ALVARADO GILL. HURTADO ROTH.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR MOVES THE
CALL.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP IS FOR ITEM
240 BY SENATOR, PRESENTED BY
SENATOR UMBERG. HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1755 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA. AN ACT RELATING TO CIVIL
ACTIONS. SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES. THIS BILL CONCERNS
LEMON LAW, THE SO-CALLED LEMON
LAW, ALSO KNOWN AS THE SONG
BEVERLY ACT, WAS ENACTED ALMOST
50 YEARS AGO. AND OH, BY THE
WAY, TO THE SMART ALEC SENATOR
ASKED ME HOW I VOTED ON IT 50
YEARS AGO. I WAS NOT HERE. IT'S
BEEN QUITE EFFECTIVE IN ENSURING
THAT THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
ACQUIRED A CAR WITH SORT OF
REPEATED REPETITIVE ISSUES BE
ABLE TO SEEK A REMEDY. BUT
THERE'S BEEN SOME CHALLENGES,
PARTICULARLY IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS, AND AS SUCH, THERE'S BEEN
A COMPROMISE THAT HAS BEEN
AGREED TO BY SOME OF THE AUTO
MANUFACTURERS, GENERAL MOTORS
AND FORD AND STELLANTIS, ALONG
WITH THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS. AND
MANY OF YOU HAVE ASKED THE RIGHT
QUESTION WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR
THE CONSUMER IN CALIFORNIA? WHAT
GOOD DOES THIS PROVIDE OVER THE
EXISTING LAW FOR THE CONSUMER IN
CALIFORNIA? BECAUSE THAT'S I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ABOUT.
AND LET ME JUST LIST A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT ARE BETTER IF THIS
LAW IS ENACTED. FIRST, IN TERMS
OF NOTICE RIGHT NOW, THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THE
MANUFACTURER PROVIDE ANY
INFORMATION AS TO HOW ONE WOULD
ACCESS LEMON LAW REMEDIES UNDER
THE NEW BILL. UNDER THIS BILL,
THERE IS A REQUIREMENT THE
REQUIREMENT IS THAT THE
MANUFACTURER BASICALLY PROVIDED
ON ITS WEBSITE A WAY TO ACCESS
THOSE REMEDIES. NOTICE IN THE
OWNER'S MANUAL AND IN THE
WARRANTY BOOKLET. AND THAT BE
PROVIDED IN BOTH ENGLISH AND IN
SPANISH. IT ALSO BENEFITS THE
CONSUMER BECAUSE UNDER EXISTING
LAW, THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT FOR
THE MANUFACTURER EVEN TO RESPOND
TO A COMPLAINT. THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT UNDER THIS LAW, THE
MANUFACTURER IS REQUIRED TO
RESPOND WITHIN 30 DAYS AND
WITHIN 60 DAYS TO BASICALLY
EITHER COME TO A RESOLUTION OR
YOU'RE OFF TO THE RACES. IT ALSO
PROVIDES, IF YOU ARE ENGAGED IN
LITIGATION FOR EARLY RESOLUTION,
EITHER THROUGH MEDIATION OR IF
YOU CONTINUE, IS THROUGH EARLY
DISCOVERY. THE EXCHANGE OF
DOCUMENTS, THE EXCHANGE OF
INFORMATION, THE EXCHANGE OF
WITNESSES AS EXISTS IN NEWLY
ENACTED LAW HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
ONE OF THE GREAT CHALLENGES,
ESPECIALLY IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS, BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION,
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION, BOTH
FORMALLY AND INFORMALLY, ARE
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH RESPECT TO
THE COURTS. LEMON LAW CASES HAVE
EXPLODED IN THE LAST FEW YEARS,
AND JUST BY WAY OF EXAMPLE, IN
2015, THERE WERE 4306 FILINGS,
WHEREAS IN 2022 THERE WERE
14,892 FILINGS 2023, THAT
INCREASE FROM 14,000, ALMOST
15,000 TO 22,000. AND IN 2024,
WE'RE RIGHT NOW WE'RE SET TO
HAVE OVER 30,000 LEMON LAW
FILINGS, WHICH FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE FAMILIAR WITH CIVIL
LITIGATION, THEY'RE CLOGGING THE
COURTS. AND THEY'RE ALSO HAVING
AN INDIRECT IMPACT ON OTHER
MATTERS. SOON, MANY OF THE
COURTS WILL BE BACK TO WHERE WE
WERE YEARS AGO IN TERMS OF CASES
NOT BEING ABLE TO BE DECIDED FOR
FIVE YEARS, WHICH IS REALLY
UNACCEPTABLE. NOW OF COURSE,
THIS IS A COMPROMISE AND THERE
ARE SOME THAT ARE UNHAPPY WITH
THE COMPROMISE. THIS COMPROMISE
REQUIRES THAT THE CONSUMER
ACTUALLY, LIKE THE OTHER 49
STATES OF THE UNITED STATES,
PROVIDE WRITTEN NOTICE TO THE
MANUFACTURER, NOT JUST THE PHONE
CALL, BUT WRITTEN NOTICE FROM
MANUFACTURERS. SO THE
MANUFACTURER CAN RESPOND. AND IT
ALSO, AS YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD,
BECAUSE OF THE EXPEDITED
DISCOVERY AND THE EXPEDITED
PROCESS, IRONICALLY, THERE ARE
GROUPS OF LAWYERS THAT SAY THAT
THIS BASICALLY REDUCES
LITIGATION EXPENSES. AND ANOTHER
GROUP THAT SAYS IT INCREASES
LITIGATION EXPENSES. IT IS IT IS
I THINK THE JUDGE'S VIEW THAT
THAT WHETHER IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE
OR NOT, WHAT IT DOES IS IT
REDUCES THE NUMBER OF FILINGS
WHICH I THINK LOGICALLY WOULD
LEAD YOU TO BELIEVE THAT IT ALSO
REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
SPENT ON ON LAWYERS, IN SOME
THIS IS NOT A PERFECT BILL, BUT
LIKE ALL COMPROMISES, IT
ACHIEVES SOMETHING FOR THOSE WHO
ENGAGE. AND I THINK THIS IS A
BENEFIT TO CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM, SENATOR GROVE? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, THIS BILL,
LIKE THE AUTHOR SAID, IS WAS
LOBBIED VERY HARD ON BOTH SIDES.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR IF THAT'S OKAY. SENATOR
UMBERG, WOULD YOU TAKE A
QUESTION? I WILL, THANK YOU.
CHAIR. THANK YOU, THROUGH THE
CHAIR, LISTENING TO BOTH SIDES
OF THE ARGUMENT AND YOU
MENTIONED IT WHEN YOU WERE
OPENING ABOUT ONE SIZE SAYS IT
CREATES MORE LITIGATION. AND THE
OTHER SIDE SAYS IT CREATES LESS
LITIGATION, MY QUESTION TO YOU
IS, IS THAT ON THE MORE
LITIGATION SIDE, THE STATEMENT
WAS MADE THAT IF YOU'RE A CAR,
IF YOU'RE CAR SELLER, RETAILER,
AND YOU PROVIDE GOOD SERVICE AND
YOU FIX YOUR CUSTOMER'S PROBLEM,
THERE IS A PERCEPTION THAT THAT
ABILITY IS NOT GOING TO BE THERE
ANYMORE, THAT AS SOON AS THERE
IS A PROBLEM WITH THE VEHICLE,
YOU CAN'T PROVIDE GOOD SERVICE
AND IT'S IMMEDIATELY GOING TO GO
TO LITIGATION. DO YOU SEE THAT
IN THE LANGUAGE, AND IF SO, CAN
YOU TELL ME IF IT'S THERE OR
NOT? NOT THAT I'M DISTRUSTING
WHAT'S BEEN TOLD TO ME. I'M JUST
ASKING. I DISAGREE, OKAY, I
DISAGREE BECAUSE THIS PROCESS
PROVIDES BASICALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESOLVE IT.
PRE-LITIGATION IT ALSO PROVIDES
FOR MEDIATION. AND THEN LASTLY,
IF THERE SHOULD BE LITIGATION,
IT PROVIDES FOR EARLY DISCOVERY.
IT PROVIDES FOR INFORMATION
BEING EXCHANGED, EARLIER ON
RATHER THAN REQUIRING MOTION
PRACTICE AND THAT KIND OF THING.
OKAY, SO JUST TO CLARIFY, IF I'M
A CAR DEALER AND I SELL YOU A
CAR AND YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
YOUR TRANSMISSION, AND IF I AS A
CAR DEALER PROVIDE YOU EXCELLENT
CUSTOMER SERVICE AND I FIX YOUR
TRANSMISSION, YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO IMMEDIATELY DRAG ME INTO
LITIGATION. THERE'S A PROCESS.
WELL, THIS BOTH SUBSTANTIVELY
UNDER THE SONG BEVERLY ACT, YOU
WOULDN'T BE QUALIFIED BASICALLY
FOR SOME SORT OF A BUYBACK IF
YOU'VE JUST BROUGHT IT IN FOR
ONE FIX. AND IT'S BEEN RESOLVED.
BUT EVEN UNDER THE NEW
COMPROMISE PROCESS, YES, YOU YOU
WOULD THE CAR DEALER WOULD NOT
BE OBLIGATED BASICALLY TO ENGAGE
IN SORT OF THE LEMON LAW PROCESS
TO THEN FURTHER RESOLVE THE
ISSUE. OKAY. THANK YOU, I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING MY QUESTION, SIR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NIELLO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. NOW, FIRST OF ALL, AS
AN AUTOMOBILE DEALER, I WE ARE
NOT INVOLVED IN LEMON LAW CASES.
WE'RE OBSERVERS. I WANT TO
STRESS THAT. THAT'S WHY I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT I HAVE TO ABSTAIN
ON THIS. BUT I'LL STATE FIRST OF
ALL THAT THE LEMON LAW WAS
PASSED 50 YEARS AGO, OVER 50
YEARS AGO. I THINK RONALD REAGAN
SIGNED THAT BILL. AND THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT IT NEEDS A REVIEW. I
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT. BUT MY
CONCERN ABOUT THIS BILL IS THE
PROCESS BY WHICH IT WAS
DEVELOPED. AND ALL YOU HAVE TO
LOOK AT TO QUESTION THAT IS THE
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. THIS IS
VERY UNUSUAL. WE DON'T SEE THIS
VERY OFTEN. WE HAVE
MANUFACTURERS THAT SUPPORT IT,
AND WE HAVE MANUFACTURERS THAT
OPPOSE IT. WE HAVE THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS WHO SUPPORT IT, AND WE
HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF CONSUMER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT OPPOSE IT. WE
HAVE OR PEOPLE ORGANIZATIONS OF,
FROM SIMILAR SOURCES WITH
OPPOSITE VIEWS ON THIS. THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THAT. NOW,
ONE THING I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
IN THE COMMITTEE MEETING, THE
OPPONENTS WERE ASKED, IS THERE
ANYTHING IN THIS PROPOSAL THAT
YOU LIKE? I THINK IT WAS THE
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA WHO
ASKED THAT QUESTION. A VERY GOOD
QUESTION THAT I DIDN'T THINK TO
ASK. AND EACH ONE OF THEM SAID
YES, THERE ARE PARTS OF THIS
BILL THAT WE LIKE, BUT NOT ALL
OF IT. SO IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THERE IS A PATH FORWARD. NOW
WITH REGARD TO, BY THE WAY, THE
EXPLOSION OF CASES IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. I DID ASK OUR
DEALERSHIPS WHAT THEIR
OBSERVATION IS ABOUT LEMON LAW
CASES IN THE LAST FEW YEARS, AND
THEY HAVE INCREASED. AND THERE'S
A OBSERVATIONS BY OUR FOLKS.
NUMBER ONE, IT IS INCREASINGLY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES,
INTERESTINGLY. AND MAYBE THAT'S
THE NATURE OF OUR FRANCHISES
BECAUSE WE HAVE OUR
MANUFACTURERS HAVE INTRODUCED
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO THE MARKET
IN THIS TIME FRAME, THERE'S ALSO
BEEN AND IF ANYBODY HAS
PURCHASED A NEW CAR IN THE LAST
HALF DOZEN YEARS, AND IF YOU HAD
ONE THAT WAS MAYBE A HALF DOZEN
YEARS OLDER, BY THE WAY, FIRST
OF ALL, I'D ASK YOU TO BUY NEW
CARS MORE FREQUENTLY, BUT I
DIGRESS, BUT YOU WOULD NOTICE
THAT THERE IS AN INCREDIBLE
INCREASE IN THE ELECTRONIC
CAPABILITY OF THESE VEHICLES,
REALLY, TO THE POINT THAT I FIND
I CAN'T EVEN USE HALF OF THE
CAPABILITIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO ME AS A DRIVER OF THE
VEHICLE. THE TECHNOLOGICAL
DEVELOPMENTS ARE GETTING A
LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF THE
RELIABILITY OF THE VEHICLES.
THAT'S NOT A CRITICISM OF THE
MANUFACTURERS. THAT'S PART OF
THE COMPETITIVE MARKET. TO MAKE
CARS MORE APPEALING TO
CONSUMERS. BUT THAT HAS BEEN A
PART OF THE DYNAMIC OF INCREASED
CASES ALSO. AND PEOPLE HAVE
MENTIONED PROSECUTORIAL,
AGGRESSION, BUT IT IS A CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS WHO ARE ON THE, THE,
THE SIDE OF REFORMING IT. SO
WHETHER THAT'S PART OF IT OR
NOT, I WILL NOT BE THE JUDGE.
NOW, THERE WAS A DISCUSSION IN
THE COMMITTEE ABOUT AFTER IF THE
BILL PASSES NEXT YEAR FOR THE
AUTHOR AND THE PROPONENTS TO
BRING IN THE OTHER SIDE TO TALK
ABOUT THEIR ISSUES AND MAYBE,
HAVE ANOTHER BILL NEXT YEAR. I'M
NOT COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
BECAUSE I'M NOT COMPLETELY
CONVINCED THAT IT WILL HAPPEN,
BUT I WILL TAKE THE COMMITMENT
OF THE AUTHOR AND THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS AND OTHER SUPPORTERS
THAT THEY'RE WILLING TO TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUES OF THE OTHER
SIDE AND SO THEREFORE, I WILL
NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL IN
THE HOPES THAT WE CAN REFORM THE
LEMON LAW IN A IN A WAY THAT
WILL WORK FOR EVERYBODY. BUT
BRING EVERYBODY INVOLVED AND
LET'S NOT SEE A SITUATION WHERE
WE HAVE PEOPLE AND ORGANIZATIONS
OF OTHERWISE COMMON INTERESTS
AGAINST EACH OTHER ON A
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
NEWMAN, IS YOUR MIC UP? OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE ANYONE ELSE OKAY, SEEING NO
MORE MICS. SENATOR UMBERG, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AND I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FAIR OAKS WHO HAS
MORE EXPERTISE IN THIS SPACE
THAN I CERTAINLY DO. AND I JUST,
THE ACTUAL AUTHOR, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, CARO, JUST TOLD ME JUST
MOMENTS AGO THAT HE'S ALREADY
BEGUN SUBSTANTIVE MEETINGS WITH
SOME OF THE MANUFACTURERS WHO
ARE OPPOSED IN ANTICIPATION OF
POTENTIAL LEGISLATION. NEXT
YEAR. THERE'S NO PERFECT
LEGISLATION. WELL EXCEPT FOR
SOME OF MY BILLS, BUT BUT FOR
THE MOST PART, THERE'S NO
PERFECT LEGISLATION. BUT THIS IS
A COMPROMISE, IN MY VIEW, THAT
BENEFITS CONSUMERS. AND I URGE,
AND I VOTE ALL RIGHT, ALL
DISCUSSION. MR. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FINAL
ITEM 240 ALAN, A NO ARCHULETA.
ASHBY NO. ATKINS. BECKER
BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTEZ I DALLEY. DODD DURAZO I
EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ I GROVE.
OTERO JONES I LAIRD I LEMON.
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. MEN I NEWMAN.
WAYNE NEIL. NO JOB. OAK PADILLA
I PORTANTINO. ROTH I RUBIO. SOTO
SKINNER I SMALL. CUEVAS STERN I
UMBERG, I WAHAB. WIENER I WILK.
I DOOLEY. I GROVE. I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
ATKINS. I BECKER. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. DODD EGGMAN. NO
GLASER. ODATO LIMON. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. NEWMAN NGUYEN. OKUBO
PORTANTINO. RUBIO. SATO I SMALL.
CUEVAS I WAHAB. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE MORE TIME.
ARCHULETA BECKER. I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO DODD. I GLASER. I
HURTADO. LIMON. I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN. NGUYEN OKOBO.
PORTANTINO RUBIO. PORTANTINO I.
RUBIO WAHAB I. WE'RE GOING TO
CALL THE ROLL. ONE MORE TIME.
ARCHULETA BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I OTERO. MAGUIRE NEWMAN. NGUYEN
OKOBO. RUBIO I.
IVES 30. NOES FOUR. THE MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM 184. NOW MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM 184. SENATOR DURAZO.
SENATOR DURAZO, YOU'RE PREPARED
FOR 184. MR. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 3123 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES-SAWYER AN
ACT RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION.
SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 3123 ENSURES ETHIC
RULES THAT GOVERN ELECTED
OFFICIALS STATEWIDE APPLY
EQUALLY TO THE LOS ANGELES METRO
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. CALIFORNIA'S
MADE CLEAR THERE'S A UNIFORM.
THERE SHOULD BE A UNIFORM ETHICS
LAW GOVERNING CONTRACT DECISIONS
BY LOCAL AND STATE OFFICIALS.
HOWEVER, L.A. METRO STILL
SUBJECT TO A 30 YEAR OLD LAW
THAT IMPOSES DIFFERENT STANDARDS
ON ITS BOARD MEMBERS REGARDING
CONTRACT DECISIONS AND CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM CONTRACTORS.
THIS HAS MADE IT DIFFICULT FOR
L.A. METRO TO COMPLY WITH THE
MOST RECENT ETHICS STANDARDS.
THE STATE HAS SET IN PLACE, AND
THIS BILL NARROWLY TAILORED,
ALIGNS THE METRO BOARD WITH THE
LEVINE ACT. IT ALSO UPDATES
METRO'S LOBBYIST LOBBYIST
REGISTRATION STATUTE STATUTE AND
CODIFIES THE SPECIFIC AUTHORITY
OF METRO'S ETHICS DEPARTMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 184. ALLEN
OLIVER. ALVARADO. GILL NO.
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I ATKINS. I.
BECKER BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD. I.
CABALLERO CORTEZ I. DALY. NÓ.
DODD I RAZO I EGGMAN. I GLAZER.
NO. GONZALEZ I GROVE. NO.
HURTADO I JONES. NO. LAIRD I
LOWMAN I MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN
I NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO.
JOBO NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO
ROTH. I RUBIO. SATO NO. SKINNER
I SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN. UMBERG
I WAHAB I WIENER. I WILK I
PLEASE, PLEASE, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN LU█T. CALL
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEAR NO.
CABALLERO DALY. NO. I MCGUIRE.
PORTANTINO I RUBIO. I STERN.
SENATOR RUSSELL MOVES TO CALL.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM 189.
SENATOR SKINNER, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SHE IS SECRETARY. YOU
MAY READ THE ASSEMBLY BILL, 1886
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ. AN
ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AB 1886 DEALS
WITH, SOME OF THE ISSUES AROUND
THE, SELF-CERTIFYING THAT, LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE DOING IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE HOUSING
ELEMENT. THE SELF-CERTIFICATION
MEANS THAT THE APPLICATIONS ARE
NOT NECESSARILY BEING PROCESSED
OR OUTRIGHT DENIED AND
ULTIMATELY CAUSING THOUSANDS OF
POTENTIAL UNITS TO BE STALLED.
AB 1886 DOESN'T ESTABLISH A NEW
TOOL, BUT NECESSARILY CLARIFIES
AN EXISTING ONE, AND, IT FOLLOWS
RECENT COURT DECISIONS, SO IT
HELPS PROVIDE CERTAINTY AND
CLEARS UP AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW.
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 1886. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SENATOR GLAZIER? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LOOK, I
CERTAINLY HAVE PROBLEMS WITH
CITIES THAT PLAY GAMES AND TRY
TO AVOID COMPLYING WITH OUR
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS. BUT IT'S
WORTH NOTING IN THIS DEBATE THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DIFFICULTY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
THEIR RESPONSIVENESS TO THE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
THAT HAVE THE OBLIGATION TO
COMPLY. AN AUDIT WAS RECENTLY
CONDUCTED THAT SHOWED THAT THERE
WERE THERE WERE SERIOUS ISSUES
CONSISTENT, WHETHER THERE WAS
CONSISTENT ADVICE BEING GIVEN TO
CITIES, WHETHER THERE WAS
RESPONSIVENESS IN THE TIMELINES
THAT THEY MUST WORK UNDER IN
TERMS OF HOW CITIES NEED TO MAKE
GOOD CHOICES AND SO MY WORRY, MY
WORRY ON A BILL LIKE THIS IS
THAT IT COMES IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE A DYSFUNCTIONAL SYSTEM.
AND WHILE I DON'T WANT TO
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS FOR CITIES
THAT ARE ACTING IMPROPERLY, I
HAVE NO INTEREST IN THAT. I KNOW
NONE OF US DO. YOU KNOW, THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE NOT SO SIMPLE.
AND THAT IS WHAT WORRIES ME
ABOUT THIS BILL, EVEN THOUGH I
KNOW THE INTENTIONS ARE GOOD,
BUT I THINK ALL OF US WHO HAVE
BEEN LISTENING TO YOUR CITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HEAR WHAT
I AM SAYING, AND REALIZE THAT
THIS IS NOT SUCH A SIMPLE
SITUATION AS ONE WOULD LIKE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER, I
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORINDA. AS ALWAYS.
IT'S NOT A SIMPLE SITUATION. IT
WAS NOT A SIMPLE SITUATION THAT
GOT US INTO A DEEP HOUSING
CRISIS OVER THE LAST 50 YEARS.
THIS BILL IS VERY COMMON SENSE
RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE SITUATIONS
WHERE A CITY WILL PROCLAIM THAT
ITS HOUSING ELEMENT IS COMPLIANT
WHEN IT IS NO SUCH THING, AND IT
IS ABSOLUTELY NORMAL TO SAY THAT
WE DON'T ALL GET TO JUST DECIDE
IF WE'RE COMPLYING WITH THE LAW
OR NOT. YOU HAVE AGENCIES THAT
ADMINISTER A LAW THAT MAKE THAT
DECISION. SO, WE SHOULD HAVE WE
SHOULD HAVE CONSISTENCY. AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET MORE
AND MORE CONSISTENT. BUT HAVING
EACH CITY APPLY DIFFERENT RULES
TO ITSELF, THAT'S NOT THE RULE
OF LAW. AND IT'S NOT GOOD
GOVERNMENT. I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE,
SHARING SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM CONTRA
COSTA ROSE AND ORIGINALLY
EVALUATING THIS BILL, I WAS
GOING TO VOTE NO ON IT AND
AGAINST IT. AND THEN AS I
STARTED EVALUATING IT AND
REALIZING, YOU KNOW, MOST OF THE
CITIES IN MY DISTRICT RECOGNIZE
THAT HOUSING IS A HUGE NEED IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW, AND
THEY'RE DOING THE VERY BEST THEY
CAN TO UPZONE REZONE, AND, AND
BEGIN TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
TO THIS HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. I RECOGNIZE
ALSO THAT I'M A I'M A BIG
SUPPORTER OF LOCAL CONTROL. AND,
SO, YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE
CONFLICT FOR ME ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. BUT AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
MENTIONED, YOU KNOW, SOME OF
THESE CITIES AREN'T
PARTICIPATING IN SOLVING THE
PROBLEM. AND IF THIS IS A SMALL
STEP THAT MOVES US IN THAT
DIRECTION TO HELP THESE CITIES
BECOME MORE CREATIVE ON HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE SOLUTION, I THINK MAYBE
THAT'S THE DIRECTION WE NEED TO
GO ON A VERY LIMITED BASIS. AND
I THINK THIS THIS BILL, WHILE
NOT PERFECT, IS ATTEMPTING TO
STRIKE THE PROPER BALANCE
BETWEEN, COMING UP WITH
SOLUTIONS AND ENCOURAGING CITIES
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THEIR AT THEIR
ZONING AND THEIR, UP ZONING AND
WHAT THEY ARE IN THEIR
ENTITLEMENTS ON HELPING GET THIS
STUFF BUILT IN CALIFORNIA. MANY
OF US HAVE KIDS THAT ARE
TEENAGERS OR IN THEIR 20S OR
30S, AND I KNOW SOME OF YOU HAVE
ALREADY SHARED THAT YOUR KIDS
HAVE MOVED OUT OF THE STATE. I'M
FORTUNATE THAT ALL OF MY, MY
THREE KIDS AND MY SON IN LAW AND
MY FUTURE DAUGHTER IN LAW ARE
ALL IN THEIR 20S AND 30S, HAVE
CHOSEN SO FAR TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN SAN DIEGO
SPECIFICALLY. BUT I CAN SEE A
DAY THAT IF THESE IF THERE'S NOT
SOLUTIONS TO THIS HOUSING CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA, THAT MORE AND
MORE OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO PICK UP AND MOVE OUT OF
STATE, AND IT'S GOING TO BECOME
A THIS HOUSING PROBLEM IS GOING
TO BE CONTINUE TO BE, A
CHALLENGE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO
I WOULD ENCOURAGE US TO BE AS
CREATIVE AND OPEN MINDED AS
POSSIBLE WHEN SMALL SOLUTIONS
COME UP. I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
1886. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE, SENATOR
DASCHLE? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I TOO, JUST
WANT TO RISE IN SUPPORT. I KNOW
THAT THIS IS VERY A
CONTROVERSIAL TYPE OF
LEGISLATION, BUT SOMEBODY WHO
SAT ON A BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
FOR 16 YEARS DID A GENERAL PLAN
AMENDMENT AND HAD A CITY RIGHT
NEXT DOOR WHICH WAS ANNEXING
INTO THE COUNTIES. AND THEIR
THEIR ELEMENTS WERE BASED OFF OF
HOW THEY WERE GOING TO GO IN THE
CITY, KNOWING ALL ALONG THAT
THEY WOULD NEVER BUILD IN THAT
AREA BECAUSE THEY REALLY DIDN'T
WANT TO BUILD IN THAT AREA.
THAT'S WHERE THEY CHOSE TO PUT
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT, BECAUSE
IT WAS VERY EXPENSIVE, ROCKY
GROUND AND VERY UNEVEN TERRAIN.
SO THESE TYPES OF SITUATIONS
HAPPEN THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA,
AND THERE ARE SOME CITIES WHO
JUST DON'T WANT GROWTH, AND
THERE ARE SOME COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T WANT GROWTH. BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, WE NEED THAT
GROWTH AS THE SENATOR FROM SANTE
MENTIONED, AND WE NEED THEM TO
PUT A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT,
DEVELOPMENT TOGETHER OR THEIR
GENERAL PLAN TOGETHER IN A WAY
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY BUILD
HOMES. SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I
WILL BE SUPPORTING AB 1886.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION IN THE DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, SENATOR EBCLC? THANK YOU.
MR. PRESIDENT, I WASN'T GOING TO
SPEAK ON THIS MEASURE TODAY, BUT
I DID SIT ON IN THIS COMMITTEE,
AND I AND I REMEMBER HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS I WANT TO ECHO THE
CONCERNS FROM THE SENATOR FROM
CONTRA COSTA WITH REGARDS TO THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE SEEN WITHIN
COMMITTEE AND WITHIN OUR CITIES
PARTICIPATING WITHIN HCD AND THE
HISTORY OF THE IMPERFECT
PRACTICES THAT ARE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT AND BE ABLE TO
APPROVE THE HOUSING ELEMENTS FOR
OUR VARIOUS CITIES. AND THIS IS
WHERE THE LOCAL CONTROL ALSO
COMES INTO PLAY, IS THAT WE HAVE
CITIES WHO ARE TRYING TO DEVISE
THEIR THEIR HOUSING ELEMENTS AND
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO STANDARD
PRACTICES FOR THE STATE, FOR THE
DEPARTMENT, THERE'S LITERALLY
THERE'S VERY SUBJECTIVE OPINIONS
AND ASSESSMENTS WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE HOUSING ELEMENTS FOR OUR
CITIES, WHICH IS A CHALLENGE FOR
OUR LOCAL CITIES AS WELL, WHEN
THEY'RE ACTING IN GOODWILL. DO
WE HAVE CITIES THAT MIGHT NOT BE
ACTING IN GOOD FAITH?
ABSOLUTELY. BUT WE DO HAVE A LOT
OF CITIES WHO ARE ACTING IN GOOD
FAITH. AND UNTIL THE STATE GETS
THE SYSTEM RIGHT, UNTIL THE
STATE GETS THEIR DEPARTMENT AND
THE AND THE QUALIFICATIONS AND
THEIR STANDARDS OF PRACTICE,
STANDARD, WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN APPROVING AND BEING
ABLE TO WORK IN A WAY THAT IS,
WORTHY OR NOT WORTHY, BUT HAVE
MERIT IN OUR STATE, THEREFORE, I
CANNOT UNTIL WE HAVE THOSE
STANDARD PRACTICES. AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH ANYONE ON
THAT LEGISLATION MOVING FORWARD.
BUT UNTIL WE HAVE THOSE
STANDARDS FOR THE FOR HCD AND
NOT HAVE ARBITRARY STANDARDS,
WHEN ASSESSING THOSE HOUSING
ELEMENTS FOR OUR LOCAL CITIES,
WHICH CREATE VERY SUBJECTIVE
APPROVALS, I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT SUCH POLICIES. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NO FURTHER, MIKE
MICROPHONES. SENATOR SKINNER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
BY OUR COLLEAGUES. AND I WANT TO
GO BACK TO SOME OF THOSE WHO
SPOKE IN SUPPORT. ONE OF ANOTHER
KEY REASON THIS IS NEEDED IS IT
DOES NOT BENEFIT ANYONE, NOT A
HOME BUILDER OR A CITY, TO HAVE
LONG DRAWN OUT COURT CASES. AND
WHEN THERE'S NOT CLARITY IN SUCH
THINGS AS THIS PARTICULAR, BILL
ADDRESSES, THEN YOU END UP WITH
COURT CASES. AND THE REASON THAT
HCD AND OTHERS HAVE WORKED WITH
THE AUTHOR ON THIS BILL IS TO
GET THAT CLARITY. SO WE CAN
AVOID LAWSUITS AND, AND THOSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE LAW WILL BE
FINE. THEY HAVE NOTHING TO WORRY
ABOUT. AND THOSE THAT ARE NOT,
THEN THEY ARE STILL GOING TO
ALWAYS HAVE THE PROBLEM OF THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT POTENTIALLY NOT
CERTIFIED. BUT THIS ADDS
CLARITY. IT WILL HELP REDUCE
LAWSUITS. AND WITH THAT, I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB 1886.
THANK YOU. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON. FINAL ITEM 189
ALLEN BRAUTIGAM, ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE. DALI. AYE
DODD. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
NO. NILO NO. COBO. NO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO
CIERTO. NO SKINNER. AYE. SMALL
COVERS. AYE. STERN UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. NÓ WIENER. AYE. WILK NO.
WE WANT TO MOVE THE CALLER OR.
LET'S. LET'S CALL THE ROLL ONE
MORE TIME, PLEASE. OAN I'LL
RODA-GIL MOVING ARCHULETA.
BECKER BRADFORD. CABALLERO. DODD
AYE. GLAZER GROVE. LIMON MAGUIRE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO STERN.
SENATOR SKINNER MOVES A CALL.
BACK. OKAY, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO THE NEXT FOUR
FILE ITEMS ARE ALL. SENATOR
BRADFORD, FILE ITEM 161, THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2672. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2672
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
AN ACT RELATING TO ENERGY.
SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 2672 I AM
PRESENTING THIS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
IT ALLOWS CERTAIN PROJECT HOME
KEY SITES TO RECEIVE DISCOUNTED
UTILITY BILLS. POPULATION OF
PROJECT HOMEKEY SITES ARE
INDIVIDUALLY ELIGIBLE FOR
DISCOUNTED BILLS, BUT DUE TO
THEIR HOUSING ARRANGEMENTS,
CANNOT ACCESS THEM. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO STATE COST OR NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OAN AYE, GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY.
DODD AYE. DURAZO EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE FURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN MILO. AYE. AYE. BUT.
HIÂU. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
MEMBERS. WE HAVE. WE HAVE A
MEMBER OFF THE FLOOR. SO WE'RE
GOING TO BE ESTABLISHING CALLS
ON THESE BILLS. SENATOR BRADFORD
MOVES A CALL. ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM 167 A AB 3263.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3263 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS. SENATOR
BRADFORD, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. I
DON'T SEE IT.
IN THE. I DON'T HAVE THAT ONE.
OKAY, BUT EVERYONE. I DON'T HAVE
THAT ONE WITH ME RIGHT NOW. SIGN
IN HERE. SENATOR, DO YOU WANT TO
PASS TEMPORARILY? PASS. PASS
TEMPORARILY. BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE THAT. OKAY. NEXT UP THEN,
FILE ITEM 205, THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2441. SENATOR BRADFORD'S
PREPARED SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2441 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDWELL. AN ACT RELATING
TO SCHOOL SAFETY. SENATOR.
BRADFORD. YES. AB 2441. ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY, KARA
WILL GIVE OUR TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS THE OPTION RATHER
THAN REQUIRE THEM TO REFER
STUDENTS TO LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
BEING UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF OR
IN POSSESSION OF A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE, NARCOTICS OR ALCOHOL,
AND WILL DECRIMINALIZE WILLFUL
DISTURBANCE OF STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS. CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES OUR TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS TO REFER STUDENTS
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR INCIDENTS
LIKE LOUD AND DISRUPTIVE NOISE
AT SCHOOL, OR BEING IN
POSSESSION OF A VAPE PEN OR
ALCOHOL, REGARDLESS OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OR STUDENTS
SITUATION. EVEN IF A TEACHER
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION WITH THE HEALTH BASED
APPROACH TO GET STUDENTS TO HELP
THEY NEED, THEY ARE FORCED TO
REFER THEM TO LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
RISK BEING FIRED. THESE ARE
UNNECESSARY REFERRALS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND HAVE LED TO
ALARMING DISPARITIES IN TYPES OF
STUDENTS MOST LIKELY TO SUFFER.
THESE HARMS. STUDENTS OF COLOR
AND STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE MORE OFTEN REFERRED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CITED AND
ARRESTED OVER POLICING IN OUR
SCHOOLS HAS FUELED THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE AND ONLY HINDERS
THE ABILITY FOR STUDENTS TO GET
RESOURCES NEEDED. NOTHING IN
THIS BILL PROHIBITS THE TEACHERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS FROM CALLING
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS BILL TAKES
THE STEPS FORWARD IN FIGHTING
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE
AND ENSURING THAT SCHOOLS ARE
SAFE, SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENTS
FOR ALL OUR CHILDREN, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BRADFORD. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION MEMBERS. SENATOR
PORTANTINO YES, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE RELUCTANTLY.
I'M GOING TO LAY OFF THE BILL,
NOT BECAUSE I DON'T AGREE WITH
MANY OF THE TENANTS AND THE
PERSPECTIVES THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES ARTICULATED,
BUT IN THE LAST SESSION, WE
WORKED VERY DILIGENTLY ON A BILL
WITH LOTS OF STAKEHOLDERS TO
PROTECT SCHOOLS FROM CREDIBLE
THREATS OF VIOLENT SHOOTERS. AND
WE SAW IN MINNEAPOLIS WHEN A
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAD EVIDENCE OF
A CREDIBLE THREAT AND DIDN'T
INVESTIGATE THAT CREDIBLE
THREAT. THAT SHOOTER THEN WENT
TO SCHOOL AND KILLED PEOPLE. AND
SO I'M A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED OF
CONFUSION BETWEEN THOSE EFFORTS
ON INVESTIGATING ACTUAL, REAL,
CREDIBLE THREATS. AND, YOU KNOW,
THIS BILL, THE HEART AND SOUL
AND MANY OF THE PROVISIONS IN IT
ARE SPOT ON. BUT I JUST HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW IT WOULD
INTERACT WITH PRIOR LEGISLATION.
AND SO FOR THAT, RELUCTANTLY,
I'M GOING TO BE LAYING OFF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? SEEING NONE, SENATOR
BRADFORD, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU. THE SAFETY AND WELL-BEING
OF NOT ONLY OUR STUDENTS, BUT
OUR TEACHERS IS AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THIS LEGISLATION. BUT THIS
STILL IS NOT NECESSARILY WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT PRESENT HARM BY
HAVING WEAPONS AND STUFF. THIS
IS IN POSSESSION OF A VAPE PEN
THAT WE FIND MORE LIKELY THAN
NOT, CHILDREN OF COLOR BEING
SUSPENDED AND EXPELLED OUT OF
SCHOOL. WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID
THOSE UNNECESSARY SITUATIONS OR
KIDS WHO MIGHT HAVE CONSUMED
SOME KIND OF DRUG OR ALCOHOL.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE ADDRESSING.
NOT THAT STUDENT THAT HAS A
WEAPON OR ARE THREATENING
TEACHERS OR ADMINISTRATORS, OR
EVEN FELLOW STUDENTS AT ALL. SO
IT'S A COMMON SENSE APPROACH. I
KNOW IT'S A FINE LINE THAT WE
ALL HAVE TO CONCERN OUR
CONCERNED ABOUT. WE WANT OUR
SCHOOLS TO BE SAFE. WE WANT OUR
CHILDREN TO BE SAFE. WE SAW WHAT
HAPPENED IN TEXAS. WE'VE SEEN IT
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THIS IS
A JUST APPROACH THAT JUST GIVES
A LITTLE BIT MORE BALANCE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE. ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OH, EXCUSE
ME. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE,
SENATOR? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I JUST WANTED TO
OFFER SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. IS
THAT. SENATOR, UNFORTUNATELY,
WE'VE COMPLETED THE DEBATE AND
HE CLOSED. SO I'M SO SORRY THAT
YOU DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. DID YOU HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE UP? AND I DID NOT SEE
IT. I WELL, I THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING UP BEFORE YOU CLOSED, BUT
YOU KNOW, IT'S ALL IN THE
GLANCE. BUT I WAS RISING AS YOU
WERE COMING THIS WAY. SO I FEEL
LIKE IT'S A TIMING. WE DO HAVE
INSTANT REPLAY. WE COULD COULD
CHECK, BUT. BUT THE POINT IS.
BUT MAY I, SENATOR, I WOULD SAY
THAT I DID NOT GET ANY GUIDANCE
THAT YOUR MICROPHONE WAS UP. I
THINK YOU HAVE MADE YOUR POINT
ABOUT YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL,
BILL AND THE OPTIONS THAT THIS
BILL PROVIDES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THAT, SENATOR.
APPRECIATE THAT ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. THE SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A
PRODIGAL NØ ARCHULETA. ASHBY
ATKINS. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DAWLEY
NØ. DODD BARRASSO. AYE. EGGMAN
GLASER. NO. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
NO. OTERO NO. JONES NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN AYE. MEN. NO. MEN. NO
NEWMAN. NGUYEN NO. MILO. NO JOE.
BOGUE. NO Dð. AYE PORTANTINO.
ROTH RUBIO. CIERTO NO. SKINNER.
AYES MOORLACH. RIVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK NO. AS.
SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 208. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2159. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2159 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MANCINI. AN ACT RELATING
TO COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 2159 AUTHORIZES
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS,
ALSO CALLED HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS, TO USE ELECTRONIC
VOTING SYSTEMS FOR SPECIFIC
ASSOCIATION BUSINESS LIKE BOARD
ELECTIONS AND APPROVING
DOCUMENTS. THIS BILL AIMS TO
INCREASE HOMEOWNER HOMEOWNER
PARTICIPATION BY PROVIDING
ANOTHER METHOD OF VOTING. THAT'S
CONVENIENT. 2159 IS PERMISSIVE
GIVING ASSOCIATIONS THE OPTION
TO ADOPT ELECTRONIC VOTING. 2159
INCLUDES MULTIPLE NOTIFICATIONS
TO MEMBERS ON HOW TO OPT OUT
DURING THE ELECTION PROCESS AND
ANNUALLY THROUGH THE MEMBER
NOTICE. 27 DIFFERENT STATES USE
ELECTRONIC VOTING AND HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION ELECTIONS AND IT'S
PROVEN TECHNOLOGY. RECENT
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CONCERNS BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE
AND ENSURE THE ASSOCIATION'S
OPERATING RULES WILL WILL ALL
INCLUDE A MINIMUM SET OF
CRITERIA TO PROTECT MEMBERS
INTERESTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THE MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI.
AYE. DODD TORAZO. AYE EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE I ADATO. AYE JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE. COBO
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER SMALL. CUEVAS STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. LIMON. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. SENATOR
BRADFORD MOVES A CALL. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM
167. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3263.
THE FLOOR MANAGER IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE BILL.
SENATE BILL. ASSEMBLY BILL 3263
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. AN
ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS. SENATOR. BRADFORD.
THANK YOU. AB 3263 WILL
STABILIZE THE ELECTRICITY RATE
FLUCTUATIONS BY ALLOWING AN
ELECTRIC UTILITY TO REQUEST THE
PUC AUTHORIZATION TO FINANCE
ONGOING WILDFIRE MITIGATION
EFFORTS AS WELL AS COSTS DERIVED
FROM DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCIES THROUGH THE USE OF
BONDS AS WILDFIRE SEASON GROWS
LONGER AND MORE DESTRUCTIVE,
ELECTRIC UTILITIES HAVE
INCREASED THEIR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND OTHER FORMS OF
WILDLIFE MITIGATION. CONSTANT
WILDFIRE MITIGATION HAS LED TO A
SIGNIFICANT RATE HIKE RATE HIKES
FOR RATEPAYERS. AB 3263 SIX
SEEKS TO CODIFY THE PRUDENT USE
OF BONDS TO HELP PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED RATE RELIEF ON OUR ENERGY
BILLS, AGAIN, ONLY UPON THE
APPROVAL OF THE PUC. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BRADFORD.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE, SENATOR
DALY. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I TOO, RISE
IN SUPPORT. THIS IS A GREAT TOOL
TO BE ABLE TO BOND AND GRAB
THOSE FUNDS UP FRONT, DO THE
WORK THAT THEY NEED TO DO BEFORE
THE RATES CONTINUE TO GO UP FOR
ALL THE SERVICES THAT NEED TO BE
PROVIDED FOR THOSE SECURING
THOSE LINES AND MAKING IT SAFE
FOR CALIFORNIANS. SO THIS WILL
ACTUALLY DRIVE THE RATE DOWN
BECAUSE THEY'RE ABLE TO BORROW
THAT MONEY AGAINST THE OR USE
THE BOND MONEY TO DO THE WORK.
AS YOU KNOW, EVERY DAY THAT WE
DON'T DO THE WORK, THE COST GOES
UP. SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
KEEP OUR RATES LOW USING THOSE
ASSETS THAT THEY HAVE AVAILABLE
TO THEM TO BOND AGAINST. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AB 3263.
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE. SENATOR
BRADFORD, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. AYE VOTE
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
I ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. I BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER. I BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE DALLI.
AYE. DODD BARRASSO. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
NAVARRE. AYE. MIN NO. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO OKOBO.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH I
AYE. RUBIO I. SATO. NO SKINNER.
SMALL. CUEVAS I. STERN I'M. BERG
WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
SENATOR. SENATOR. BRADFORD MOVES
THE CALL.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING
BACK ON THE FILE. WE'RE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM 22, SB 312 BY
SENATOR WIENER. HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. THE
SENATE BILL 312 BY SENATOR
WIENER. AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. SENATOR
WIENER. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 312 IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS REFLECT AGREEMENTS.
WE NEGOTIATED WITH BOTH THE
CHAIR OF THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY,
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND CHAIR
O'BRIEN IN ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES. THESE AMENDMENTS
FURTHER ENSURE THAT SB 886, THE
CEQA EXEMPTION THAT WE CREATED A
FEW YEARS AGO FOR STUDENT
HOUSING AT UC, CSU AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES COULD BE EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENTED. THE BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY A NUMBER OF STUDENT
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM 22. ALLEN I ALVARADO.
GILMAN I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I AYE
ATKINS I BECKER. BLAKE SPEER.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. CORTEZ I
DAWLEY I DODD BARRASSO. I EGGMAN
I GLASER. GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO. JONES I LAIRD. LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE. MENJIVAR AYE. MIN I
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN I NILO I
OCHOA. EBCLC I PADILLA. I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SATO. I SKINNER. SMALL QUAVERS I
STERN. I UMBERG, I WAHAB. I
WIENER, I WILK I SENATOR WIENER
MOVES A CALL. SENATOR WIENER,
YOU'RE UP AGAIN WOULD FILE ITEM
26 SB 951. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 951 BY SENATOR
WIENER. AN ACT RELATING TO
COASTAL RESOURCES. SENATOR
WIENER FLOOR IS YOURS. I THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. SB 951 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. AMENDMENTS MADE IN
THE ASSEMBLY WERE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE, INCLUDING REMOVING A
PORTION OF THE BILL TO ADDRESS
CHAPTER RING OUT ISSUES. THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES, YOU CAN CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 26. SECRETARY.
THANK YOU. ALLEN I RODA-GIL I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO CORTEZ I DALI. DODD
GARZA I EGGMAN I GLASER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO JONES
I LAIRD I LIMÓN. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN. NEWMAN I NGUYEN
I MILO. I TURBO I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO. ROTH I RUBIO I SATO
I SKINNER. SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN.
I UMBERG, I WAHAB I WIENER. I
WILK, I MIN I. SENATOR WIENER
MOVES THE CALL.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE FOR ONE.
ASSEMBLYMAN ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. SENATOR BERKSHIRE.
PLEASE READ SECRETARY. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2127 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AND AQUILINA.
REGISTRATION SENATOR. BERKSHIRE.
I THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
CALIFORNIA'S NEW MOTOR VOTER LAW
HAS BEEN A SUCCESS, WITH NEARLY
26 MILLION NEW OR UPDATED VOTER
REGISTRATIONS SINCE IT LAUNCHED
IN 2018. NOTWITHSTANDING THIS
SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENT,
THERE HAVE BEEN CHALLENGES
MODERNIZING THE VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS AT THE DMV.
THE NEW MOTOR VOTER TASK FORCE
WAS ESTABLISHED TO MONITOR THE
LAW'S ROLLOUT AND ADVISE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THE DMV
ON ITS EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION.
THERE ARE SEVERAL UPDATES AND
SYSTEM CHANGES FORTHCOMING, AND
THERE HAVE BEEN TECHNOLOGY
DRIVEN IMPLEMENTATION DELAYS AT
DMV. THEREFORE AB 2127 WOULD
EXTEND THE OPERATION OF THE TASK
FORCE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
CONTINUED OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE
PROPER IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
FULL EFFECTIVENESS OF THE NEW
MOTOR VOTER LAWS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR JONES, FOR WHAT PURPOSE?
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I HAVE
HELPFUL AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK
TO AMEND AB 2127 SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ THOSE AMENDMENTS
AMENDMENT AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR
JONES. IS THAT ONE? SENATOR
JONES? THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, COLLEAGUES,
OUR CAMPUSES, OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES WERE BOMBARDED WITH A
WAVE OF VIOLENT AND ILLEGAL
PROTESTS. THESE PROTESTS LEFT
OUR HISTORICAL CAMPUSES
VANDALIZED, CREATED AN UNSAFE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT, AND
DISTURBINGLY, ILLEGALLY
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST JEWISH
STUDENTS. AS WE APPROACH THE NEW
ACADEMIC YEAR, CAMPUSES ARE
PREPARING JUST RIGHT NOW TO BE
BATTLEGROUNDS FOR MORE OF THESE
LAWLESS PROTESTS. LET ME BE
CLEAR VIOLENCE ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES ARE NOT PROTECTED
UNDER THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
REGARDLESS OF YOUR POLITICAL
VIEWS. THAT INCLUDES ILLEGAL
ENCAMPMENTS, VANDALISM,
OBSTRUCTING CAMPUS ACCESS,
HOLDING INDIVIDUALS HOSTAGE,
HARASSMENT AND VIOLENCE. THESE
ARE CRIMINAL ACTS AND
PERPETRATORS MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FAILURE TO
CONTROL THESE SITUATIONS IS
UNACCEPTABLE IN ALL CASES, BUT
ESPECIALLY ON OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES THAT RECEIVE LARGE
AMOUNTS OF TAXPAYER FUNDS. FOR
EXAMPLE, WE SAW AT UCLA AN
UNACCEPTABLE FOR EXAMPLE, WE SAW
AT UCLA IS AN UNACCEPTABLE. AND
RECENTLY, A COURT RULED THAT THE
UNIVERSITY IS AT FAULT FOR
ALLOWING RELIGIOUS
DISCRIMINATION ON CAMPUS. WE
MUST SEND A CLEAR AND
UNEQUIVOCAL MESSAGE THAT THIS
TYPE OF BEHAVIOR WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED IN OUR STATE. THE
AMENDMENT SET BEFORE US TODAY DO
TWO THINGS TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ILLEGAL
PROTESTS. ACTIVITIES ON OUR
PUBLIC COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES. FIRST, IF OUR COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS WON'T DO THEIR
JOBS, WE SHOULD STOP PAYING
THEM. THESE AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
THAT FUNDS USED FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT DURING ILLEGAL
PROTESTS, AS WELL AS ANY LEGAL
DAMAGES RESULTING FROM SUCH
PROTESTS, COME SOLELY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIONS BUDGETS OF THE
INSTITUTIONS INVOLVED. IT IS
TIME TO DEFUND FAILING
ADMINISTRATIONS. SECOND,
CRIMINAL CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR MUST
HAVE CONSEQUENCES. THESE
AMENDMENTS REVOKE CAL GRANTS
FROM STUDENTS WHO ARE FOUND
GUILTY OR ARE EXPELLED FOR THEIR
INVOLVEMENT IN ILLEGAL PROTESTS,
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING INCITEMENT
TO RIOT, VANDALISM AND
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS. TAXPAYERS
SHOULD NOT BE BANKROLLING
LAWLESSNESS ON OUR CAMPUSES,
WHETHER THAT'S FUNDING
INEFFECTIVE ADMINISTRATIONS OR
SUBSIDIZING CRIMINAL PROTESTERS
TUITIONS. THESE AMENDMENTS SEND
A STRONG MESSAGE ILLEGAL,
VIOLENT, DISCRIMINATORY PROTESTS
WILL NOT BE TOLERATED IN OUR
STATE AND TAXPAYERS WILL NOT
BEAR THE COST. I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND SUPPORT ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. SENATOR GONZALES,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I'M GOING TO SPEAK TO
THE MERITS OF THE BILL. AB 2127
WILL ENSURE CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO CLOSE VOTER REGISTRATION GAPS
BY MAKING IT EASIER FOR ELIGIBLE
VOTERS TO REGISTER OR UPDATE
THEIR REGISTRATION. KANSEN LAY
ON THE TABLE. AND SO I THEREFORE
MOVE THAT THESE AMENDMENTS BE
LAID ON THE TABLE AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ TO LAY THE
MOTION ON THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE. THIS IS NOT DEBATABLE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMON AYE.
MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO NO.
COBO. NO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
AYE SATO. NO. SKINNER SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
NO. GROVE. NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER GLAZER.
HURTADO. MCGUIRE SKINNER. AYES
26. NOES NINE. THE AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN LAID ON THE TABLE. NOW
WE'LL RETURN BACK TO THE BILL IN
CHIEF. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION, EVENT,
HEARING AND SEEING? NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FINAL ITEM ONE FOR ONE ON Ã
ALVARADO. GILL NØ. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALI.
NÓ. DODD AYE. CARRASCO AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO JONES. NO
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO. COBO.
NO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. AYE SATO.
NO SKINNER. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. AYE.
WAHAB Ã. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
NÓ. ASHBY. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER. GLAZER
HURTADO. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
SKINNER. SENATOR BLAKE MOVES THE
CALL. TEN. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
TO ITEM 210. SENATOR WAHAB, ARE
YOU PREPARED? SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. THE ASSEMBLY BILL 846 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. AN ACT
RELATING TO LOW INCOME HOUSING.
SENATOR WAHAB, THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA, I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 846. THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
LOW INCOME RENTERS LIVING IN
PUBLICLY ASSISTED, AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FROM SIGNIFICANT RENT
SPIKES. THE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM, OR LIHTC, IS
A CRITICAL SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION
AND REHAB NATIONWIDE. THE TAX
CREDIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE TCAC,
WHICH OVERSEES THE PROGRAM,
RECENTLY ADOPTED REGULATIONS
THAT APPLY A RENT CAP TO LIHTC
PROPERTIES AS A CONDITION OF
GETTING NEW TAX CREDITS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE DID NOT
BELIEVE IT HAD CLEAR AUTHORITY
TO APPLY THE NEW CAP TO EXISTING
PROPERTIES. THIS LEAVES TENANTS
IN EXISTING PROPERTIES
INCREDIBLY VULNERABLE TO HIGH
RENT INCREASES. WE WANT TO AVOID.
AB 846 PROVIDES THE NECESSARY
CLARITY BY DIRECTING THE TAX
CREDIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE TO
ESTABLISH A LIMIT ON RENT
INCREASES IN EXISTING LOGITECH
PROPERTIES IN CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 210. ALLEN
I, GILL NO. ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. CORTEZ I
DALY DODD. I DURAZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HURTADO I JONES. NO. LAIRD I
LIMON I MCGUIRE. MINGYUAN I MIN.
NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO.
OKOBO NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. NO SKINNER.
MAO. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG. I
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK. NO
SENATOR WAHAB MOVES TO CALL.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR LEMON WITH
FILE ITEM 215 AB 2182.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. THE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2182 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAYNIE. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC WORKS. SENATOR LEMON,
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2182 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAYNIE. AB 2182 IS A
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM FOR
PREVAILING WAGE LAW. IT WILL
MAKE CURRENT PREVAILING WAGE
DETERMINATIONS APPLICABLE TO
LOCAL PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS AT
THE TIME THAT THE WORK IS
PERFORMED, WHICH CREATES AN EVEN
PLAYING FIELD FOR THE UNION
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. WHEN
BIDDING ON LOCAL PUBLIC WORK
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE. THE
BILL ALSO STRENGTHENS
ENFORCEMENT OF PREVAILING WAGE
LAW, WHICH INCLUDES ADDING THE
ABILITY FOR REPRESENTATIVES FROM
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEES, REASONABLE ACCESS TO
ACTIVATE PUBLIC WORKS JOB SITES.
ADDITIONALLY, AB 2182 HELPS
ENSURE UNION CONTRACTORS ARE NOT
AT A DISADVANTAGE WHEN COMPETING
FOR PUBLIC WORKS, AND THAT THE
PREVAILING WAGE RATES REQUIRED
TO BE PAID ON PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS REFLECT THE ACTUAL
PREVAILING WAGE RATES POSTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AT THE TIME. THE WORK
IS PERFORMED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 215. ALLEN A
GILL NO. ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY NÓ DODD. TERRAZZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROVE. NO. HURTADO I JONES. NO
LAIRD I LOWMAN I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
NO. NILO NO COBO. NO. PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO.
SEYARTO. NO SKINNER. SMALL.
CUEVAS I STERN. I UMBERG. HI I
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK. I SENATOR
LOWMAN MOVES THE CALL.
OR PASS OUT THE AMENDMENT. NEXT
UP WE HAVE FINAL ITEM 216. YEAH,
YEAH. WE'RE GOING TO JUST
GETTING READY.
ALL RIGHT. SENATOR EGGMAN, SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ FILE ITEM 216. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2136 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER. AN ACT RELATING TO
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. SENATOR
EGGMAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. AS THE HOUR DRIES
LATE, WE ALL BEGIN TO FEEL A
LITTLE BIT HOSTILE. BUT TODAY
I'M RISING TO PRESENT AB 2136 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
JONES-SAWYER. AB 2136 CLARIFIES
THE LEGALITY OF ACCESSING AND
PROVIDING DRUG CHECKING SERVICES.
THERE ARE THOSE AMONGST US WHO
USE DRUGS. WE WANT THEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO CHECK
THOSE TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
NOT THINGS LIKE FENTANYL,
TRICLOSAN STUCK IN THEM TO BE
ABLE TO PROTECT THEMSELVES AND
OTHERS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? GONNA LIFT YOUR MIC
ON THE AMENDMENTS. THERE YOU GO.
OKAY, HERE WE GO. ASSEMBLY IS
ONLY VIDAK. OKAY. SHE'S THREE
TIMES. SHE SAID IT TO ME BECAUSE
SHE'S GONNA. SENATOR CHIRLA.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I HAVE
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK. YOU HAVE
HELPFUL AMENDMENTS? YES. OKAY.
YES THERE ARE AMENDMENTS AT THE
DUST. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
AMENDMENT AMENDMENTS. AMENDMENTS
BY SENATOR OKUBO SET ONE.
SENATOR OTOBOKE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I HAVE THIS WONDERFUL
UNITING AND FRIENDLY AMENDMENT
THAT WOULD EXEMPT TIPS FROM
STATE INCOME TAX PROVIDING
RELIEF TO CALIFORNIANS IN THE
SERVICE AND HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRIES. MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY
HAVE LIVED IN THE SERVICE
INDUSTRY, INCLUDING MY MOM WHEN
SHE WAS A SINGLE MOM. TIPS
AREN'T REGULAR INCOME. DESPITE
THE FACT THAT CURRENT TAX LAW
TREATS THEM AS SUCH. TIPS ARE
NOT GUARANTEED, THEY ARE NOT
CONSISTENT, AND THEY'RE NOT
ENOUGH TO MAKE ENDS MEET. AS A
MATTER OF FACT, IT'S A GESTURE
OF GRATITUDE FOR A SERVICE THAT
GOES ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT IS
EXPECTED. THIS STRUGGLE IS
BIPARTISAN. BOTH FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS SUPPORT A
FEDERAL TAX EXEMPTION ON TIPS.
THIS IS BECAUSE THEY BOTH
RECOGNIZE THAT WE MUST MAKE
EVERY EFFORT TO HELP OUR WORKING
CLASS TOGETHER. TOGETHER, WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
HISTORY TODAY ON THIS FLOOR BY
COMING TOGETHER TO PROVIDE
RELIEF TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS, BECAUSE THE SENATE
WILL LIKELY TABLE THESE
AMENDMENTS UNLESS WE ARE
COURAGEOUS. TODAY AND WANT TO
PROVE THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO BE
PARTIZAN ALWAYS, I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S CLEAR WHAT THIS
VOTE MEANS. VOTING AYE TO LAY
THESE AMENDMENTS FRIENDLY.
UNITING ON THE TABLE MEANS YOU
DO NOT SUPPORT A TAX EXEMPTION
ON TIPS AND YOU WON'T TAKE MUCH
NEEDED ACTION TODAY TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIANS SERVICE
AND HOSPITALITY WORKERS AND
REJECT TABLING THE AMENDMENTS
AND MAKE HISTORY TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, THIS
BILL PROVIDES A PUBLIC HEALTH
CENTERED APPROACH TO REDUCING
DRUG RELATED DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA. I THEREFORE MOVE
THAT THESE AMENDMENTS BE LAID ON
THE TABLE AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY SENATOR GONZALEZ IS
ASKING FOR AYE VOTE, LAYING THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE. THIS IS
NON-DEBATABLE SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI. ALL
RIGHT. YOU NØ ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO.
JONES NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE MENJIVAR. AYE. MIN AYE
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO
NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
AYE. SATO. NO SKINNER. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HURTADO. AYE MAGUIRE. SKINNER ON
A VOTE TO 29 TO 9, THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN LAID ON THE
TABLE, AND WE'LL RETURN NOW TO
THE BILL IN CHIEF. SENATOR
EGGMAN, IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM?
I JUST KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THAT
IT IS THAT WE ALL FOCUS ON THE
FENTANYL CRISIS, AND THIS IS ONE
WAY TO DO IT. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES. THANK YOU. SEEING NO MORE
DISCUSSION, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON. FINAL ITEM 216
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I
BECKER. AYE BLAKE. SPEER. I
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DAWLEY. NO. DODD
AYE. TORAZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO NO. JONES NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMON AYE. MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN NO. MILO. NO. CHOBO.
NO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO SATO. NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN I UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO GROVE. AYE
TO. NO WE MOVE, SENATOR EGGMAN
MOVES TO CALL. WE HAVE EVERYBODY.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO THROUGH THE
ROLL ONE MORE TIME. EVERYBODY'S
ON THE FLOOR. WE HAVE A FULL
HOUSE.
TÍNH NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 217.
SENATOR STERN, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2481 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL. AN ACT RELATING TO
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS. SENATOR
STERN, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOWENTHAL'S BILL
TO IMPROVE OUR CYBERBULLYING
REPORTING PROCESS THAT IS
ALREADY UNDER EXISTING LAW AND
IS DUE FOR AN UPDATE THIS YEAR.
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT
VERIFIED REPORTERS HAVE A
PROCESS TO REPORT SOCIAL MEDIA
RELATED THREATS. THIS
PARTICULARLY PERTAINS TO YOUTH
RELATED THREATS, SO MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS THAT TREAT
YOUNG PEOPLE OR PRINCIPALS OR
ADMINISTRATORS AT SCHOOLS CAN GO
THROUGH A PROCESS TO ACTUALLY
GET CERTIFIED BY A SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANY, TO THEN BE A VERIFIED
REPORTER FOR PURPOSES OF
CYBERBULLYING. SO WE THINK IT'S
GOING TO NOT JUST RELY ON THE
STUDENT BEING BULLIED, BUT BY
THE FOLKS WHO HAVE A LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO BE TO CARE FOR
THEM AND TO LOOK OUT FOR THEIR
PUBLIC SAFETY AND HOPEFULLY MAKE
THE INTERNET A SAFER PLACE AS WE
KNOW IT IS NOT RIGHT NOW.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING.
SEEING NONE, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FINAL ITEM 217 OAN I
RODA-GIL WE'RE GOING TO TRY AND
SHUT THIS DOWN. ARCHULETA ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DAWLEY DODD. NO DAWLEY. NO. DODD
AYE. BARRASSO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLASER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE
LIMON. AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN NEWMAN. NGUYEN MILO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
SKINNER. HI. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ATKINS. AYE GLASER. AYE GROVE.
JONES MAGUIRE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. MILO OKUBO. SATO.
ARCHULETA. AYE TO NO. ALL RIGHT.
AGE 30, NO'S TWO. THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 218 AB
2088. SENATOR CORTEZ, HE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2088 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. AN ACT
RELATING TO CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES. SENATOR CORTEZ, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
2088 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY. THIS BILL HAS
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWED OVER
TIME. AB 2088 WILL GIVE
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES THE
FIRST RIGHT OF REFUSAL TO NEW
JOB POSTINGS THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, A MAJORITY OF
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ARE WOMEN
OF COLOR, MAKING LESS THAN
$30,000 PER YEAR AND DON'T HAVE
HEALTH INSURANCE OR RETIREMENT
BENEFITS, OFTEN TIED TO PART
TIME EMPLOYMENT. CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES, AS MOST OF US KNOW,
ARE THE STRENGTH OF OUR SCHOOLS.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH INSURANCE AND
RETIREMENT BENEFITS IN ORDER TO
SUSTAIN THEMSELVES BY HIRING
WORKERS IN HOUSE, WE WILL HELP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FILL VACANCIES QUICKLY
WITH DEDICATED STAFF WHO ARE
ALREADY FAMILIAR WITH THEIR WORK
ENVIRONMENT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 218. ALLEN. GILL
NO. ARCHULETA ASHBY. NO. ATKINS.
AYE BECKER. BLAKESBERG BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALI
NO. DODD NO. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLASER NO. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. AYE LIMÓN. NO
LEMON. NO. VOTE MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. MEN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
WAYNE NO. NILO NO. COBO. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO SATO. NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. WIENER.
WIENER AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. NO. YES JUST
HAVING A HARD TIME. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER NO. CABALLERO JONES. LEMON
MENGIBAR. RUBIO BERG. WAHAB CALL
THE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE
MORE TIME. ALLEN BECKER.
CABALLERO JONES. LIMÓN MENGIBAR.
RUBIO UMBERG. WAHAB SENATOR.
CORTEZ Þ. EGGMAN. I DON'T KNOW.
NOW WE MOVE THE SENATOR CORTEZ
MOVES TO CALL. BLAKESPEAR. NEXT
UP IS AB 2839 FILE. ON 225,
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2839 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN. AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
BLAKE, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS TODAY GENERATIVE. I
CAN MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR THE
AVERAGE PERSON TO KNOW WHICH
IMAGES BEFORE THEM ARE REAL OR
FABRICATED. THIS BECOMES A
PARTICULAR THREAT AS IT APPLIES
TO ELECTION DISINFORMATION, AS
SOPHISTICATED DEEPFAKES CAN
HEAVILY INFLUENCE VOTER BEHAVIOR
AND UNDERMINE THE PUBLIC'S FAITH
IN OUR ELECTIONS. MANY OF YOU
HAVE LIKELY HEARD OF THE
ROBOCALL THAT WAS DISSEMINATED
BACK IN JANUARY, WHICH IMITATED
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND ENCOURAGED
VOTERS NOT TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
NEW HAMPSHIRE PRIMARY ELECTION.
THAT AI GENERATED ROBOCALL WAS A
PRIME EXAMPLE OF NEFARIOUS USES
OF GENERATIVE AI, WHICH SEEKS TO
DISRUPT OUR ELECTIONS. AB 2839
ADDRESSES THIS GROWING THREAT BY
PROHIBITING THE DISTRIBUTION OF
MATERIALLY DECEPTIVE MAILERS,
ROBOCALLS AND VIDEO
ADVERTISEMENTS THAT DEPICT FALSE
INFORMATION PERTAINING TO AN
OFFICER CONDUCTING AN ELECTION.
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL, VOTING
EQUIPMENT OR CANDIDATES RUNNING
FOR OFFICE IN ALIGNMENT WITH
FIRST AMENDMENT PROTECTIONS.
THIS BILL IS NARROWLY TAILORED
TO APPLY TO DECEPTIVE
COMMUNICATION THAT IS
DISTRIBUTED WITHIN 120 DAYS
BEFORE AN ELECTION, OR AND 60
DAYS AFTER AN ELECTION.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROHIBITION
APPLIES IF THE CONTENT IS
REASONABLY LIKELY TO HARM THE
REPUTATION OR ELECTORAL
PROSPECTS OF A CANDIDATE, OR IS
LIKELY TO FALSELY UNDERMINE
CONFIDENCE IN THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION. RECENT AMENDMENTS
REQUIRE DEEPFAKE PARODY
MATERIALS TO BE LABELED AS BEING
DIGITALLY MANIPULATED FOR THOSE
PURPOSES, AND LIMIT LIABILITY
FOR DAMAGES FOR TECH AND MEDIA
COMPANIES. ADDITIONALLY, RECENT
AMENDMENTS AT AN URGENCY CLAUSE
TO TAKE EFFECT BEFORE THE
NOVEMBER 5TH, 2024 GENERAL
ELECTION. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY MEMBER
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM
HEARING SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM 225 ALLEN Ã ALVARADO TO GO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NØ
DODD I BARRASSO I EGGMAN. GLASER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE. NØ. HURTADO
I JONES. LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR. I MIN I NEWMAN I
WAYNE. MILO NØ COBO. PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO.
SEYARTO. NØ. SKINNER FIVE I
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN. I UMBERG
I WAHAB. WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE
CALL THE. Ã WIENER I WILK I
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GILL.
NO EGGMAN. I JONES. NGUYEN OKOBO
RUBIO I. ALL RIGHT. AGE 32 NOES
FIVE ON THE URGENCY. AYES 32
NOES FIVE ON THE MEASURE.
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ON 234. AB 3233. SENATOR LAIRD,
HE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL 3233 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARDIS. AN ACT
RELATING TO OIL AND GAS.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 3233 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARDIS, MONTEREY COUNTY,
IN MY DISTRICT, SAN BENITO
COUNTY, COMING INTO MY DISTRICT,
LOS ANGELES COUNTY, ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND CULVER CITY HAVE
INTRODUCED AND PASSED LOCAL
MEASURES TO REGULATE THE TYPE
AND LOCATION OF OIL PRODUCTION
IN THEIR BOUNDARIES. DESPITE
OVERWHELMING AND POPULAR SUPPORT
FOR THESE LOCAL MEASURES, THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT RULED
LAST FALL THAT THE LOCAL MEASURE
IN MONTEREY COUNTY WOULD NOT
HOLD DUE TO HOW WE HAVE WRITTEN
THE STATE LAW. THIS INVALIDATES
THE ACTIONS OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
TAKEN, DISENFRANCHIZES VOTERS
WHO HAVE VOICED THEIR CONCERNS
AND ULTIMATELY LIMITS THE
ABILITY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROTECT THEIR COMMUNITIES. THIS
IS A LEGAL PRECEDENT THAT WE
CANNOT IGNORE. THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY CODIFIES DECADES OF
STATE PRACTICE UNDER CAL, JIM
AND DOGGART BEFORE IT BY
GRANTING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AUTHORITY ON OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS, METHODS AND
LOCATIONS WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION TO BE ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR, A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS UNDER
THIS LAW WOULD STILL NEED TO
PASS MEASURES WHICH INCLUDES
EXAMINING THE ECONOMIC, HEALTH
AND SAFETY IMPACTS OF OIL AND
GAS TO BE FURTHER CLEAR, THIS IS
NOT A MANDATE OR PRESCRIPTIVE.
IF A COUNTY WANTS TO KEEP OR
INCREASE OIL PRODUCTION, THERE
IS NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT
TOUCHES THEIR DESIRE TO DO THAT.
THE THIS THAT'S WHY THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED DIVERSE SUPPORT FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES. THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION, THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS, MAYOR KAREN BASS OF
LOS ANGELES, AND COUNTLESS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. I SEE A
MICROPHONE UP FROM SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO MY
ADORED COLLEAGUE, WHO USED TO BE
THE SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES, I HAVE TO SAY THAT I
COMPLETELY, 100% DISAGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE ABOUT
IT BEING RECIPROCAL. AND IF A
COUNTY WANTED TO EXPAND OR,
EXPAND OR BE AN ASSET TO
PRODUCING RESOURCES IN THE STATE,
THAT IS AN INCORRECT STATEMENT.
IF I AM WRONG, I WOULD LOVE FOR
YOU TO SHOW ME THE LANGUAGE
WHERE IT SAYS THAT FOR INSTANCE,
KERN COUNTY COULD, OPERATE UNDER
THEIR EIR AND START PRODUCING
PERMITS LIKE WE WERE BEFORE CAL
JIM TOOK THEM OVER, WHEN I FIRST
LOOKED AT AB 30, 32, 33, I WAS
LIKE, OH MY GOD, THIS IS A GREAT
BILL. NO OFFENSE TO EVERYBODY
ELSE IN THE STATE, BUT I
REPRESENT KERN COUNTY, SEVENTH
LARGEST OIL PRODUCING COUNTY IN
THE ENTIRE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND IF WE WERE GOING TO
DO RECIPROCAL, IF THIS BILL WAS
RECIPROCAL TO WHERE WE COULD
EXPAND PERMITTING, CREATE JOBS,
NOT SHUT DOWN OUR OIL INDUSTRY,
NOT LET OUR EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
55% PEOPLE OF COLOR, SECOND
CHANCES VETERANS, WOMEN, BE LOSS
OF JOBS. WELL AND LOSE A JOB.
THANK YOU FOR THE DOLLAR TREE IN
THE AMAZON. DIDN'T PAY THE WAGES
THAT WE GET IN THE OIL INDUSTRY,
BUT AT LEAST THEY'RE NOT ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT LINE, I THOUGHT,
WOW, THAT WOULD BE GREAT BECAUSE
WE WOULD OPERATE UNDER THE ONLY
EIR THAT'S EVER BEEN DONE IN THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
PERMITTING AND MITIGATION. AND
PROVIDING, SOLAR STUFF, PAYING
FOR THINGS THAT, YOU KNOW,
MITIGATE THE AIR EMISSIONS ISSUE
THAT THAT HAS BEEN MEASURED ONLY
BY LORELEI OVIATT. OUR COUNTY
PLANNING DIRECTOR. SHE'S THE
ONLY ONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S EVER MEASURED
ANY TYPE OF OUTPUT FROM THE BASE
OF THE WELL, AND IT IS NOT 30
200FT. AND IT'S BEEN PROVEN
SCIENTIFICALLY THAT IT'S NOT
3200FT. KERN COUNTY IS THE
ENERGY CAPITAL OF THE WORLD. YOU
GUYS HEAR ME SAY THAT ALL THE
TIME? BILLS LIKE THIS THAT ARE
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE AND
SIGNED TO THE GOVERNOR HAVE MADE
IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR OIL PRODUCTION
TO GROW IN MY COMMUNITY. AND THE
FACT IS, IT'S DECLINING. OF
COURSE, THE STATE'S DEMAND FOR
OIL HAS NOT CHANGED. WE ARE
STILL CONSUMING 1.8 MILLION
BARRELS EVERY SINGLE DAY. WE'RE
GETTING IT FROM FOREIGN NATIONS
WHEN WE BRING THOSE SHIPS FROM
ECUADOR, SAUDI ARABIA AND ALL
THOSE PLACES, IT SPEWS
EMISSIONS, CARBON EMISSIONS,
GLOBAL WARMING, CARBON EMISSIONS
FROM POINT OF ORIGIN TO POINT OF
DESTINATION. AND THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD ONLY COUNTS
THOSE EMISSIONS COMING OUT OF
THAT SHIP WHEN IT'S 12 MILES OFF
OUR COASTLINE. THAT IS FAULTY
INFORMATION THAT WE ARE MAKING
POLICY ON. I CAN TELL YOU THAT,
IT'S THIS BILL. THIS BILL IS NOT
EQUAL PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW.
IT DOESN'T GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE COUNTIES, BE
ABLE TO PRODUCE OR, LIKE I SAID,
PRODUCE ENERGY. YOU KNOW, IF THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SOME OTHER COUNTY WANT TO SHUT
DOWN THE OIL PRODUCTION OR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WANT TO DO THAT,
THAT'D BE GREAT. BUT MINE DON'T.
MINE WANT TO PRODUCE A DOMESTIC
AND ENERGY SUPPLY, PROVIDE YOU
WITH CLEAN, RELIABLE ENERGY THAT
WILL MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS INSTEAD OF
IMPORTING IT FROM HOSTILE
NATIONS THAT ARE THAT ARE
HOSTILE TO CALIFORNIA. NOT ONLY
IN OUR GLOBAL ENVIRONMENT, BUT
IN OUR IN OUR STATE, HOSTILE TO
OUR VALUES, AND TO THINK ABOUT
THE PRICE REDUCTION. LOOK AT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. WE'RE BRINGING
SHIPS FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES
WHEN WE COULD DRILL IT IN KERN
COUNTY AND PUT IT IN A PIPELINE,
GO 150 MILES SOUTH, IT WOULD BE
IN A PIPELINE. THERE WOULD BE NO
CARBON EMISSIONS, AND IT WOULD
GO TO A RETAILER. YOU WOULD SAVE
MONEY ON TRANSPORTATION COSTS,
SAVE MONEY ON FUEL. YOU REDUCE
COSTS TO THE GAS PUMP, AND IT
MAKES NO SENSE THAT YOU WOULD
MAKE A ONE SIDED POLICY THAT
SAYS YOU CAN ONLY PASS LAWS THAT
WILL ELIMINATE OR SHUT DOWN THE
OIL INDUSTRY. IF THIS THING WAS
RECIPROCAL, I'D BE ADVOCATING
FOR THIS IN A HEARTBEAT BECAUSE
I REPRESENT THE COUNTY THAT
PRODUCES ENERGY THAT YOUR
CONSUMERS AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS
USE EVERY DAY IN YOUR VEHICLES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
SENATOR CIERTO THANK YOU AND AS
MANY PEOPLE DO, I'LL BE BRIEF.
NOW WE ARE TALKING. THIS BILL
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT A BILL THAT COULD
ENABLE ONE COUNTY, SAY LA
COUNTY, WHO HAS MANY REFINERIES
IN ITS JURISDICTION TO
UNILATERALLY DECIDE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO PRODUCE ANY MORE AND
SHUT DOWN EVERYTHING. AND IF
THEY WERE TO DO THAT, WE WOULD,
FROM A STATE ECONOMIC
PERSPECTIVE, THAT WOULD BE AN
ECONOMIC CATASTROPHE FOR OUR
STATE. OIL IS A STATEWIDE
RESOURCE, MUCH LIKE WATER IS A
STATEWIDE RESOURCE. WE ALL NEED
IT. WE ALL USE IT UNTIL WE ARE
COMPLETELY PHASED OUT. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO NEED IT SO IT DOES
NOT MAKE SENSE TO LEAVE THIS AS
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT DECISION. AND
I'M ALL ABOUT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DECISIONS. BUT OIL DOESN'T GROW
IN EVERY REGION. WE DON'T HAVE
OIL IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY. THE OIL
GROWS OR THE OIL IS CONTAINED IN
THE GROUND UNDERNEATH, SOME OF
THE AREAS WHERE OIL FIELDS.
THAT'S WHERE THE OIL DERRICKS
GO, AND THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE
CHOSEN TO REFINE THAT OIL. SO I
WOULD URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS. I
KNOW IT SOUNDS NICE. IT SOUNDS
LIKE WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS
TOWARDS GETTING RID OF OUR
DEPENDANCE ON OIL, BUT WE'RE
REALLY NOT GETTING RID OF THE
DEPENDANCE ON OIL. WE'RE GETTING
RID OF THE OIL BEFORE OUR
DEPENDANCE IS GONE. AND IF WE DO
THAT, IT'S GOING TO YOU WON'T
GET YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO GET
BREAD TO THE GROCERY STORE. SO
THINK HARD FOLKS. THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE BILLS THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE. BUT WE'RE GOING TO PASS
IT JUST BECAUSE IT SOUNDS GOOD.
SO I WOULD ADVISE A NO VOTE. I
HOPE WE COME TO OUR SENSES ON
THESE THINGS. THANK YOU SENATOR.
NEXT UP, SENATOR DODD. MR.
PRESIDENT MEMBERS, I DON'T THINK
I'VE GOTTEN UP ONE OTHER TIME,
MAYBE TWICE ON A DEMOCRATIC BILL
IN FRONT OF THIS BODY AND SPOKEN
AGAINST IT. I RESPECT MY GREAT
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CRUZ, BUT I
HAVE TO SAY, I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM MURRIETA ON THIS,
ON THIS ISSUE. WE ARE MESSING
WITH SUPPLY AND DEMAND BY
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
GET INVOLVED IN THIS SUPPLY
CHAIN. WITH REGARD TO OIL, WE'RE
ALREADY STARTING TO SEE IT IN
OUR STATE AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHO WANT TO HELP ON THE CLIMATE.
THEY REALLY WANT TO HELP.
THEY'RE FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THEY
SEE THE STATES DOING THINGS.
THEY WANT TO DO THINGS. AND WE
ALL WANT TO GET OUT OF THIS. WE
KNOW THAT OIL IS NOT IN OUR
FUTURE. WE KNOW THAT THERE'S AN
END POINT ON THIS OIL GAME, BUT
I THINK THE WAY WE'RE GOING, IT,
I GUESS MY POINT WAS WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE THEM SHUT DOWN
GAS STATIONS IN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES ALL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY
THINK THEY'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING. NO MORE NEW GAS STATIONS
OR ANYONE'S THAT SHUT DOWN.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO. WELL, YOU
KNOW, IF YOU DECREASE THE SUPPLY
AND THE DEMAND IS STILL THERE AS
THE MY COLLEAGUE FROM MURRIETA
JUST SAID, THE PRICES ARE GOING
TO GO UP. THIS IS BASIC
ECONOMICS AND IT'S THE SAME
THING HERE. IF WE ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CUT BACK ON THE
SUPPLY, I THINK WE'RE IN
TROUBLE. AND THE VERY PEOPLE WE
SEEK TO PROTECT IN THIS HOUSE,
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ARE THE ONES THAT GET HIT THE
HARDEST. SO I DON'T THINK I'VE
CHANGED ANY MINDS IN THIS ROOM.
BUT JUST FOR ONCE, I JUST
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT
FOR ME TO GET UP AND SAY WHAT I
THINK IS REAL. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DODD. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MEMBERS,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SEEING NONE. SENATOR
LEONARD, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT,
AND I APPRECIATE THE DEBATE. THE
DEBATE IN PART, IS ABOUT THINGS
THAT AREN'T IN THIS BILL OR ARE
NOT WHAT THIS BILL DOES. AND
LET'S BE CLEAR, WHEN THE VOTERS
IN MONTEREY COUNTY, THE YES
MEASURE WAS OUTSPENT 30 TO 1, IT
GOT 56% OF THE VOTE. THE ISSUE
WAS NOT NECESSARILY OIL
PRODUCTION. IT WAS THE
BYPRODUCTS OF OIL PRODUCTION. IT
WAS TRYING TO REGULATE THE WATER
QUALITY THAT WAS NEXT TO THE OIL
FIELD AND BASICALLY AND MAKE
SURE WE TALK ABOUT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES, THOSE ARE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES NEXT
TO THE OIL FIELD, AND THEY DON'T
HAVE CLEAN WATER, OR THEY HAVE A
THREAT OF CLEAN WATER, OR THEY
CAN'T DETERMINE WHETHER IT'S
CLEAN OR THEY CAN'T EVEN CONTROL
WHETHER OR NOT THAT HAPPENS NEAR
THEM. AND I FOUND IN IN MY LAST
JOB, IT WE DID THE RIGHT THING
AT ONE POINT, IN PART BECAUSE WE
WERE SUED. THERE WERE PERMITS
THAT WERE THOUGHT TO BE ISSUED
AT CERTAIN POINTS THAT WEREN'T
IN FACT ISSUED TO THE CODE. AND
WE FOUND THAT THERE WERE MANY,
MANY PERMITS THAT DIDN'T MEET
STATE'S WATER QUALITY OR STATE
STANDARDS, THAT WE COULD NOT
REISSUE WHEN THEY HAD TO
ACTUALLY COMPLY WITH STATE LAW.
AND LET ME BE CLEAR, AGAIN, IT
WAS LIKE, WELL, WHAT'S IN THIS
BILL? TELL ME WHAT'S IN THIS
BILL THAT THIS BILL BASICALLY
SAYS, AND LET'S CALL OUT KERN
COUNTY. IF KERN COUNTY WISHES TO
EXPAND, THEY CAN DO IT BY
ORDINANCE. THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT IS PRESCRIPTIVE,
AND IT PUTS IT ON THE LOCAL
COUNTY. IT DOES NOT PRESCRIBE
THAT SOME COUNTY CUTS. IT LETS
THE COUNTY DECIDE. AND THERE
MIGHT BE AN ISSUE WITH WHAT GOES
ON IN STATE REGULATION. BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S IN THIS BILL.
THIS ALLOWS THE COUNTIES OR THE
CITIES DECIDE IN THEIR AREA THAT
THEY CAN BEST PROTECT THEIR
RESIDENTS. AND IN FACT, IF THE
RESIDENTS THEMSELVES VOTE FOR
THAT WATER QUALITY PROTECTION OR
THE RELATED AIR PROTECTION THAT
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A RIGHT TO DO
THAT. SO THIS IS ABOUT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THIS
IS ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL WHERE
THEY CAN GO EITHER WAY. AND I
THINK IT DESERVES TO BE PASSED.
I REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR LAIRD. ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY BEFORE
YOU CALL THE ROLL, WE'RE GOING
TO GO THROUGH ONE TIME MEMBERS
AND PUT EVERYTHING WE'RE PUTTING
THE VOTE ON CALL BECAUSE WE HAVE
A MEMBER OFF THE FLOOR. OKAY,
LET ME GO THROUGH ONCE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OAN OVERALL, GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER
I. BLACKSBURG BY BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. I CORTEZ. DAWLEY DODD.
DAWLEY. NO. DODD. NO NO. DURAZO
EGGMAN. I GLASER. NO GONZALEZ I
GROVE. NO. HURTADO NO. JONES NO.
LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE. I AM
NAVARRE I MIN I NEWMAN. NO
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO JABO, NO
PADILLA I PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO.
SATO. NO. SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG. WAHAB
WIENER. WIENER I WILK. NO. I THE
LEADERSHIP HAS ASKED ME TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME,
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO PUT IT
ON CALL. SO, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. OAN I
ARCHULETA NÓ ASHBY I ATKINS,
BRADFORD CORTEZ I TERRAZZO.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO I'M BERG.
WAHAB. SENATOR LAIRD MOVES A
CALL.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 227. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2465. FLOOR
MANAGERS. HURTADO. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2465
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON AND
ACT RELATING TO EQUITY. SENATOR
HURTADO, PLEASE GIVE SENATOR
HURTADO YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2465 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON. THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE STATE BOARDS TO
PRIORITIZE ENTITIES APPLYING FOR
GRANTS TO BE PRIORITIZED IF THEY
ARE FROM A SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED ORGANIZATION. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED SOME
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE. ANY DISCUSSION ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I GILL. NO ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY NÓ DODD I DURAZO
I EGGMAN I GLASER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE NO. HURTADO I JONES NO.
LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MAN I, I NEWMAN, I
WAYNE. NILO NO. OCHOA. NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO, I ROTH I
RUBIO. I STELLATO NO. NO.
SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN,
I UMBERG, I WAHAB, I WIENER I
WILK. NO. NGUYEN NO. SENATOR
HURTADO MOVES A CALL 27-29.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 229. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2068. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2068 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ORTEGA, AN AQUILINA.
EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR LIMON. THANK
YOU, PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 2068 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ORTEGA. THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCIES
THAT CONTRACT THEIR PUBLIC WORK
AND CUSTOMER CALL CENTER
SERVICES OUT OF STATE TO PROVIDE
FULL LIST OF THESE CONTRACTS. IN
RECENT YEARS, THERE HAVE BEEN
INDICATIONS THAT THESE
CALIFORNIA AGENCY AND DEPARTMENT
CALL CENTERS ARE NOW BEING
LOCATED IN OTHER STATES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION, SEEING
NO MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN Ã.
ALVARADO. GILL. NO. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DALLI NO. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. MEN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
WAYNE MILO. NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO
OKOBO. PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
WILK. AYE SENATOR LIMON MOVES A
CALL. MEMBERS. IT'S A LITTLE
HARD TO HEAR, AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT'S SLOWING DOWN THE ROLL
HERE. SO I'D LIKE TO ASK
EVERYONE TO BE RESPECTFUL OF THE
VOTE IN PARTICULAR, AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE VOTES CAN BE
HEARD. SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 230. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 3160. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 3060
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. AN
ACT RELATING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. TAX LEVY.
MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE SENATOR
ASHBY YOUR ATTENTION. PLEASE.
SENATOR ASHBY, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT AB 3160 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JESSE
GABRIEL, AB 3160 PRESERVES THE
EXISTING $500 MILLION IN
ENHANCED STATE HOUSING TAX
CREDITS FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
YEARS. THIS WILL HELP BUILD
THOUSANDS OF NEW AFFORDABLE
HOMES. THESE CREDITS HAVE ALSO
ENABLED CALIFORNIA TO DRAW DOWN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
HOUSING CREDITS, LEVERAGING
EXISTING FEDERAL, LOCAL AND
PRIVATE FUNDINGS TO CREATE A
RATIO OF MORE THAN 5 TO 1. THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY A COALITION
OF HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS AND HAS
HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE MEMBERS. DOES ANY SENATOR
WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY SENATOR WANT TO BE
HEARD? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON BY
ALVARO GIL. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ DALY.
DODD AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO. EBCLC
PADILLA. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO AYE. STELLATO SKINNER.
A SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE SENATOR ASHBY
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 232. ASSEMBLY BILL 1895.
SENATOR SKINNER IS THE FLOOR
MANAGER. SHE IS PREPARED
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1895 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER. AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS AB 1895 WILL PROVIDE THE
STATE MORE ADVANCE NOTIFICATION
WHEN A HOSPITAL EXPECTS
CHALLENGES IN THEIR PERINATAL
UNIT. WE ARE FACING A MATERNAL
CRISIS IN OUR STATE AND NEARLY
50 MATERNITY WARDS HAVE CLOSED
ACROSS CALIFORNIA, WITH MORE
THAN HALF OF THOSE SHUTTING DOWN
IN JUST THE LAST FOUR YEARS, AB
1895. TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS
REQUIRES A HOSPITAL WITH A
PERINATAL UNIT TO REPORT SEVERAL
DATA POINTS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS, INCLUDING
THE NUMBER OF MEDICAL STAFF AND
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN THE UNIT
AND VARIOUS OTHER INFORMATION.
EXCUSE ME, SO THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES CAN ASSESS THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT TO THE
COMMUNITY SERVED IF THE HOSPITAL
CLOSES THAT UNIT. AB 1895, IS A
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR SKINNER, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SENATOR GROVE? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, I RESPECTFULLY RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. I
KNOW THE AUTHOR MEANS, WELL,
BEING A DOCTOR HERSELF, AND I
KNOW SHE MEANS WELL AND IS
ATTEMPTING TO FIND A SOLUTION
FOR THE CLOSURE OF HOSPITAL AND
MATERNITY WARDS. JUST RECENTLY,
RIDGECREST CLOSED ITS, MATERNITY
WARD, LABOR AND DELIVERY
DEPARTMENT, AND THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO GO TO A STANDBY
EMERGENCY. THE NEXT AVAILABLE
HOSPITAL IS AN HOUR AND A HALF
AWAY, GOING DOWN A CANYON ROAD.
MOUNTAIN ON ONE SIDE, RIVER ON
THE OTHER. THE BOTTOM LINE IS,
IS THAT WHEN WE SAY MEDI-CAL FOR
ALL IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, BUT WE DON'T
REIMBURSE THESE HOSPITALS OR
THESE MEDICAL PROVIDERS THE RATE
REIMBURSEMENT THAT'S EQUIVALENT
TO THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS IN
A HOSPITAL OR DELIVERING A BABY,
OR PROVIDING CARDIO CARE. IF WE
DON'T REIMBURSE THEM THE PROPER
RATE. AS A STATE ON MEDI-CAL
RECIPIENTS, THEN IT'S A PATHWAY
TO BANKRUPTCY. THERE'S NO
BUSINESS THAT CAN STAY IN
BUSINESS IF IT COSTS YOU $10,000
TO DELIVER A BABY AND YOU GET
REIMBURSED FOR 7000. THERE'S
JUST NO WAY 60 TO 70% ON THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR MEDI-CAL
PAYMENTS IS JUST UNACCEPTABLE IN
THIS STATE. WE HAD THE MCO TAX
THAT WE WERE GOING TO ALLOW
PROVIDERS AND HOSPITALS TO GET
AN INCREASED COST IN CERTAIN
MEDI-CAL RATES SO THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT USE THAT HAVE
BIRTHING, THEY HAVE CARDIO CARE,
THAT HAVE NEUROLOGICAL CARE,
THAT HAVE EMERGENCY ROOM
SERVICES, THAT WAS GOING TO
INCREASE THOSE COSTS. AND WE
PULLED THAT AWAY ON THE BUDGET,
WHICH MAKES NO SENSE BECAUSE ALL
OF US, ALL OF US WILL NEED A
DOCTOR, ONE DAY. OUR
CONSTITUENTS WILL NEED A
HOSPITAL ONE DAY AND TO HAVE
THEM REIMBURSED AT THE LOWEST
RATE POSSIBLE IN THE ENTIRE
NATION IS JUST ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS, MANY OTHERS ON THIS
FLOOR HAVE EXPERIENCED THE SAME
THING. WE HAD A HOSPITAL MEETING
WHERE THERE WAS SEVERAL OF US
THAT GOT TOGETHER, AND WE HAD
GOT TO, ALL OF US DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN, NORTH, SOUTH, EAST,
WEST COAST, COASTAL, INLAND. WE
ALL HAVE FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED
HOSPITALS. AND HAVING THIS BILL
GO INTO EFFECT WILL FURTHER
FINANCIALLY DISTRESS OUR
HOSPITALS IF WE DON'T COME UP
WITH SOME KIND OF SOLUTION.
THERE IS GOING TO BE AN
EMERGENCY NEXT YEAR OF HOSPITALS
BEING ABLE TO STAY IN BUSINESS.
AND THOSE THOSE, I BELIEVE 11
HOSPITALS THAT ARE FINANCIALLY
DISTRESSED NOW WILL GO TO A VERY
HIGH NUMBER. AND I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE,
STOP PUTTING THESE MANDATES ON
HOSPITALS UNTIL WE CAN FIGURE
OUT HOW TO REIMBURSE THEM AT THE
APPROPRIATE RATE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE,
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO GILL. NO
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DAWLEY DODD.
AYE DARAZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ VÌ. GROVE
NO. HURTADO. AYE JONES. NO.
LAIRD LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO OKOBO.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO SATO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK NO. SENATOR
SKINNER MOVES TO CALL MEMBERS.
WE HAVE JUST A FEW MORE BILLS
LEFT, BUT WE'RE GOING TO ASK ALL
MEMBERS TO REMAIN IN THE
CHAMBERS NOW. WE'RE ASKING ALL
MEMBERS TO REMAIN IN THE CHAMBER.
OKAY. SEVEN. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 237. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2739. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2739 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. MANCINI AND AQUILINA.
FIREARMS PLEASE. MEMBERS, GIVE
SENATOR BECKER YOUR ATTENTION,
PLEASE. SENATOR BECKER, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2739 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI. THIS IS
A BILL THAT SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL GUNS CARRIED ILLEGALLY, THAT
ARE ILLEGALLY CARRIED, ARE
TREATED THE SAME UNDER THE LAW,
UNDER CURRENT LAW, CARRYING A
CONCEALED WEAPON WITHOUT A
PERMIT IS A CRIME AND IS DEEMED
A PUBLIC NUISANCE. THE FIREARM
THAT IS ILLEGALLY CARRIED MUST
BE SURRENDERED AND DESTROYED.
HOWEVER, THE SAME RULES DO NOT
EXIST FOR OPENLY CARRYING AN
UNLOADED HANDGUN IN PUBLIC OR
CARRYING A LOADED FIREARM IN
PUBLIC. THIS BILL DECLARES BOTH
OF THOSE CRIMES A NUISANCE AND
SUBJECTS THE FIREARMS TO
EXISTING SURRENDER DESTROY
PROVISIONS FOCUSED SOLELY ON THE
FIREARMS FIREARM. IT DOES NOT
CREATE A NEW CRIME OR INCREASE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES, AND AGAIN,
IT DOES NOT INFRINGE. CERTAINLY
ON THE RIGHTS OF LAW ABIDING GUN
OWNERS. ANY FIREARM SUBJECT TO
THIS LAW WERE CARRIED IN
VIOLATION OF CALIFORNIA LAW.
IT'S A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
TARGETS IRRESPONSIBLE GUN
POSSESSION, AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. OKAY. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BECKER, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OAN. I RODA-GIL AYE. ARCHULETA
I ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
NO. HURTADO JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LIMON AYE. MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR
MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. OKOBO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK
SEN. BECKER MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS. I HAVE THE JOY OF
SHARING SOME NEWS WITH YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP ANOTHER
BILL OR TWO BEFORE A DINNER
BREAK. IT'S GOING TO BE A ONE
HOUR DINNER BREAK DUE TO
COMMITTEE BUSINESS. AND THEN WE
WILL COME BACK TO THE FLOOR TO
FINISH OUR WORK. SO WE HAVE MORE
WORK TO DO. AND I KNOW WE'LL BE
DILIGENT IN DOING IT. SO WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A COUPLE MORE
BILLS. WE LAST ASK ALL MEMBERS
TO REMAIN ON THE FLOOR. NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM 233. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1992. FLOOR
MANAGER IS SENATOR PADILLA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1992 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARNER AND AQUILINA. CARBON
SEQUESTRATION. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 1992 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERNER. THIS
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION TO ADD BLUE
CARBON DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS TO
A SUITE OF FACTORS TO CONSIDER
FOR POTENTIAL MITIGATION WHEN
APPROVING COASTAL DEVELOPMENT
PERMITS, WHEN IT IS FEASIBLE,
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT BLUE CARBON
ECOSYSTEMS SUCH AS SEAGRASSES
AND SALT MARSHES ARE OFTEN
EFFICIENT AT CAPTURING AND
STORING ATMOSPHERIC CARBON THAN
MOST TERRESTRIAL FORESTS. IN
FACT, SOME ECOSYSTEMS CAN
SEQUESTER FIVE TIMES MORE CARBON
THAN TROPICAL RAINFORESTS AND
STORE 50 TIMES MORE IN THE
SURROUNDING SOILS. SADLY
CALIFORNIA HAS LOST OVER 90% OF
ITS HISTORICAL WETLANDS AND
ASSOCIATED BENEFITS THAT THEY DO
PROVIDE. PROTECTING COASTAL
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO AUTHORIZE THE CNRA TO
AUTHORIZE TEAL CARBON PROJECTS.
IN NON COASTAL LANDSCAPES WITH A
THREE YEAR DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION TO ALLOW THE
AGENCY TO CONSULT WITH OTHER
AGENCIES, THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR PADILLA. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A BILL.
NÓ ARCHULETTA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY. NØ. DODD. AYE BARRASSO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
OTERO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
NAVARRE. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO JOBO.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO NO.
SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS A STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK NO. SENATOR
PADILLA MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS
THE NEXT THREE BILLS WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE UP THIS EVENING ARE FILE
ITEM 168, FILE ITEM 214 AND 231.
SO NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 168.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 460.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
ASSEMBLY BILL 460 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER KHN AND AQUILINA.
WATER. SENATOR LAIRD, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT. THIS BILL SIMPLY
INCREASES PENALTIES FOR CERTAIN
VIOLATIONS OF CEASE AND DESIST
ORDERS AND CURTAILMENT ORDERS
ISSUED BY THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. THE
EXISTING PENALTIES ARE
INSUFFICIENT TO DETER ILLEGAL
DIVERSIONS. THERE'S SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE MEMBERS. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THIS MATTER? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OAN. AYE GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR AYE.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DALY DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMON
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
NILO AYE. TROUBLE I Dð. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROD AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE NGUYEN. AYE SIERRA. AYE
SENATE. OKAY. JONES. NO. SEN.
LAIRD MOVES A CALL. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 214.
THIS IS. EXCUSE ME. WE'RE GOING
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2240.
FLOOR MANAGER SENATOR HURTADO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2240 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA. AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING. SENATOR HURTADO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB 2240 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, DOCTOR ARAMBULA
CALIFORNIA FARM WORKERS SHOULD
BE TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT, REFLECTIVE OF THE
ESSENTIAL CONTRIBUTION THEY MAKE
TO CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL CODIFIES PROTECTIONS
FOR FARM WORKERS AND ESTABLISHES
STAKEHOLDER WORKING GROUPS TO
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT REFORMS TO
THE MIGRATORY FARMWORKER HOUSING
PROGRAM TO BETTER REFLECT THE
MODERN FARM WORKER POPULATION.
AB 2240 IS A COLLABORATIVE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN STAKEHOLDERS,
AND THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
HURTADO. MEMBERS. DOES ANY
MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS
BILL? SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. I'VE ALREADY GO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY. NØ.
DODD. AYE. BROUGH AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO.
TURBO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH 231 IS NEXT. THAT'S ON
THE LIST. RUBIO AYE. SATO NO.
SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK WILK. NO
SENATOR. HURTADO. AYE SENATOR
HURTADO MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS.
THE NEXT BILL UP IS FILE ITEM
231. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2467
FLOOR, MANAGED BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
YEAH. THIS IS A FILE ITEM.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS. WE'RE HAVING
TROUBLE HEARING UP HERE. I THINK
ONE OF THE REASONS THE ROLL IS
SLOW IS BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE NOT
AT THEIR DESKS, AND WE CAN'T
HEAR VERY, VERY EASILY. SO WE'D
LIKE TO ASK MEMBERS TO CREATE A
LITTLE BETTER DECORUM IN THE
HOUSE. THE NEXT ITEM IS 231 231
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2467 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BARKAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. SENATOR
EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. PRESENTING AB 2467 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN, WE DID THIS. WE DID
A HEARING TOGETHER, THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE FOCUSING ON
MENOPAUSE. WE'VE DONE A LOT FOR
MENSTRUAL EQUITY, AND NOW IT'S
REALLY TIME TO START THINKING
ABOUT MENOPAUSE AND THE COVERAGE
THAT'S SUPPLIED FOR THAT. SO
THIS REQUIRES HEALTH CARE PLANS
TO COVER SYMPTOMS FOR
PERIMENOPAUSE AND MENOPAUSE TO
RECEIVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO
FAR. AND I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR EGGMAN. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MATTER? ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
BILL? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FIVE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DAWLEY DODD. AYE.
DURAZO EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. MILO.
EBCLC PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE SATO.
SKINNER. I CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK AYE. SENATOR
EGGMAN MOVES A CALL. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, CAN I GET YOUR
ATTENTION, PLEASE? WE HAVE SOME
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE, AND THEN I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ABOUT THE REST OF OUR EVENING.
FIRST UP FOR COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS, SENATOR WAHAB.
THANK YOU. SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
WILL MEET IMMEDIATELY IN ROOM
113 TO HEAR TWO BILLS. AB 2348
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AND SB
918 BY SENATOR UMBERG. MEMBERS,
PLEASE MAKE YOUR WAY TO THE
HEARING ROOM. THANK YOU. NEXT
UP, SENATOR DODD, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR ALLEN. SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS, ROOM
112. UPON ADJOURNMENT OR TO
RECESS HERE IN ROOM 112. I THINK
THEY DID IT THIS MORNING. THEY
MIGHT HAVE DONE. ALL RIGHT.
THERE IS EC IS NOT MEETING THIS
AFTERNOON. SO SORRY ABOUT THAT.
I HAD THE WRONG INFORMATION.
ANYONE ELSE? ARE THERE ANY
OTHER. LET'S ASK THE QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS? OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, LISTEN UP. BECAUSE I
KNOW WE WANT TO COMPLETE OUR
WORK AND WE'RE ALL COMMITTED TO
THAT. ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. YOU
KNOW.
COMMERCENTRE. ALLEN. SENATOR
ALLEN, CAN YOU COME TO THE
FRONT, PLEASE?
MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE PRO TEM. PRO
TEM MCGUIRE MEMBERS, I KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE BREAKING FOR
ONE HOUR. WOULD LIKE TO JUST DO
A QUICK CHECK IN BECAUSE WE ARE
MAKING GREAT MOVEMENT HERE
TODAY. BUT THEY BROUGHT THE
MOLASSES TRUCK IN A LITTLE SLOW.
IT'S ALL GOOD, BUT WE'RE GOING
TO GET THERE. SO HERE'S THE
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE FOR
TONIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO NEED ALL
MEMBERS BACK ON THE FLOOR IN AN
HOUR. BECAUSE WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO DO IS WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL VOTES. AND WE CAN'T
TAKE UP THOSE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL VOTES UNLESS EVERY MEMBER
IS ON THE FLOOR. SO WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IF
YOU NEED TO MAKE A FRIENDLY
VISIT OVER INTO THE ASSEMBLY TO
BE ABLE TO CHECK IN ON YOUR
BILLS, THAT YOU DO THAT DURING
THE DINNER HOUR IN ADDITION, WE
ARE GOING TO BE LIFTING THE
CALLS. SO WE ARE GOING TO NEED
ALL MEMBERS BACK ON THE FLOOR TO
BE ABLE TO LIFT THE CALLS. SO
RESPECTFULLY KNOW HOW BUSY
EVERYTHING IS. IF YOU DON'T
MIND, GO VISIT THE ASSEMBLY HERE
OVER THE NEXT HOUR DURING THE
DINNER BREAK. PLEASE COME BACK
NO LATER THAN 630, NO LATER THAN
630. IN THE CHAMBERS SO THAT WE
CAN TAKE UP THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL VOTES. THEN WE WILL LIFT
THE CALLS AND WE'LL TRY TO GET
GET YOU OUT OF HERE AT A
REASONABLE TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT, AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE INCREDIBLE WORK,
FOR ALL THE SENATORS AND STAFF.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MCGUIRE. SO
THE COURSE OF ACTIONS IS FOR
COMMITTEES TO MEET FOR DINNER,
TO BE TAKEN AND GO BACK ON THE
FLOOR AT 630, MEMBERS SHARP, 630
AND WILL BEGIN WITH BILLS ON
CALL, AS WELL AS THE UNANIMOUS
CONSENT BILLS AS WELL. THANK YOU
ALL. AND WE'RE IN RECESS.
LIFTING CALLS ON ALL OUR ITEMS.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH ITEM
68. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALL RIGHT. GO Ó JONES. I'D
RATHER GO. AYE JONES. MCGUIRE.
AYE JONES. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
WIENER AYE. AYES 40 ZERO ZERO.
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS
ITEM 73. SB 1066. ALVARADO Ã
ASHBY, A GLAZER A. JONES I,
MCGUIRE I, RUBIO I. 40 TO 0
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 76 SB 1077. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL, I,
JONES I, MCGUIRE I RUBIO I WAHAB.
I 39 NOES ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 79 SB 1100. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL I JONES I MCGUIRE I
RUBIO I. AYES 40. NOES ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS FILE.
ITEM FILE. ITEM 85 SB 1152.
ALVARADO. ABSENT MEMBERS. I'M
SORRY, I JONES I MCGUIRE. I AYES
40. NÓ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 94 SB 12
1717. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO, GIL, I, JONES
I, MCGUIRE. AYE. MIN WIENER I.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. MEN I AYES 40. NØ ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 125 SB 1528. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL.
AYE GONZALEZ. I JONES I MCGUIRE.
AYE. MIN. I MILO. AYE WIENER.
AYE I ABSTAIN I. MILO. NOBO.
GUDES. NO NO. MILO. NO. AYES 39.
NOES ONE. THE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 156 AB 1472. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO,
GIL. CORTEZ AYE. JONES. NO
MCGUIRE. AYE COBO. WIENER. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
AYES 33. NOES SIX. MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP. NEXT UP IS FILE
I 157 AB 1950. PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO, GIL NÓ
ASHBY. AYE. JONES NO. MCGUIRE
AYE. OKOBO. EYES 33 NOES SIX.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM. FILE ITEM 159 AB
2258. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL. DAWLEY
TERRAZZO. AYE GROVE. JONES NÓ.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. NGUYEN.
MILO PATROL BOAT. SEYARTO WILK.
AYES 31. NOES ONE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 160
AB 2666. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO, GIL NØ JONES.
NØ LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. BOCOBO PADILLA.
AYE CUEVAS. UMBERG. AYE CUEVAS I.
EYES 32. NO. SEVEN. MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FOLLOWING
ITEM 162 AB 2678. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL.
I BECKER, I GROVE. JONES NO.
MCGUIRE I GROVE. NO MILO.
PADILLA I SMALL. CUEVAS I. AYES
35. NOES THREE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 166
AS AB 3074. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO NO.
BECKER I CABALLERO I DODD I
GROVE. HURTADO I JONES. I
MCGUIRE. HI, I NGUYEN. MILO.
PORTANTINO I CIERTO. SKINNER I
CUEVAS I WAHAB. EYES 33. CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
GROVE NGUYEN I MILO. CIERTO
WAHAB. I WROTE A NO TO I. ICE 36
NOES ONE. THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW. FILE ITEM 172 AB 2313.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GO NØ HURTADO I JONES.
NO. LEMON I MCGUIRE. I MENGIBAR
I MIN I OKUBO. NO. ALVARADO,
GIL. NO. TO I. AGE 33. NO.
SEVEN. THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 174 AB TWO 2750.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO, GIL, I GONZALEZ.
HURTADO I JONES I LIMON. MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I PADILLA. I WAHAB.
WIENER NO. WAHAB. NO. FERNANDO
STERN I TO. NO I AGE 35. NOES
THREE. THE MEASURE PASSES NOW ON
THE FILE. ITEM 175 AB 364.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL. NO. HURTADO NO.
ROTH. I 828. NOES 11. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW ON THE FILE.
ITEM 184 AB 3123. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
VALLEY. BECKER CABALLERO. I
DALITA. NØ MCGUIRE. I STERN.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ONE MORE TIME. OAN BECKER.
STERN I DON'T KNOW, AGE 26 NOES
11. THE MEASURE PASSES NOW ON
THE FILE. ITEM 189 AB 1886.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
NO WE JUST. YEAH. 1886 ALLEN.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA
BECKER. BRADFORD CABALLERO. I
GLAZER. GROVE. NEWMAN. I DON'T
KNOW. LIMON MCGUIRE. I
PORTANTINO ROTH. I RUBIO. I
STERN. I. AYES 25. ARCHULETA I.
AYES 26. NOES SEVEN. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT IS FILE ITEM 161 AB
2672. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CABALLERO I DELI.
DURAZO I GROVE. LIMON I MCGUIRE.
I NGUYEN. AYES 37. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW THE FILE
ITEM 205 AB 2441. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA.
ATKINS. I CABALLERO. DODD EGGMAN
I LIMON I MCGUIRE. I NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO STERN. I
UMBERG. NO ARCHULETA. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. CABALLERO DODD. NEWMAN
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. UMBERG
NO. CABALLERO. NO. I WILL MOVE
THE CALL NOW. WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 208 AB 2159. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABALLERO I DODD. MCGUIRE I,
OCHOA. SKINNER I, I SMOKE
WEATHERS. I WAHAB, WILL. NOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DODD. I OCHOA. BOGH I WAHAB.
AYES 39. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'VE GOT TO PAUSE
TEMPORARILY, FOLKS.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE READY
TO BEGIN BACK. WE'RE BACK AT
FILE ITEM 167 AB 3263. PLEASE
MEMBERS. ALAN. BECKER CABALLERO
I DODD I GROVE I MCGUIRE. I
OKUBO. PADILLA I SKINNER. I
STERN, I UMBERG, I WIENER. I Tð.
NÓ UMBERG. I. AYES 31. NOES SIX.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW.
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 22. SB 312, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER I, BLAKE
SPEER I CABALLERO I DODD. GLAZER
I, HURTADO I, LAIRD. MCGUIRE I,
SKINNER I VÌ. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD I LAIRD.
LET'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ONE MORE TIME. NO. OKAY ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. AYES 39, NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. DOES
SEND ME ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THE
ASSEMBLY MINUTES ARE CONCURRED
IN. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 26 SB 951. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER I
CABALLERO I DALLY I DODD I GROVE
I HURTADO I LIMON. MCGUIRE I
PORTANTINO. SKINNER I. AYES 38.
NOES ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 141 AB
2127. YOU CAN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER I, GLAZER.
HURTADO I, MCGUIRE I SKINNER, I.
I GLAZER I. I AYES 31. NOES
NINE. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 210
AB 846. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BLAKE SPEER.
CABALLERO. DALLY NØ. GLAZER
GROVE. NÓ MCGUIRE. I MIN I
PORTANTINO. MIN. I DON'T KNOW.
PORTANTINO SKINNER. I. AYES 26.
NOES TEN. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW ON TO FILE ITEM 215 AB 2182.
PLEASE CALL OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
DODD GLAZER MCGUIRE. I RUBIO.
SKINNER I. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD GLAZER.
RUBIO I. AYES 30. NOES EIGHT.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 216 AB 2136.
PLEASE CALL OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA. MCGUIRE I RUBIO I. H
29.
OH
AYES 30. NOES TEN. THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW. MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 218 AB 2088.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN BECKER. CABALLERO I JONES.
NO. LEMON MENGIBAR I RUBIO.
UMBERG I WAHAB I. AYES 22. NOES
14. THE MEASURE PASSES NOW.
MEMBERS. WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 234 AB 3233. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS I
BRADFORD DURAZO NÓ Ó.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO UMBERG.
WAHAB WAHAB I. GET THEIR
ATTENTION. WE NEED ORDER! WE
NEED ORDER! CALL THE ROLL ONE
MORE TIME, PLEASE. BRADFORD.
RAZO PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO
UMBERG. SEN. LAIRD MOVES THE
CALL. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TWO. TWO SEVEN
AB 2465. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD MCGUIRE. I
BRADFORD I BRADFORD I. NEXT UP
IS FILE. OH, I'M SORRY AYES 31
NOES NINE. THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 229 AB 2068. PLEASE
CALL OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD MENGIBAR. I OKOBOJI.
BRADFORD I BRADFORD I. PADILLA I.
AGE 32 NO. SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 230 AB 3160. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. I'LL
RATHER GO WITH BRADFORD. CORTEZ
I BRADFORD, I BRADFORD. I DAWLEY.
NO. GROVE NO. LEMON I MILO. NO
OCHOA. BOGH. NO. PADILLA I SATO.
AYES 33. NOES FIVE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 232 AB 1895. PLEASE CALL
OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD I
DAWLEY. LAIRD I. PADILLA I,
RUBIO I. AGE 31 NOES SEVEN. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 237 AB 2739. PLEASE
CALL OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD I DAWLEY TERRAZZO I
OTERO I JONES. NO. MENGIBAR I
NGUYEN. MILO OKOBO. WAHAB WILK.
DAWLEY. NO. WILK. NO. AYES 31.
NO. IS FIVE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
233 AB 1992. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MEMBER BRADFORD.
I AGE 31 NOES NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW ON TO FILE ITEM 168
AB 460. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD I DAWLEY.
GROVE I WAHAB I. DAWLEY. NO AYES
38. NOES TWO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW ON THE FINAL ITEM. ITEM 214
AB 2240. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL NO.
BRADFORD I LIMÓN. I OKOBO UMBERG.
UMBERG I. AYES 31. NOES EIGHT.
THE MEASURE PASSES OUR FINAL
ITEM. IS AB FILE ITEM 231 AB
2467. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD. I DAWLEY.
TERRAZZO JONES, MILO. BOCOBO
CIERTO 47 FILE TERRAZZO. I. AYES
34. NOES ONE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. THAT CONCLUDES OUR ON
CALL ITEMS. MEMBERS GIVE US A
MINUTE.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE NOW MOVE
INTO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
NOW IS THE TIME MEMBERS. IF YOU
HAVE AN ITEM UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR AMBER THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN
ROOM 112. MOST LIKELY. THIS IS
NOT FOR COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
RIGHT NOW. NO. OKAY. MY BAD.
THAT'S NØ MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS RIGHT NOW. ARE THERE
MEMBERS WITH MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS? SENATOR GONZALEZ
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. PLEASE PLACE ITEM 219
AB2514 ON THE INACTIVE AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. DOES WILL
NOTE SENATOR EGGMAN. YES. FILE
ITEM 219 AB 25. IS THAT WHAT YOU
JUST SAID? WELL, I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT. SENATOR STERN.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE FILE ITEM NOT
219 133 AB 1537 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOOD TO THE ENACTED FILE,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. THE DESK WILL
NOTE SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR,
ASSEMBLYMAN MIKE GIBSON. I
REQUEST THAT FILE NUMBER 148 AB
3067 BE MOVED TO THE INACTIVE
FILE DESK WILL NOTE.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS,
SENATOR GLAZIER. MR. PRESIDENT,
I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON FILE ITEM
125. IS THAT CORRECT? ONE, TWO
FIVE, PLEASE. SIR SENATOR
GLAZER'S ASKING FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON FILE ITEM
125. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
GRANTING RECONSIDERATION? SEEING
NONE. AYES 40 NOES ZERO.
RECONSIDERATION. RECONSIDERATION
HAS BEEN GRANTED.
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE AGENDA,
FOLKS. WE'RE CALLING THE ROLL
AGAIN ON FILE ITEM 125.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 125. ALLEN A GILL.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY. ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DALLEY I DODD. I
TERRAZZO I EGGMAN. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN I NILO OKOBO I PADILLA.
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO.
SEYARTO I SKINNER I CUEVAS I
STERN, I UMBERG I WAHAB. I
WIENER I WILK I PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
I'LL ROLL TO GO. I MILO PADILLA
RUBIO. HI. AYES 38. NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT, FOLKS, WE'RE GETTING
CLOSE TO THE END. WE'RE GOING TO
ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING. LISTEN
UP. WE'RE GOING TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. ALL THESE ITEMS
ARE AVAILABLE. I MEAN, ELIGIBLE,
I SHOULD SAY, FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SO LET'S KEEP THAT IN MIND.
WE'LL FIRST START OFF WITH FILE
ITEM 147. SENATOR BECKER.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2484 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRYAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
COURTS.
SENATOR BECKER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL WILL EXEMPT PARENTS
FROM OBTAINING THE CONSENT OF
ALL PARTIES TO HAVE THE
APPEARANCE OF AN EXPERT WITNESS
IN CHILD DEPENDENCY PROCEEDINGS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM, HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
147 SEEING NONE AYES 40 NØ ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS
FILE LINE ON ONE, THREE SIX.
SENATOR NILO. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1901 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHEN. AN ACT
RELATING TO VEHICLES. SENATOR
NILO, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
GOOD EVENING, FELLOW MEMBERS. I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 1901 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN.
THIS BILL CREATES A PROCESS FOR
SALVAGE POOLS AT THE DMV TO
ALLOW ABANDONED VEHICLES TO HAVE
TITLES PROCESSED IN A MORE
STREAMLINED WAY. PRIOR TO 2016,
SALVAGE POOLS USED THE DILIGENT
EFFORTS. THAT'S A NAME OF A
PROCESS AND BOND PROCESS TO
OBTAIN A VEHICLE'S TITLE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE DIGITAL
EFFORTS PROCESS WAS QUITE
BURDENSOME, TAKING 3 TO 6 MONTHS
TO COMPLETE AND FOR THESE
REASONS, DMV AND SALVAGE POOLS
DISCUSSED A MORE STREAMLINED
SERVICE. DMV SUBSEQUENTLY
REALIZED THEY DIDN'T REALLY HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO DO THAT. AND SO
THIS BILL, Ã, CREATES THAT
PROCESS LEGALLY TO MAKE
ABANDONED VEHICLE TITLES MUCH
LESS BURDENSOME. THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED, HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY
NO VOTES, HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEING NONE. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL TO THIS ITEM? SEEING
NONE. AYES 40. NØ ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
138. SENATOR NEWMAN, ARE YOU
PREPARED? NO, HE'S NOT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2807 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BILL PADUA. AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SENATOR NEWMAN, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. I THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VÀ VALLAPUDUA TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2807,
WHICH WILL CLARIFY CALIFORNIA
LAW AROUND EVENTS IN WHICH
PARTICIPANTS BLOCK OR IMPEDE
TRAFFIC ON A HIGHWAY, STREET OR
IN AN OFF STREET PARKING
FACILITY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PERFORMING MOTOR VEHICLE STUNTS,
MOTOR VEHICLE SPEED CONTESTS,
EXHIBITIONS OF SPEED OR RECKLESS
DRIVING, THEREBY CREATING GREAT
RISKS FOR NOT ONLY THE SAFETY OF
SPECTATORS, BUT THE BROADER
PUBLIC AS WELL. THIS BILL ALIGNS
DIFFERENT TERMINOLOGY IN USE
ACROSS THE STATE, RECOGNIZING
THE EQUIVALENCY OF THE MORE
POPULAR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TERM
OF SIDESHOW WITH THE COMMONLY
USED SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TERM OF
STREET TAKEOVER, AND CLARIFYING
THAT BOTH TERMS REFER TO THE
SAME EVENT. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. MEMBERS. THIS TWO IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? AYES 40. NØ ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FOR TWO.
SENATOR SECRETO, HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2186 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALLACE. AN ACT RELATING
TO VEHICLES. SENATOR SECRETO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 2186 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALLACE IN 2022, WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE EXPANDED THE CRIME
OF MOTOR VEHICLE EXHIBITION OF
SPEED TO INCLUDE OFF STREET
PARKING FACILITIES, IT DID NOT
INCLUDE PROVISIONS RELATED TO
IMPOUNDING THE VEHICLE. AB 2186
CLOSES THAT GAP. THIS BILL HAS
HAD NO NØ VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS. ITEM? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING
AND SEEING. NONE. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 40.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW UP IS ITEM 151. SENATOR
GROVE IS READY. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ THE ASSEMBLY BILL 1954
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS. AN
ACT RELATING TO SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS. SENATOR GROVE. THANK
YOU. COLLEAGUES THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS TO
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL PARTIES, SUCH
AS THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S AND
ALTERNATIVE COUNTIES, FOR
PROCESS OF SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS. ADDITIONALLY, THIS
LAW WILL REQUIRE NOTIFICATIONS
TO BE SENT NOT ELECTRONICALLY
BUT BY US CERTIFIED MAIL. THIS
ENSURES THAT THE RECEIVING
COUNTY HAS THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION TO KEEP THE
INDIVIDUALS SAFE ON THE BEST
RECOVERY, AND THIS PUBLIC SAFETY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. THIS TWO IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
151? AYES 40. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 179. SENATOR CIERTO. HE IS
PREPARED AGAIN. SECRETARY MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 718 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO VETERANS. SENATOR
SECRETO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. ONCE AGAIN MEMBERS,
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT AB 718
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
THIS BILL WOULD DIRECT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS TO CONDUCT A
STUDY OF MENTAL HEALTH AMONG
WOMEN VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY HAVE BEEN SEVERELY
SHORTCHANGED IN THIS AREA. THIS
WOULD FIX THAT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING.
SEEING. NONE. ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
TO FILE ITEM 179? SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 182. CIERTO AGAIN.
THREE IN A ROW. HERE WE GO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1859 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALANIS. AN ACT RELATING TO
CORONERS. SENATOR. SECRETO.
THANK YOU AGAIN, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 1859 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALANIS ALANIS. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE CORONERS TO TEST
FOR THE PRESENCE OF TRANQ, A
DEADLY ANIMAL TRANQUILIZER, AND
CERTAIN AUTOPSY CASES, AND
REPORT POSITIVE RESULTS TO THE
RELEVANT AUTHORITY. THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NØ ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW. NEXT UP IS
ITEM 186. SENATOR CHIRLA B¢O
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2308 BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS DAVIES. AN ACT
RELATING TO PROTECTIVE ORDERS.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2308, WHICH EXTENDS THE DURATION
OF A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER FROM 10 TO 15
YEARS. THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY
THE CONFERENCE OF CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS AND HAS SUPPORT
FROM THE MAJOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
GROUPS, AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE. THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING? UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING. NO OBJECTION. AYES 40.
NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 193. WE
HAVE SENATOR CIERTO AGAIN.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1871 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALANIS. AN ACT RELATING
TO THE PUPIL INSTRUCTION.
SENATOR CIERTO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 1871 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS. MEMBERS
AB 1871 WOULD ADD PERSONAL
FINANCIAL LITERACY TO THE
ADOPTED COURSE OF STUDY WITHIN
THE SOCIAL SCIENCES FOR GRADES
SEVEN THROUGH 12. THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING THAT? SENATOR WILK, YOU
HAVE ISSUE. ALL RIGHT. ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL TO THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO ITEM 194. THAT SENATOR
WILK IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1862 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHEN. AN ACT
RELATING TO LIMITED LIABILITY
PARTNERSHIPS. SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AB
2107 ALLOWS PATHOLOGISTS TO
REVIEW DIGITAL DATA, RESULTS AND
IMAGES FROM A REMOTE LOCATION IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY
OF DIAGNOSIS. WITHOUT THIS
AUTHORIZATION, PATHOLOGISTS WILL
BE LIMITED TO VIEWING THESE
MATERIALS IN A PHYSICAL LICENSED
LABORATORY. EVEN THOUGH NO
LABORATORY EQUIPMENT IS NEEDED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING? UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING. NO OBJECTION.
AYES 40. NØ ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW LET US FILE ITEM
139. SENATOR DODD, HE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 598 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR DODD. MR. PRESIDENT,
MEMBERS, I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
598 A FOR CLEANUP BILL. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN BUFFY
WICKS. BOFFA IS THE BAY AREA
HOUSING FINANCE AUTHORITY, WHICH
IS AN ENTITY THAT IS GOVERNED BY
THE BAY AREA'S METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL. THE BILL REFLECTS
CONCERNS BY THE BAY AREA
BUILDERS AND BUSINESS GROUPS
THAT BAFA WOULD USE MONEY IT
RAISED TO LEVERAGE CHANGES IN
LAND USE POLICY IN LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT RECEIVE THE
MONEY THAT IS NOT BAFFERT'S
INTENTION, AND THIS BILL MAKES
IT EXPLICIT BAFA CANNOT LEVERAGE
ITS MONEY TO INFLUENCE LOCAL
LAND USE POLICY AND WHILE WE
KNOW MTC AND ABAG RECENTLY
DECIDED TO REMOVE A PROPOSED $20
MILLION BOND FOR BOFFA FROM THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT, THE INVOLVED
PARTIES WANTED TO GO AHEAD AND
MAKE THIS CHANGE SO THAT
EVERYONE WAS ON BETTER FOOTING.
THE NEXT TIME. THE BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE BAY AREA
BUILDERS AND BUSINESS GROUPS, AS
WELL AS THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE GROUPS THAT
SPONSORED BOFFA AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING. NONE
MEMBERS. ARE YOU ANY OBJECTION
TO APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? THIS NEEDS. ALL RIGHT,
WE'VE BEEN CORRECTED. WE NEED A
ROLL CALL. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON FILE ITEM 139.
OAN MØT. COMMERCENTRE. Þ L AND
I OF RODRIGO VÌ ARCHULETA. VÌ
ASHBY I. ATKINS I. BECKER I.
BLAKE. SPEER I. BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I. CORTEZ I. DALLEY I.
DODD I. TARRAZO I EGGMAN, I.
GLASER I. GONZALEZ I. GROVE I.
OTERO I. JONES I. LAIRD I.
LEHMAN I. MCGUIRE I. MENGIBAR I.
MIN I. NEWMAN I. NGUYEN I. NILO
I. EBCLC I. PADILLA I.
PORTANTINO I. ROTH I. RUBIO. I.
SEYARTO I. SKINNER I. SMALL.
CUEVAS I. STERN I. UMBERG I.
WAHAB I. WIENER. I. WILK FIVE
AYES. 40. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW UP IS FINAL ITEM
202. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. SHE'S
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
SALAS. ASSEMBLY BILL 2580 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WICKS AN ACT
RELATING TO HISTORICAL
RESOURCES. SENATOR. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 2580 A BILL BY BUFFY
WICKS, WHICH REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO LIST ALL NEW
HISTORIC DESIGNATIONS IN THEIR
ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORT TO HCD.
BY DOING SO, AB 2580 WILL
INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE
INTERSECTION OF HOUSING POLICY
AND HISTORIC PRESERVATION. IT
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND RECEIVED NO NO VOTES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SOMEBODY
WANTS A ROLL CALL. OKAY, I WAS
GOING TO ASK IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION? SO THERE IS
OBJECTIONS. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. OAN AYE.
ALVARADO. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. AYE. DODD
TERRAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE. TROBOK
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
NO. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER A SMALL. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
GROVE. AYE. IT'S PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT. MEMBERS. MR. SECRETARY,
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME? THEN
WE'RE GOING TO SHUT IT DOWN. MR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS TO NØ DODD. AYE.
AYE AYES 38, NOES TWO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO PAUSE HERE FOR A
MOMENT. WE'RE GOING TO RECONCILE
THE PAPERWORK. GIVE US A FEW
MINUTES. THE DESK IS GOING TO
GET THE PAPERWORK IN ORDER.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ALL MEMBERS
PLEASE STAY ON THE FLOOR. ALL
MEMBERS, PLEASE STAY ON THE
FLOOR.
PERFECT. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE
NEED YOUR ATTENTION. WE'RE GOING
TO CALL ON TWO ITEMS. MEMBERS I
NEED YOUR ATTENTION. WE'RE
LIFTING THE CALL ON TWO ITEMS.
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE ROLL.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE ROLL
TWICE, AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE THE ROLL. STARTING WITH
ITEM 205. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO UMBERG.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DODD NEWMAN. PORTANTINO ROTH.
RUBIO UMBERG. AYES 20. NOES 14.
MEASURE FAILS. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
A MOTION TO RECONSIDER. ANY
OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE.
RECONSIDERATION GRANTED. AYES
40. NÓ ZERO.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO ITEM 234. WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO THE ROAD TWICE. HERE WE
GO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD DURAZO
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO UMBERG.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD DURAZO. PORTANTINO ROTH.
RUBIO UMBERG. AYES 20. NOES 14.
MEASURE FAILS. MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION. ANY OBJECTIONS?
SEEING. NONE. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
MR. PRESIDENT, IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER BUSINESS, THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I KNOW THIS
HAS BEEN A LONG DAY. AFTER A
LONG WEEK. HERE'S THE GOOD
DEFINITE NEWS. WE FOR SURE ONLY
HAVE TWO MORE DAYS LEFT. SO
FANTASTIC WORK TODAY WE
ACCOMPLISHED 43 ASSEMBLY BILLS,
64 SENATE BILLS, A TOTAL OF 107.
WE WILL HAVE APPROXIMATELY 70
ISH ASSEMBLY BILLS AFTER TODAY
TO BE ABLE TO COMPLETE OVER THE
NEXT 48 HOURS. WE CONTINUE TO
SEE OUR SENATE BILLS COMING BACK
FROM THE ASSEMBLY. WE'LL BE
TAKING THOSE UP TOMORROW AS
WELL, WITH A PRETTY HEFTY
CONSENT CALENDAR TOMORROW
MORNING. MEMBERS WILL BE BACK IN
AT 10 A.M. TOMORROW MORNING, 10
A.M. TOMORROW MORNING. UNTIL
NEXT TIME, WE'LL SEE YOU.
FRIDAY, AUGUST 30TH, 2024 AT 10
A.M. MEMBERS. THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED. WE'LL RECONVENE
TOMORROW, FRIDAY, AUGUST 30TH AT
10 A.M.